I'm really stupid.
Welcome back to Ultra Wild's Echoes of the Eye.
You guys, my brain is so small!
Oh no!
Oh no.
Some illustration is too, thank you.
too.
Tadaiima.
Yeah!
Oh.
Why do you say that?
Because I've been thinking...
Well, okay.
I'll be honest.
I haven't been thinking about it all week.
But I've been thinking pretty consistently.
Like, how do I solve this?
Next puzzle.
I have no idea!
I don't know.
So, um, we're getting endurance today.
Let's see how far we can get.
Hopefully finish.
We'll see.
As long as my brain is capable.
Probably.
Does Mint have the ability to think?
Maybe with help from the backseaters?
Yeah, but you guys will probably say no Elp.
You guys will probably say no Elp.
Oh my goodness, my voice is a little hoarse.
That's an elephant.
I was supposed to record the podcast.
Usually, like, stuff like that will help warm up my voice.
Omatara overslept because she's not feeling well.
No Elp.
Please, just a little.
Alp.
Just a little, little Alp.
Please.
A little Alp.
Yay!
Okay, let's just get started.
Because we can, um, go over some stuff that, uh, that, uh,
the stuff from last week.
Why am I lagging?
Okay, I think I'm okay.
Hmm.
No elf.
Just elf.
Just a little bit of elf.
Like tiny red.
Okay, so we're here at the stranger for our little recap.
It's been a week.
So the stranger is this ring world.
hidden with a cloaking field.
It's also like trying to get away from the sun.
I think that they know something bad's gonna happen.
And it's not Herthian or Nomayan.
It's scary.
That's all that it is.
We have the reservoir.
There's more to explore here.
We got inside the house eventually.
Wait.
Is it the...
more to explore here.
Enjoy your artist giving you buffs.
I know, right?
Feels like you're rubbing it in Doki's face.
You know, it's all an illusion, basically.
You know, a trick of the eye, a ghostly apparition, a ghost
trick, if you will.
I don't know what jumbly dumblies means, Archer, But I think
it's pretty apt to this, I think.
She shifted the ectoplasm around.
There's the house with the projector in the reservoir you
didn't use yet.
There it is.
Okay.
I found a projection showing the stranger's current
trajectory in the sun's predicted supernova rate.
It's in the summary.
Oh my gosh, I can't.
read the summary.
I'm feeling summary FOMO.
AI summary FOMO.
This thing is what I was thinking of.
Wait, hold on.
What does this say?
I found a diagram of a hollow metal structure suspended by
chains.
There is a round hole underneath that appears to be only the
only entrance.
Yeah.
And it's this sealed vault that takes us to the lake.
And we're trying to unlock it.
Maybe?
I guess so.
Poor Doki boy.
Dokeyboard?
Holy moly.
That is so good.
Did you come up with that yourself?
Oh, wow.
I'm missing context.
Why is Doki Bird aboard?
Because she's flat.
That's all.
You know.
Okay, let's see.
The sealed vault.
Which is these things.
And then the things that show how to make it appear and
disappear.
You just go to those things and you'll light it up, baby.
And then I guess we gotta go to them and blow them out.
maybe we'll see what's this side reel yeah okay river okay
hold on which one is the the okay this is the reservoir okay
we're gonna go back there since there's more to explore
river lowlands
this stinking tower is the bane of my existence right now i
found a site no not the secret passage This one.
This, this, this, this, this, this, this has been haunting
me.
The ghost is being haunted.
This has been haunting me.
For, for, for a week.
Two, thank you.
Wait, hold on.
Sorry, I just realized I cannot read.
Oh, hey, you meant I'm ashamed for missing first two
streams.
What?
Don't even be.
worried about that but thank you samu thank you i just
watched the vibe so let's go with this nightmare love you
boss thank you so much this game expands your brain big time
i oh gosh it's this puzzle that's really making me making me
scratch my head a lot oh so that is what we're gonna mean
we're going to focus on everything because we're trying to
cliffside building we haven't been here yet either we
haven't been able to go because the bridge rotted away
hidden gorge but there's nothing else i guess this is the
only wait yeah this is the only place that still has stuff
to explore so let's go there before we oh wait and obviously
in the unknown in the unknown places there's stuff to
explore, which I really don't want to, but you know.
But we still have a place that we can go to that is safe.
I just realized.
Where's the map?
Here.
Yes.
Wait, where is it?
Wait, I locked onto it, didn't I?
Oh, hold on.
I'm getting out.
I'm going over here.
Kopa!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much!
Oh, stranger.
You guys spoiled me.
Oh.
I'm coming in.
Hot.
Maybe.
I'm not locked onto it.
What do you mean?
Wait.
What happened?
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot to lock onto it.
Who is on the thumbnail?
Watashi Minto desu.
What do you mean who's on the thumbnail?
What?
What do you mean by that?
Is it so unbelievable?
Is it so unbelievable that that could not be me on the
thumbnail?
It's called Artistic Liberties.
Everybody.
It's called Artistic Liberty.
Also, Ducky, thanks for the fire, for gift day.
Okay, we already wasted some time, but that's okay.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, I don't want to run into the chandelier.
We're going to roll?
This is a foolproof plan.
You roll, and then that's it.
It's the easiest thing ever.
to the reservoir.
Another masterful somersault landing.
Thank you.
Oh goodness.
I'm already getting nervous.
I'm already nervous.
Wait, oh, we're here.
Okay, nice.
Oh, we're in this entrance.
Never mind.
We're in a completely different place than I thought we
were.
That's okay, though.
Okay.
It would be quite thanks to the bomb, right?
There's a bar shortcut to the left of the hangar.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
There's a shortcut?
I don't think so.
Oh, the elevator, but I...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No worries.
Good, we can just kind of get there.
I like taking the river.
Down, down, down by the river.
Does anyone still remember that game?
Whatever happened to Baldur's Gate.
Okay, we're just going all the way to the end, everybody.
Are we going down or up?
Yes.
You.
It's still big?
Is it?
I never finished it.
I don't know.
Maybe I think it was because, like, for me, I didn't
understand so much because I'm not into...
What do you call?
Into D&D so much.
So there was, like, a lot that I felt like I kind of missed
out on because I was, like, I don't understand some of this
lore.
They kind of throw you into the game and expect you to kind
of understand, like, you know, certain roles and certain...
Okay.
Over here, right?
Let's go over this way.
It's a pretty long game.
Yeah, whoa.
Why is this version of...
Wait, have I not heard this song?
This version of the song?
This sounds kind of different.
Okay!
Oh!
Wait, no, we went in here.
We can't read.
We did go in here.
Wait!
Was it over here?
Did I not go in here?
Can't read.
No, we did go in here.
Wait, what did I make missing?
Now I'm kind of confused.
Hmm.
Moosey moosey.
Oh, taking your lantern.
In here, maybe.
This projector room.
Huh?
Okay.
Maybe in here.
There's a slideshow in there.
Hello?
Oh, no!
Oh, it's okay, though.
We'll just open it back up.
No biggie.
Oh, maybe here?
No, I remember getting baited by this before.
Oh,
gosh, that's scary.
The door to nowhere.
I think that was our first time seeing it.
Actually, flicker like that.
Uh-oh.
We don't have much time.
Well, we have time, but we don't have time.
Let's see, maybe down below.
Wait, is there a down below?
Where could be the projector?
Or the slide?
Sorry, if you guys if I forget something and you're just
like, it's at this place, that's totally okay if you want to
tell me because it's me forgetting, if you remember.
Sometimes my brain is small.
of ambush up.
Thank you!
I can't remember what this one I think it was like
no I can't remember it all but we went in here and this is
where the password is they write it on the walls because
they're just you know really silly about it right there
she's traded brain for thumbnail booba.
I'm like that meme of the girl that like doesn't that picks
up the book or whatever.
I'm the opposite of that meme.
Son, I fire, I fire.
Son, I fire.
Son,
I fire.
Oh, sorry.
No,
I do remember this room.
Kersey!
Thanks for the gifted!
So you turned beamball?
I guess so.
Oh, hello.
What am I missing in this area?
I don't see it in here.
Is it in the other house that we had to go break into?
No, shoot.
Mike Tyson!
I kept it!
Over yonder.
It's near the bait door.
I'm not kidding.
Okay.
I'm trusting you.
I'm trusting you Superfly, Dan Fry.
I'm calling you by your full legal name right now.
I'm calling you by your full legal name.
I thought that there would be something to do with the bait
door, right?
Because it's like, why would else would they, I mean, I
don't know why else they would have it, just to make you
feel a little goofy.
But I don't see anything over there.
See something hanging.
Okay, I'm going to the bait door.
To troll.
Down from the bait door.
No way.
Like in the water.
Down, down, down, down, down by the river?
Oh, yeah, blah, blah.
No elk.
Give him credit if he's right, then.
I absolutely will.
Here we go.
I think I should bring my...
Oh, ah, ah!
I see, I see, I see, I see.
Oh, blah, blah, blah.
You were right!
Superfly Dan Frye!
That was it, that was it, right?
You were right!
Oh my gosh.
I think maybe they could have had it, like, kind of glinting
in the water for dummies like me, you know.
But also, dummies like me should not be playing this game.
Because, you know.
Oh, oh my gosh, Matara Khan!
Oh.
That was fast.
I can see fire.
More fire.
Something's going on in there.
I swear, if this is all that it was...
If this is all that it is...
Oh, the guys.
The deer people.
Oh!
The...
They show up.
They're walking.
They're coming real close.
They're coming close.
Um.
Oh.
Wait.
In the thumbnail of Gengar is a ghost.
Like, mint.
Did mint take over Gengar's body?
Wish that was me.
Stop.
No, I just dressed up as Gengar, obviously.
Okay.
Oh, yes, yes, we knew that.
That...
So they built the thing around Matara Khan.
Wow, they imprisoned her and sunk her in the water.
They were like, see ya!
That's it.
Ship log updated.
Okay.
Hmm.
Nothing for our...
I think it's because we already kind of knew that that was
in there.
So it wasn't like so...
You know, we already knew about the entrance in there.
And we already knew about...
Uh...
thing, so...
Now to explore the scary place!
I don't...
Wait.
We're going in!
We'll go in through here, I guess.
Wait, this is the one...
This is actually probably the area that we need to explore
the least, now that I think about it, but...
Um...
I am gonna, I am, wait.
Does this take us to the tower, though, doesn't it?
Hello.
I'm just gonna...
Yeah, we need to unleash this.
Do we, though?
Do we need to unleash it?
You know what?
I'm just gonna doze off.
Good night.
Wake up.
Oh.
Good night.
Oh, no, no, no, no, good night.
Did I wake up too soon?
Oh, I don't have the artifact!
Oh, shoot.
I don't even remember where to get one.
Maybe...
Oh, she forgore.
I truly did.
I truly forgot about that part.
I'm thinking, you know what, I'm just gonna meditate in the
next loop and then we'll go, we'll start from...
We'll start from scratch.
Near the egg.
So...
Since we already had the bridge explode, I think we'll start
over.
We got what we needed there.
And we shall continue onwards.
I can't believe my eyes played such a trick on me I really
thought it was something disappearing But it was just, I
really thought it was an egg That was like dancing around
But it was Just a water droplet How could I, how could I
gaslight myself so much?
The egg Okay Okay, okay.
A slideshow that shows a strange vault being encased in a
large metal structure and lowered underwater.
Nearly all the slides have been burned and cannot be viewed.
Yeah, it was so useless.
Thank you.
According to the slide reel, a strange vault was encased in
a large metal structure and lowered underwater.
Which we know.
That's what that is.
I feel like they expected you to find this way sooner.
I'm sorry, I'm not playing Subnautica here.
I'm playing, you know, I'm not diving underwater all the
time.
The real egg was the friends we made along the way.
Pro-gast-gastlighter.
Okay.
Which?
I don't remember how to get to which one.
Like, I don't remember how we get to the shrouded woodlands
versus how we get to the starlit cove.
But this cave is very intriguing.
Kindle-it towers at the top of nearby island.
And then the Endless Canyon.
I can't remember how we get to Woodlands is the first one.
I wonder if we're able to get to the cliffside building.
By somehow waking up when we're in this building in the
other world.
If that's how we get to it.
That's what I'm thinking.
But I...
Hidden Vault Seals!
Impossible.
But we need to find this cliffside building.
I suppose I'm imagining it would maybe be in the Endless
Canyon The Endless 8th Canyon Want Elp or no Elp?
I will ask for Elp when I'm like truly Desperate So But I
appreciate it Shrouded Woodlands Okay so this is the first
one Is this the This looks to be the tower Where when we
come out of the tower is this the tower the the one and then
let's go to the endless canyon
what a thumbnail i'm successfully playing youtube you guys
i'm i'm clickbaiting i'm you know doing all that good stuff
say the word if need help thank you
Please clickbait more.
You dirty dirties.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, so where we need to go is, uh, do a little somersault,
foolproof plan.
We need to go to the right side, I believe.
landing.
She knows us so well.
The chat reflects the streamer.
Cute ball!
Thanks for the five gift.
Thank you!
Push, push, push.
Yesterday's thumbnail was top tier, Stummy and Vupa.
Stop!
Oh my goodness.
So easy.
Sometimes less is more you guys you know don't never forget
that happy outer wilds me though thank you
oh whoa okay to the right to the right to the right to the
right to the right to the right this way this way this way
this way okay nice but i don't want to get i don't want to
get sucked up Unless it's this one.
No, no, that's not one.
That's not one.
It needs the symbol.
Love Outer Wilds.
Hope you're enjoying the DLC.
I am!
Thank you!
Grimey?
Okay.
To the right, to the right, to the right, to the right, to
the right, to the right, to the right, to the right, to the
right!
To the right, to the right, to the right, to the right, to
the right, to the right!
I think it's this one.
If not, well, we haven't been here so many times, so I guess
it kind of works out.
Okay, Hell Guy.
Since we haven't been here so many times, I guess it's all
good.
Now I gotta remember where to get an artifact.
Stick.
Uh.
Let's go to the area.
the other side.
Hmm.
Oh.
Wait.
Hmm.
How do I...
How did I get up there before?
Because this doesn't work, right?
Yeah, this one's broken.
Huh?
The other one is not broken.
Oh!
I thought this was one for the boat.
My bad.
I thought this was...
I thought it was one for the boat.
Like, I thought it was one to pick up your boat.
My bad.
Up, please.
Up, up, up ease.
You guys, it's fine.
It's all good.
Everything is fine.
this is definitely like a game though that can be really
difficult to you know you to like orient yourself I only
haven't played it in a week you know but like if you haven't
played it for even longer I can't even imagine how like
difficult it might be to remember things you know oh so this
is the entrance ah this is the entrance through the hole We
know this entrance.
But we don't have to go back in there.
I think we're pretty good.
The DLC is much harder I am.
So far.
I think...
There's a few things that have been stumping me.
But I've gotten some of the other puzzles.
This is the room where they...
They have to burn the...
This has all the ghost matter, though.
Also...
reverse burn?
Let's see, is there anything in here?
Oh wait, uh, we had to go down here, right?
I don't remember where the artifact is, but we'll find it,
I'm sure.
We go here!
Um, um, no!
Wait?
That'll... artifact?
Oh, there's a reel in here.
like maybe we maybe it's in the in the projector room oh
look whoop I think it's usually in like the projector
basement right I believe
What is that?
There's one in here.
Yes!
Okay.
Alright, let's get going.
Like, the panels flicker.
So it either makes me think it's like...
They're like a...
a screen of some sort it's not really a view of the outside
or something i don't know i have no idea and open up please
thank you wait wait oh gosh oh oh i'm over I'm...
I'm so scared!
I'm so scared.
Oh gosh.
Sleepover party.
I miss when we were just a weird cult.
When we were a weird cult, man.
I miss... I miss those days.
Now here, we do know that there's a guy.
okay so maybe
oh i thought i saw something walking what is that down there
must be some more text right okay
no wonder you know when people were like the DLC got too
spooky for me too spooky for me i couldn't complete it i i i
get it i get it i get it i really really get it before i was
just like i don't know how spooky will this get like the
game it wait is this this isn't where the person was singing
though right no it's like how spooky can this get i was like
you know like the whole game before like the original game
was definitely eerie but like scary i didn't think so it
gets worse
My stomach hurts.
This is the first area we came into, even.
When I first...
When we first came to the other world, so...
Okay.
I can't quite remember where all we went.
I remember being too afraid to continue in certain areas.
There is a baby mode if it's too...
scary but i don't want to be a baby oh we haven't seen this
area see look like they seem pretty friendly right they have
their own little music shows and stuff they don't seem so
bad this is where they perform and stuff and when oh oh
extinguish Bad people don't like music.
What are the instruments made of?
Wood?
Right?
Is that an antler?
Maybe they are bad.
I'm curious, though.
What is...
You can say it's a...
spoiler if you um if i can't know but what does turning on
baby mode do because if it's like a huge imp it's a spoiler
okay i'll believe you we have to get in there somehow
because this goes to here and makes a bridge
okay I remember getting grabby grabbed over here right there
I believe um or somewhere oh my god oh that tree just scared
the heck out of me okay yeah we were there before but time
ran out yes yes oh wait this is where we get grabby grabbed
maybe.
Turning on baby mode drastically reduces your speed and puts
it to the ground as babies crawl.
Uh-oh.
I think that was, uh...
Okay, so we do have to go downstairs.
Everything's okay.
Don't worry about it, man.
No need to scream.
Or anything.
Okay, he's still there.
Have to be a little quicker.
Right?
Is this area fine, though?
I think I'll be safe, I think.
I think I'll be safe.
From the water is what I mean.
I think I'll be safe from the water.
Oh, God!
Not from anything else!
I'm...
Okay.
I think I've went through all of this area, but it doesn't
hurt to...
Try again, I'd say.
Doesn't hurt to try again.
What was that?
I want to go to baby mode.
Now that you guys have reminded me, I'm like...
Sounds like a pretty good option.
Not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie.
We just opened.
I thought I just heard a door open.
Oh!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, there's an actual guy there!
Is it a friendly guy?
Surely.
That's why I'm able to conceal my, uh...
Can he hear footsteps?
That's a good question, I wonder.
He's just pacing.
Waiting for death.
Probably.
Only one way to find out.
Is he gonna like run out the door if he sees me?
Be like, I
wanna see him.
But I also, I'm so scared!
I
want to see him.
Okay, let's just continue onwards.
Oh, here.
You won't notice me.
He's not going to come out.
Okay.
We got to go back to the grabby grab.
I got to make a little bit of progress.
Come on.
Uh.
Can't see anything anymore.
They're real.
Just, uh...
Just act like you belong.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
The grabby grab is up there.
I made a fatal mistake.
My bad.
It's, uh...
Here.
Grab it up?
Wait, where is it?
Grab it.
Where is it?
Huh?
Is it here?
I saw it, though.
Do I do it from...
Oh my god.
Keep walking.
What do you mean keep walking?
Um...
He's gonna...
He's gonna see me.
So irian, all right?
Oh my gosh, I really want to see him.
I'm so curious!
What does it look like?
Maybe over here.
Ah!
I found it.
Oh good, it's even like a shortcut, so...
Awesome.
Okay.
Let's see what else can we find in here.
Oh, okay.
Okay, there's some more stuff over here.
Okay, stuff over here, stuff over here.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
This is a horror game.
It might as well be, right?
Where are we going?
Glad I didn't miss the excitement.
Oh, I thought for some reason I read OW's Overwatch.
Skill them, thank you.
Oh, wait, this is the place where the...
Okay, we know where this is because when I do this, the boat
appears.
Ah, this is another way to get on the boat.
Okay, that's good to know, actually.
Because it's not...
I mean, well, it's a little annoying to get here, but it's
not so far out of the way if we ever need to get back on the
boat.
Overwatch is not the most wonderful game.
I mean, to reach the Roan.
I agree with you, but...
This isn't Overwatch?
So that means the tower fell, right?
I believe.
And so we're about out of time.
Wait, but I just made it here!
Wait, what's this?
the tree at the base of a tree is an entrance okay they
really like music
okay what else can I find in here before our demise
I think there's something in here but time's up yep time's
up Do you think they know that they're in a time loop as
well?
These alien creatures?
Their chairs look like toilets.
They look like toilet seats.
Maybe that's how we know we cannot trust them.
Go ask them.
Hey, do you know that you're about to die in like two
seconds?
I think they know.
Open up.
Wonder what this means.
at least found some stuff.
I think this is the end of the road for this area at least,
so we're about to...
Hmm.
It's crooked.
I wish I could fix it.
Oh my gosh.
It's so quiet.
It's so eerie.
Just...
We'll just wait for your Death to take us now.
Hmm.
I prefer it to be quiet.
No way!
It's too scary!
Can we go back to the boat?
I'm scared.
Hmm.
I wonder what else it's gonna say about this area.
You're yapping got me through my masters!
Oh my gosh, Aaron Haku!
Same time next week, same time next week.
Thank you for the Superjack.
Congratulations!
Here's the four more ears.
Four more ears.
Angel, thanks for the gifted.
Masters.
Not literally... Wait.
I found a mural of a large tree at the bottom floor of the
lodge.
Oh, that really is everything there.
Nice.
So curious though, what if I go back and I have my lantern
on right by the guy?
Ooh, I want him to see me!
I'm so curious.
Okay, but that area has been explored.
So very cool, very cool.
Do it?
You want to trigger Alert 100?
I kind of do.
Okay, we're going to go do it.
What's the easiest way to get there?
I'm trying to think of the easiest way to get there.
What's the worst that could happen?
But it's also kind of a pain in the butt to get all the way
over there, isn't it?
Well, we'll just go to the other area.
is fine.
We'll go to the other areas.
The hole gets you straight to that area.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, but the hole is such a pain in the butt to get into.
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, where's...
Ah, ah, oh.
Hello.
My bad.
Which hole?
It's like a, it's like a little hole in the the ship yeah I
literally was just like the hole brings us there perfect I'm
sure it's fine sure it doesn't need any I think I think it's
okay it's just a little scratch raiders oh my gosh thank you
thanks for the raid I didn't see who raided ray mag thanks
for the gifted wait thank you so much
Sorry, I've been gaming.
Hello, hello.
We're playing Outer Wilds, which is a spooky...
Well, it's not a spooky game, but this is a very spooky DLC.
So if you're not good with spooky things...
Oh, I remember what to do here.
If you're not good with spooky things, viewer discretion...
Happy Tuesday.
Murphy, thanks for the five-gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Tomorrow, I have...
I have karaoke.
If you want to watch that, I'll have karaoke, and then right
after I'm going to play Doom.
Early, early in the morning.
I'm kind of worried, because early, early in the morning, I
have to...
I'm taking my cat to the vet.
getting him an ultrasound
so I'm going to be up super duper early to do that and then
artifact and then streaming two time and then I have stuff
that I'm doing at night so it's just a lot of craziness
tomorrow this whole week it's been a little crazy busy for
me the one no this is not the one that's missing a person
look at how creepy this is our this is our cult friends this
guy is even like you can't be hiding stop get your fingers
off of there
don't hide the light okay let's take those off hope it turns
out to be a good day man thank you give our thank you got my
postcard today i'm happy to say both of your faces were in
mint condition Who's the boing boing mint cosplayer in the
thumbnail?
Stop!
What are you talking about?
They're average!
This is the one where we get on the boat, isn't it?
Am I...
I think we can get on the boat or we can go somewhere else,
but somewhere else sounds really scary and the boat sounds
like a lovely location to be in.
The boat sounds like a really lovely location.
And everywhere else sounds not so lovely and nice.
The boat sounds really comfortable.
And everywhere else sounds really scary that I don't like
it.
Which, I know this is not the direction of the boat, so I'm
a little frightened.
What is this?
Oh.
Where is this going?
Actually.
It's not that I think about it.
I have no idea.
Is this where I think, um...
I was going to say, I think this is where we saw someone
walking around.
And there, they were down there!
I saw a light moving!
I saw a light moving.
I don't know.
Is that where we're headed?
Please say no.
This is an egg.
No, it is very much not a figment of my imagination.
It is very much real.
I'm most afraid that it allows you to extinguish the lights
here.
That's what terrifies me the most.
I'm brave.
Oh, that's the electricity.
Oh, oh, oh, the controller just vibrated a little bit.
Okay, so this doesn't really lead to anywhere, actually.
Unless it's this direction.
Oh god.
I'm being brave, I'm being brave, I'm being...
I'm being brave, I'm being brave, I'm being brave.
It's to save the candle.
Yeah!
Oh!
Wait, what is this?
Guys, I don't think I'm as brave as I think I am.
No!
I think I'm as brave as I think I am.
I'm just scoping out the area.
I think I'm actually gonna...
I think I'm actually gonna pee myself.
Is true happiness throwing bricks at me?
What are you talking about?
It's a...
He's down there, you see him?
Oh, that's close?
Wait, is he a zombie?
No way.
Wait, this is where the show is.
Wait, I kind of want to go see the show.
I can't see anything.
I don't know, like, oh my god, there's two of them!
Are they zombie, guys?
There's two of them, there's two of them.
I don't know, like, what their range is, is what I meant to
say.
I think I almost said hitbox.
I don't know what their range is.
ranges.
I can't tell where the other guy went.
Oh, this is true.
Oh, no, wait, they're gonna see me.
Where'd he go?
Where'd the other guy go?
We saw him.
There were two of them.
Extinguish.
Um, I literally can't see anything, though.
Holy cow, it's so dark.
Just watching his Oshi, don't disturb him.
Okay.
I don't see anyone else, so...
Whoa, just kidding.
I just...
Unless it was a star.
Unless it was a shining star in the sky.
No, there he is!
There he is!
There's one guy, and I think the other guy is leaving.
Huh.
I love hearing mint in the background with screams.
The artifact is just an alien pen light.
Jesus.
I'm further away from the place, but I think we have to
go...
I heard a whistle.
I'm gonna get caught for sure, you guys.
I'm gonna get so caught.
I'm gonna get caught for sure.
sure.
I just got grabby-grabbed.
And I think I...
Actually, I think I need to go back over there.
Wait, so I've been here because these candles are lit up.
Right?
Where am I crazy?
Have I been here?
No.
Maybe?
Huh?
Where am I?
Shortcut!
Ah.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them!
They're all going for, the show has ended though.
You guys are late.
Nah, they're going for Bupan.
They're going to go see their Oshi.
They're gonna go get goods merch and stuff.
But I know that if I don't hurry up, the bridge is gonna
break and...
I won't be able to get there at all.
There it is!
Ah!
Our flame's gonna go out!
Oh no!
That was too slow, but can you blame me?
Okay, I'm gonna run up to him.
Dang.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Well, we know where we need to go there.
It's just, um...
Yikes.
Oh, gosh.
Sorry for being so slow.
You guys, I'm just scared!
I'm scared!
So close.
And all right.
Okay.
Let's go to the tower.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, dang it.
Oh, that, that, that, that, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Small steps, you've got this.
I just don't know how far away they'll notice me as all.
So that's why I'm, I'm such an, I'm overly cautious all the
time, you guys.
Because if I'm not overly cautious, it never works in my
favor.
I just came here from, you know, stream hello i was watching
her stream earlier too gosh she is such a oh my god her
singing i was like thinking the first time i heard her sing
i was like all i want to hear um is her do a cover of of um
what's it called whoa ho no that's snake eater but that too
voice.
It's so awesome.
Sins of the Father!
Yes, thank you.
Yes, I want to hear her cover.
Sins of the Father.
This is where, like, this area is down there.
But the boat doesn't go over there.
You think we can make it if we jump?
I don't think so.
So I have such tiny legs.
I'm a small, small alien.
But yeah, if anybody's coming in.
This is DLC of a game.
And we're kind of like in the middle of it.
So if you don't stick around, that's all good.
But if you want to watch from the beginning.
That's good too.
Yes, this is where the hole is.
I'm going to jump.
Oh.
It was like the eggs and bacon alarm.
For real.
Can't, can't.
I guess I'll go back in.
I think...
I don't think we have so much time left, but...
I'll try again.
I think we can make it this time.
issue right who we but we know we know that there are guys
walking around in here as well thanks for over two months
may help your well thank you thank you gin gin thank you so
much
we know they're walking around in here oh why aren't you
going to the show
wait so this this we know this one has an alarm down here i
remember the alarm down here but i think if i just keep my
thing off wait is it over here
i think if i
okay here we go
i literally can't see anything
i could see the night sky and that's about it.
I can see black.
You can see the night sky?
Oh, that's planet?
I think I'm going the right way.
Oh, this way.
I can't tell if I turned around or not.
I can't tell anything.
What's that?
Wish.
Oh, I'm right next to it.
I thought it was a cross.
Oh.
Hmm.
Cool.
Uh, what's this way?
Maybe it's a bad idea to head towards the light, but...
A steerable boat.
Yeah, you're...
Whoa.
This place is really...
Is this like...
what's a called place where they had all the worship of the
eye oh don't fall in so it's there's also an equivalent here
what's this oh no no please no I just got here
oh my goodness Um, how do I get out of here?
Let me out, please.
Oh, we're just about...
I didn't hear a screech this time.
Oh!
What the?
What is this?
Oh, wait.
This is to get inside.
Just kidding.
There is a screech.
Just kind of faded.
Oh.
Okay, hello!
There we go.
So we were over there technically.
Kind of.
We...
Trying to think of where...
Is this the...
This is the place that I'm trying to wake up in.
right here, I believe.
I believe that's what I think I have to do.
Because I think I have to wake up here.
Oh, I dread welcome the membership, thank you.
Because I'm assuming this is like a one-to-one creation of
their world, right?
I mean, that would make sense.
And so we were here because we came from here.
We went this here, right?
Maybe, I don't know.
Why is everyone saluting?
You'll see in like maybe one minute.
Oh, wow.
Some stuff is the same.
Where is the sun anyway?
Uh.
Hello?
You could have definitely given me more time in there.
Tower.
The AI summary just called you blind.
Nandakto.
I
know you can see the sun.
Actually, okay, hold on.
You can see the sun and stuff at the very beginning when you
enter it.
But remember we got that diagram of the planet thing moving
away?
So I wonder if we've been moving this whole time, like, away
from the sun.
But then why do we die?
A dense forest along the banks of a river.
I heard music coming from a candlelit building across the
water.
Found a covered bridge leading to the darkest part of the
forest.
Wait, it doesn't say that there's, like, anything else to
see here.
So...
But I'm so curious what's going on in the building.
because the ash twin project sends the information back in
time and it gets destroyed
yes okay yes ash twin project always sends your memory back
okay that makes that yes oh whoop uh this one a secluded
village nestled within a cove a candlelit tower sits atop a
I found the remains of a burned out building on the
outskirts of the village.
There's more to explore here.
But there's not more to explore here.
So...
Don't trust the logs.
There are a bunch of logs that don't trigger more to
explore.
Dang it.
So you're telling me I have to go to the show?
I have to be brave.
I don't know what you're saying!
But let's go back here to the tower.
Because I'm quite curious about...
Wait.
Hold on, how did we get there?
I'm already losing it.
Okay.
I'm curious what you just missed.
I'm curious about so many things.
I'm curious about everything that's going on.
There's more to explore here.
It is very scary, though.
Okay, maybe I should go back.
Okay, I'm going to try the show.
I'm going to try the show.
Oh, God.
You guys, I'm scared, though.
I'm scared.
But I'm scared.
I'm scared to try this show.
Oh, oh, oh, there we go.
See, we can see the sun right now.
I think we're moving.
I think this thing is like saying saiyonara to everywhere.
Be brave, Minto.
Can I turn on baby mode?
How is turning on baby mode?
A spoiler.
If...
Oh, whoops.
You could do it from the very beginning.
You know?
That's all my questions.
No babies here.
There is!
I'm a big baby!
Goo goo goo gaga.
I've returned to baby.
Knowing what it does is a spoiler.
This is so messed up.
This is so messed up of you all.
You can't know what the baby mode does because it's a
spoiler.
Too bad you're so afraid.
Then how do I know what I'm turning?
I wouldn't even know what I'm turning off.
Thank you.
My mantra to be brave is what's the worst that can happen
and it'll be less scary the second time.
That is true.
It'll be less scary the second time.
I don't believe in what's the worst that can happen though
because I don't know.
I don't want to get jump scared.
Jeffrey!
We needed to make people aware of it so that they knew what
they were getting into.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Also, yes, the way it works is a spoiler.
Stop!
Jeffrey!
Oh, gosh.
I'm so scared.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Um, there was, like, a hand.
There was a grabby grab.
Is it this way that goes to the grabby grab?
No.
This is...
Wait, I went to the right place, right?
Yeah.
Say hi to them.
What's the worst?
You die?
That's all right.
I've already...
I've already gone through that once.
We'll tell you once you're ready to know.
Okay.
No, don't open that.
Because we're not going on the boat.
Oh, wait.
I could go on the boat.
No.
I don't think I can.
I don't think I can go on the boat, actually.
Because it doesn't stop.
By.
Yeah, there it is over there.
Okay.
Where's the grabby grab?
But we'll start seeing them.
We'll start seeing them, alright.
Be brave, meinto.
Not really that brave, you guys.
You seem to mostly fear the unknown.
I fear a lot of the...
I just... I fear, Murphy.
I fear.
I can't find the grabby grab, so I might have to just do...
Wait a second.
Did I see...
Oh no, this is where we went.
Yeah.
I just fear!
There they are.
They're walking.
They're already heading over.
Uh, wait.
Here we go.
Do you think they'll see me from over here?
Do you fear me now?
Never.
Wow.
I can't tell if they're...
Oh, I just felt my...
controller rumble which means that like whatever thing that
happens here just happen okay they're gone
they're not gone i think you'll see me look at him wow
they see me walking so they know they they think i'm a one
of them right They think I'm one of them, probably.
Oh, boy.
You're kind of short.
Act natural.
I'm acting natural.
I'm just gonna have to follow him, I think.
As I say, there's no fear, but the fear of tigers.
Has she made any progress in A?
Dude, I have made progress!
What are you talking about?
I've made progress, right guys?
I think I'm on their pathway.
Uh-oh.
Time to go.
Don't fall too close behind me.
Okay, here we go, here we go.
I'm one of you guys.
Hey!
You rude!
I was here for the show!
I just wanted to see you!
Not invited.
Oh my god!
You finally did so good!
Thank you!
Didn't buy a ticket.
Yeah they're really cute actually!
I thought something scarier would happen.
They were really confused, though.
They were like, um...
What the hell?
They were really confused, I think.
Can I go back?
You think they'll let me in this time?
Hey, I'm back, man!
Private party.
Literally, the jazz music stops me.
I think they'll let me in.
this time or but like I don't think there's anything I can
really explore in there because they'll they're gonna be
what they're just gonna get me again so I think I have to go
past and go to the next floor
I'm just one of you guys I'm just one of you guys
I don't remember where the entrance was uh oh I'm gonna get
got don't get me please I'm one of you guys come into your
meeting I have your little candle and everything okay
they're just jealous I'm alive
mm-hmm breathe on their lantern that's so messed up
you are alive in the game sorry you know
Oh, I forgot.
All right, to the tower, we go.
Oh, geez.
Weird.
Okay, to the tower we go, everybody.
Oop, oop, oop, oop, oop, okay.
Let's get around this little tree here.
There is that other tree.
actually has like I haven't seen like such a tree here
mysterious everything is so mysterious oh I was trying to
avoid this rock but you know okay
unless wait it was hold on it was in this tower wasn't it no
I don't know Like, where we saw it, is what I mean.
Is this one right?
Yep.
What was in the tower?
The, um, the mural that we saw.
But maybe I'm misremembering.
You mean the tree?
The tree mural, yeah.
Okay, good night.
So now that I know that they're not going to be so mean to
me, They were so confused.
They were just staring like They were so confused.
That's kind of funny.
Oh yeah, here we can go.
That's right.
Ignore you.
there was the burnt house down here fear conquered wouldn't
quite say that but you know I'm doing my best okay let's try
and go to the left side this time
I know from here that I can okay I think we're good let's
try going wait well let me go I don't think... I think I can
only steer it back and forward this way and this way.
Yeah, so I can't, like, take it to another spot.
Just imagine a random alien showing up in a...
We're all just staring at me.
Okay, so we're back here at the burnt mural.
Anything else here of significance?
We had this thing up here.
The boat is on rails.
Ah, that makes sense.
before.
It's like it's almost like a binocular.
There's nothing else over here, actually.
I'm looking around.
No!
Hmm.
Yeah, binoculars.
Kip's wanting to say magnifying glass.
magnifying glass for far things away but I can't use it too
short too short okay whatever I think that's the only stuff
over around here oh maybe possibly okay there is something
else there is
Smelloscope.
There's something else here?
You were just by it, I was?
Who?
Blind Minto.
I keep almost falling into the water.
This thing.
Ah!
I didn't realize it could open.
Oh!
What?
What does this mean?
This tiny flower.
is producing well I say tiny this flower is producing
galaxies
okay what yeah see there's the eye symbol so yeah they also
liked that it's really interesting that these guys have the
same symbol for the eye and then no my also have the same
symbol for the eye I find that a little little fascinating.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, yeah,
don't leave, don't leave.
Very convenient.
I don't know if convenience the word, but, you know.
Yeah, I can't go any further because of this rock.
Is this the thing that goes off?
Here we go.
Nice.
Well, then.
explore as much more that we can before we get kicked out.
There's a hand.
Yeah, let's go to the other side.
I can't remember exactly everything that we hit on this
area.
But I do know how...
I do want...
I do know we need to get down there.
Huh.
Oh, that's where we came from.
Oh.
Maybe that's how we get down there.
Wee!
Okay.
Loop done.
Let's go meditate.
Let's meditate.
You know what?
We'll meditate in the water.
always so spooky how the world turned sideways before waking
up I know right so funny I gotta go to the bathroom and I'm
gonna go check on my cat if that's okay with you guys um
he's been eating a little bit more so but I've just been
checking on him he's been mostly kind of laying under the
bed um so I've just been kind of leaving him alone.
I have...
I have a doctor's appointment for him tomorrow.
And I...
How can I give you some...
music before I go fishing?
I don't want to waste the time.
You know what?
I'll just waste the time.
You guys can have the music.
And the ASMR.
And then we'll just reset.
When I'm back.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Okay, I fed him.
And I went to the bathroom.
And I forgot to get more tea.
So I'm going to go get more tea.
And then I'll be back for realsies.
Then I'll be back for realsies.
Okay, all right, give me like, give me like two more
minutes.
Winky spanky.
Okay, who's going to win?
What are you talking about?
Okay, you guys.
What's going on?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, I went into, uh, into, what's the word mode?
There we go.
Okay.
Meditate.
Welcome back, boys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you winning, Mint?
I think so.
Mint was cheating by peeking at a walkthrough.
Okay, I'll be, I'm gonna have a hundred percent transparency
here.
I didn't look at a walkthrough.
But I asked a friend to look at a walkthrough.
I was like, okay, can you look at a walkthrough and just
give me a hint?
Don't tell me the answer.
Just do it.
Just look at the...
And they didn't.
If anything, they really...
They were just like, I don't know where you're at.
I was like, no, just like...
I was like, just look for...
I was like...
Look for something that says the hidden vault seal.
And they were like, I don't know.
I can't, I can't find anything.
So I was like, don't, don't tell me the answer.
Just give me like a one word hint.
What I should do.
And so, Mint that's cheating.
I didn't get any help.
So, you know, let's go back to the Starlet Cove.
I give up on the show.
For now, at least.
I want to have more time at the cove.
She tried to cheat.
No, I didn't try to cheat.
I just wanted a little hint because you guys weren't giving
me anything.
You guys wouldn't give me anything.
I'm so...
I'm so lost.
We're going to be here all day.
That's okay.
We're gonna be here all day, you guys.
All day.
I have to wake up so early for my cat, but you guys don't
care.
You're just like, no help.
You guys are like, doesn't matter.
No help.
To the tower, to the tower.
Ask chat
The hint is Explore more Oh, that's what I'm doing We're
going to the tower To explore some more
Since I also don't have this Well, I maybe I'm not going to
say anything Because I will eat my words You know what,
never mind I'm just going to shut up Just going to shut up
Oh, the artifact Oh, oh, I I think we can get one over here
as well.
Right?
Oh, wait, no, I don't think we can.
Oh, you guys, I think I just messed up.
Wait, I think I just remembered that there's no artifact.
Yeah, there's no artifact here, is there?
Oh.
Okay, we're going to another place.
There's one in the tower hidden room.
Just kidding, we're not going to another place.
Turn around, turn around.
Oh, the water is too strong.
Wait, the water's really strong here.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
I think slowly but surely we can do it.
Come on.
Come on team.
Team team team.
There we go.
Power, power, power.
Power, power, power, power, power.
Power.
This way, this way.
Slowly but surely we're making it.
I don't know if we can make it.
Whatever.
secret room
wait it's not which secret room the one down there did i get
one guide did i get one guide for realsies did you just one
guy me
why are you spreading lies on the internet What?
Why are you spreading lies?
The meditative shame.
Why are you spreading lies on the internet?
How could you do that?
How could you say that and then feel good about yourself?
That's what you get for reading chat.
I don't think it's very...
Okay, come on.
I don't think it's...
Telling me where an artifact is is not the same as telling
me how to...
do a puzzle!
It's completely different.
To the stranger.
Whoa, we're moving sideways.
Me after spreading misinformation to a VTuber.
I just inconvenienced the streamer.
I just made it so that the streamer had to do something and
then go out of their way.
And then it didn't matter in the end.
I just disrupted the stream and i made my mark in this
stream forever i just disrupted the streamer and they're
angry about it i just made them angry perfect
i think the streamer is gonna have a horrible day after this
i think the streamer is gonna think about this all night
streamer is gonna be thinking about me and how much i Give
them the wrong information.
I think I'm going to do it again next week.
You.
Your inconvenience is nourishment.
Get in there.
There we go.
Oh, Minecraft rules.
Real laugh.
Oh my goodness.
There we go.
Okie dokie.
Hop!
Alright.
Let's get out of here.
Skadaddle-addle.
She's so obsessed with me now.
Give the streamer wrong information once.
We'll be obsessed with you forever.
Wait.
Oh!
This way.
Or going to the tower.
I don't feel like going to the show anymore.
I have to go back to the show though, don't I?
Eventually I have to go back to the show.
Uh...
This is a terrible place to leave!
Okay.
No stop, please.
Um...
Push...
You got it.
Oh!
No!
This way.
I like when the music starts back up, like I know I'm doing
something correct.
Okay.
No, no, no.
That's fine.
Just get me out of here.
What is wrong with this boat?
It's defective.
And don't say it's the driver.
It's the driver.
Should I say not?
It's the captain.
Stop.
It's the streamer.
It's the steersman.
There's still this whole... Wait a second.
of something else.
My bad.
Okay.
Good night, everybody.
I feel really like we're all close friends now.
But they're not zombies at all.
They were very much alive guys.
They looked pretty cute.
Just like the pictures.
Also, how do we get down here?
Hmm.
Yeah, I thought they were pretty cute.
You didn't think so?
Okay.
Also, when I jumped from here, the alarm went off.
So we're going to have to not get caught again.
We're going to have to be sneaky about the boat controls.
In IT, we have an acronym for Common Bug.
Hebbkack.
Problem is, it exists because chair and keyboard.
Oh, what are you trying to say, huh?
You think he's in here?
So then, what are you trying?
to say there's a thing there okay they're probably like hey
man you can't open up the the thing i'm like being such a
nuisance here oh i thought i would open the door i'm being
such a nuisance here being like i'm just gonna open your
safe that you uh clearly don't want people using they're
like hey don't do that i'm like too bad I'm gonna do what I
want.
I'm an alien.
Hold on.
There was another light.
Let me light that one too.
Let's see what happens.
Oh.
Oh, my controller just rumbled.
So I believe that electricity thing just happened.
She forgore.
What did I forgore?
I don't have, like, my little guy anymore.
Hmm.
I don't have my little scout anymore to shoot through.
She knows she just doesn't remember.
I don't remember.
Does anyone want to give me a...
She forgore what she forgore.
I did, I did, actually.
I don't remember at all.
What did I forgore?
No, elf, but it's something I knew before!
This is so unfair.
Why are you guys like this?
I already knew.
Are these the flowers?
What is...
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Because the light...
The door is always open when there's no light.
I remember.
Ooh.
Shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up.
Wait a second.
Oh my god.
Tower stuff.
Oh my
god.
We're finally here.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god.
Is this where?
Oh, this is really, really tall.
There's not going to be anywhere.
in here, though, right?
I think I have to extinguish these.
Good night, sweet prince.
Oh, oopsie.
I think I extinguish these and then I go back to the other
world.
But also, what's up here?
Oh, it's just the same.
Yeah.
Look at you guys.
Drawing things with sunlight.
Wait, what did that say?
Oh, drop artifact.
No, we're good.
Okay.
So that's how you get here.
I cheesed this part.
What do you mean you cheese this part?
How do you cheese this?
How do you cheese this at all?
But now we have the seals, right?
But hold on, before we jump into the water, I have something
I want to do.
To a flip!
Hold on!
Oh, here.
There is something else on this side.
Is it a boat?
Okay.
This.
Does this create a boat?
It does.
Okay, never mind.
I don't need no boat.
Okay.
Mint changed your name?
I changed my name?
Who am I now?
Wait, no, I'm Mint though.
I'm Mint though!
What do you mean?
I changed my name.
Okay, I think we have to um...
Yeah!
Good morning gamers!
All right, see you suckers.
I don't know why I can't jump out there, but I can't jump
here.
Okay, into the secret tunnel.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, we're gonna get the passwords, right?
Maybe.
And then, where, what location was it?
To unlock?
Oh, it was inside the thing.
Yeah, inside the bell, inside the bell.
Okay.
Open!
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Wow!
Thank you.
Open.
Oh, come on!
No, no, no, no!
You guys suck!
Oh.
Whoa, we're leaning, we're leaning, guys, we're leaning.
Wait, which one was this one for?
Oh, wait, we've been here.
This one, though.
We know this cave.
We know, this, it did a ship log, but I'm screencapping it,
too.
I'm screencapping it so that when we go back to the cave, I
know what to do.
Okay, take a picture.
Okay.
New info!
Can we even make it there, though?
Oh, you sons of...
This is fine.
This is good.
This is fun.
This is fun, everybody.
This is okay.
I told you.
We're literally just messing up the...
They're like, hey, we really...
Like, it's bad...
It's bad, bad news bears if anybody messes with, uh...
If anybody messes with this thing and I'm just like I don't
care and I do it anyway.
Oh wait, I can see the sun from here still.
Hmm, interesting.
I thought we wouldn't be able to see the sun anymore.
Okay, um, let's go.
Down, down, down by the river.
It was...
Here, right?
This is where the cave is at.
I need that.
I need that boat.
Do you think we can make it?
Yeah, we can make it.
Oh, oh, oh.
I can make it.
Oh, I'm trapped in the boat.
Hold on.
Boat, boat, boat, boat, boat.
Boat.
There we go.
Nice.
Go, go, go.
Cave was at the third area.
This area right here, then?
Instead?
This one?
No.
That's not this one, is it?
I mean, we can check.
We're right here.
Oh, the right side?
Are you sure?
Oh, yeah!
Okay, we're gonna loop.
We're gonna loop around.
Because...
I do want to try and get this if we can.
We have a little extra time.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Oh, wait!
Wait, too much push, push!
Mm-mm-mm-mm.
Because...
I'd like to...
Try and get it.
We're making progress, guys.
We're making progress.
Push, push.
Yeah, this is the one that has the little...
the artifact thing.
Appreciate you guys pushing me in the right direction.
Eek!
When I...
Light!
Come back, vote!
Okay, when I need it.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
To the right.
That way.
Artifact?
It's right here.
We got him.
Don't worry.
We got him right here.
Actually, I'm going to hold on to him just in case we lose
our boat for some reason.
Okay.
Stop your being too pushy.
That's what you're supposed to.
That's what...
she means push that's what that's exactly what oh she means
a push okay
we got this we got this we got this oh
yeah oh oh yeah go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go this way this way i don't even know if
we can get inside it anymore because everything's destroyed
but oh the elevator might work be okay.
Uh.
The elevator!
The elevator might work.
Still.
I think it works.
Yeah!
We're fine!
Let's see.
Uh, oh.
I missed my...
Wait.
I'm gonna Oshi my Oshi off this road.
We're a little...
Getting a little violent here.
That's okay.
You're just excitable, I get it.
Now getting over to the other side...
Getting over to the other side is...
I think we can make it.
Here we go.
Nice.
Big flip.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now, what's so curious about this part is...
I don't remember...
Anything that looked like...
I'm...
Oh, here...
I just never went over to the side.
Wait a second!
Oh!
This is how you get over here!
This whole time we could have done it so easily!
Stop.
It's not done yet, right?
No, no, no.
I just made it here, please.
Please, I just made it!
Please!
No, please!
Hold on, I'm pulling up my picture.
Resume, resume, resume.
Okay.
Use the interface.
This one!
Down!
Saturn!
You!
Down!
Star!
What's going on?
What's happening?
Oh, an elevator.
Lift it.
No, no, no, no, no!
I just made it here, please!
Go down, go down!
updated wait what is this what does this mean
okay we still have a couple of seconds oh I'm getting hurt
wait what's happening oh I'm just in the light that's what
it is
updating updating updating updating updating updating
What does... Ha?
Ha?
In past loops you looked at the ghosts matter and instantly
assumed you couldn't get past.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
Oh, there's a thing even here!
I'll come back.
Next round!
We'll come back everybody.
Unless.
No, we don't have time.
There it is.
I'm right at the top It's kind of fun
Hmm But now we can get there so easily I'm wondering I used
I can probably bring the artifact Now that I know how to get
around the ghost matter So
Good loop everybody
Nice See good?
Yeah I'll put some of my throat stuff This was yummy.
Oh la la la la la.
Wow!
Holy moly!
Secret!
A map I found in the abandoned temple reveals a secret
location.
Somewhere within the stranger.
Oh, but you're not gonna show me?
Okay, we're gonna have to go screenshot those points, I
think.
Oh wait, here we go.
Thank goodness.
Projection that seems to reveal a secret location within the
stranger.
Yep.
Too much progress for the voice.
Secret...
Oh, secret location.
Symbol room.
A secret room filled with wooden containers marked with
different symbols.
Three of the containers are marked with glowing vault seals,
but their contents have been burned away.
I opened the container marked the symbol of...
a burning slide reel and found a vertical sequence of
symbols inside yep and then we use that oh and we oh they
all say the same thing i'm just trying to i reach the
tower's upper floors by projecting a path to a second
entrance at the back of the tower
an abandoned temple marked with the symbol of a burning
slide reel it can be accessed from a passage in the hidden
gorge there is an interface upstairs that can be used to
line up symbols sequence there is oh oh that's how we that's
how we did the okay yes that's how we did the the elevator
duh entering the correct sequence opens a path to a secret
room beneath the temple there was some stuff upstairs I
guess that's what we didn't get and then we have all these
secret locations to go to so Well, that's exciting.
Yippee.
Yippee, yippee.
Okay.
I will not make this mistake again.
And the slide reel.
Yes, the slide reel, thank you.
Yes, we need that.
That probably is what this thing is remaining, right?
So we'll go look at the slide reel.
We'll go there first, for sure.
And I think since we'll be there, I'm gonna...
You can kind of see them in the logs, but since we won't
have...
I won't memorize them.
And since we won't have the ship, I'll just...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna screenshot them.
Hello, I would like to do a tumble.
Okay.
Awesome!
I know that there's like an easier way to get there, but I
really didn't want to go through the little hole.
It's kind of obnoxious, so.
And I can't...
Well, actually, I guess we could always...
Oh, I'd have to open it.
It's fine.
Everything's fine, you guys.
It's all good.
I like the river.
Me too!
I like the river also.
Okay.
Okay, uh, I'm gonna grab the artifact just in case I need
it.
Um, because this is probably the easiest one to get, so...
Well, I'm playing along with my own spooky game right now.
And this DLC is spooky!
We really hit a fun point in the game, though, I believe in
a smith.
Baby's got this.
We got this!
Thanks, Carl!
Oh, wow.
Yeah, it's good to just grab it, I think.
And have it on hand.
The boat is...
I sew coat.
Baby's strong.
This is Baby Nation.
Babies rise up.
Babies?
If you're a baby, say go-go-go-go-go.
All my babies in the chat!
Go, go, go, go!
All my boobies in the chat!
Yeah!
Go, go, go, go!
Gosh, I really can just get you guys to say anything, can't
I?
Oh my god, look at all these eggs!
Baby maxing.
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, this way, this way, this way.
This way, this way.
Yes, streamer.
You take me for a fool.
I take you for a baby.
Gugu gaga.
Gugu gaga, TL, garbage.
I don't think that's what a baby would say.
Don't be unrealistic.
Only realism in my streams, please.
Thank you.
I don't want to set some weird standards for babies.
I want milk.
Maybe talk to your mom about that.
This is the ghost of easy, but ghosts are real, and I'm
proof of it, obviously.
Do you sometimes think of your wisps as your babies?
once.
I've never ever once even thought that.
But that's okay.
I've never once thought, aw, my little precious babies.
Only realism.
Ah!
Ghost!
Get the Exorcist!
No!
I'm a good ghost.
It's diaper?
This is the projection room, right?
So we'll have to come back here.
to see that.
Oh, I was like, what is down there?
Literally where we just came from.
So they stopped.
They were like, abandoned the eye.
We don't believe in the eye anymore.
We believe in the burned reels.
They were like, the eye sucks.
Screw the eye.
It's burned reels time.
That's where it's all...
I thought I remembered.
Anyway.
we're fine
um yeah burned reels is where it's at everybody okay i like
the music here it's very cool
dog oh look at that oh how handy there's a shortcut it.
Glad I checked up here.
Okay, use the interface.
You, Saturn, you, you.
What's happening again?
Oh, we're gonna need the real.
Oopsie.
It's fine, though.
Okay, let's pick up the lanterns.
Oh.
This doesn't really help that much either, though.
Does it?
There was, like, a better one.
A better way to see.
Hold on.
Probably through the, through here.
We'll see it better, right?
Let's hold on.
You want to screenshot these?
Give me one second.
We're going to have to come back for the, uh, for the
artifact anyway.
Hmm.
Insert.
And let's go get this guy right here.
Signal scope can zoom.
Oh, you're so right.
Then we'll do that.
Just give me one second.
Let's look at this first.
Because it might give us a also zoomed in on here.
And so if it dies, we can just screenshot it from here.
Oh.
Worship.
Oh, they sink it.
Then they look at the camera.
Look at that one guy is really happy.
Oh.
This is, like, not your best angle, but that's okay.
They're like, yeah!
Screw the eye!
We're going to go burn all these!
Erase history!
He's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's got to be a method to our madness.
This one?
Wait, what the hell is this?
They're sinking the egg.
It's saved.
Oh!
I think they...
Save the information, maybe?
Unarchived karaoke's Deletes browser history.
Nah!
Okay.
Okay, interesting.
So where the hell do we find that thing?
Maybe that thingamabob is in...
Well, okay, up here.
I can't quite tell what these locations are about.
Are they of that thingamabob?
Or are they of the places where they burn the reels?
Scant Eclipse Channel.
Okay, signal scope, right?
It zooms in way too much.
Because now I'm like, I don't even know what the heck, where
the heck that is.
Okay, hold on.
Is that an egg?
Okay, guys, I think I found the egg for real.
Then back up.
Shut up.
Stop using logic against me, okay?
Stop being sensible.
I don't like that.
I actually have no idea where this is.
Wait, is this like a secret?
Secret!
Oh my gosh!
Print screen.
Hold on.
Paint.
Paste.
Okay, next.
This one is pretty easy.
I don't even know this one is right by yeah this one's right
at the beginning so I'm just gonna print screen f12 how you
guys I'm I I don't put everything into paint I know it
probably drives people crazy but you know what at least I'm
not Matara who gazzos everything
This one is...
Zoom in.
RB.
RB?
Wait, why isn't it?
Oh, it's equipped.
Why isn't it zooming in?
Equip.
RB... It's not zooming in for some reason.
Uh...
I'm trying to see which- which this is.
I can't tell.
Print screen control R MS Paint.
Control V master race.
Oh, no, it's a bug.
Uh-oh.
Okay, hold on.
But this is where we're at, actually.
Now I think about it, right?
This is where we're at.
So there's a hidden room.
I'm guessing, right?
This is where we're at, I think.
It's a known bug.
You guys know everything.
How do you guys know so much?
How do you guys know everything?
Jeffrey told us Oh You guys know everything
Hold on Um Wait Hold on Uh oh Uh I'm really slow And I can't
put down the artifact Uh oh Uh oh Wait I'm really slow And I
can't put down The artifact No no No
But I can still rotate this.
I'm just gonna be a little slow, guys.
Press RB.
RB doesn't work!
Uh-oh.
RB stuck.
RB stuck!
Oh my god, I'm really, I'm really slow.
I always press, I always press like where circle is because
I'm so used to like dang Metal Gear.
Okay, hold on.
Uh, Barbie.
How do I...
Oh,
hold on.
I did it again.
Oh.
Um.
What can I set it to?
How can I set it?
Wait, see.
Maybe?
That worked?
Ah!
We're fixed!
I just, uh, I just reset everything.
Which I didn't change anything before either, so we're good.
Hoki-doki.
Let's get out of here.
Oh, there's one in here!
There's been one in here this whole time!
Okay, so...
If I'm looking at this picture, it's in this...
tower here.
Right there.
Hmm.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Why do you have to frighten me so?
Oh, I thought it would stop halfway through.
Um.
Hmm.
I thought it would, like, stop halfway through.
and so I couldn't.
Nope.
Uh, no.
Hmm.
Let's see.
How can we get in here?
I have to go back up.
Oh gosh.
Ah!
You know
if the building was going to come down or not?
Holy moly.
Okay.
Let's go downstairs.
There's...
It's right there.
And down a little bit more.
Ah.
Oh.
YOLO.
I think I went too far down.
Oh, we're exactly where we were before.
And with no elevator.
Oh.
Goodness.
Okay, hold on.
Let's...
Oh, it's going to be such a pain in the butt getting over
there again.
Ouch.
We're all good.
Everything's fine.
We're going to figure this out.
We're going to figure this out, guys.
Let's see.
I'm looking at it.
so funny i never know i'm i guess i never noticed that part
before
could have brought the elevator back down no no i could not
because it was broken
no no no
what if i like launch my i see
oh oh oh i can't equip my launch scouter now.
I can't equip my scouter.
My RB is still broken.
I'm gonna have to restart the game maybe.
Uh.
Oh no.
I just wanted to...
I wanted to...
Rebind it.
Equipment.
Retrieve scout.
Sk.
Oh.
There's only a retrieve.
Okay.
Primary action.
No, it's not primary interact.
Primary action tool.
Oh.
Use the mouse.
That's such a pain in the butt though.
Huh.
Primary tool interaction.
Wait, where do you guys see that?
Oh, here, here, here.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Oh.
How do I rewind it?
If I press it, it like...
Okay, here we go.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Yippee!
Aha!
See, the dang elevator could stop here, it just chooses not
to.
Hmm.
Now if I shoot it...
Like here.
It's not the most ideal way to see it.
Wait, where is it anyway?
Like it actually...
Oh, okay.
There's.
I don't see anything like any way to go in from the bottom.
I was seeing if like I could fly up from the bottom or
something.
Do I just have to be good at flying?
Do I just have to be good?
Do I just have to be really smooth with this?
Oh, oh, I can't get in there.
Ow!
Let me see if I'm down.
Oh no, I should have at least brought the elevator down.
Okay, well I guess that makes things a bit easier.
Tell the elevators who's boss.
Yeah, see if I want to bring the elevator back down, the
thing is broken and it always has been, so.
Ah, all the way back.
There we go again.
Wait, wait, wait.
Bikupupupup.
It looks like, it looks like, oh yeah is that a tree yeah it
looks like this one is like more broken than this one but I
don't think it is I think it's the same yeah it's the same
amount I don't know if I can fit in there
bring skill shot the Scout to the elevator and bring it down
holy cow that would be insane right gotta be clever mint I'm
I'm kashikoi, I'm, you know...
Hold on!
Yeah, we can't fit through there.
What's another way to be clever?
Does it involve the elevator?
Because I mean, I could...
I could skill shot it, right?
Like...
No.
Too high, too high.
Ha!
Dang it.
No.
Here.
Just kidding.
Oh my gosh, it's like the most precise thing that I'm ever
doing ever.
I'm really thinking.
I'm really processing.
That's why I tried with the elevator before.
But maybe I just didn't do it correctly.
Some...
I'm seeing smileys.
Is someone spoiling?
No spoiling, you guys.
Oh, no, no.
Get on here.
Oh.
Time's up, everybody.
buddy.
Time's up.
Well, it's okay because we have the other ones as well.
I only went to this one first because we were here.
Think in the box.
Ah.
Hmm.
Bro didn't even let us listen to the banger.
Buy the soundtrack.
We're on a mission!
Oh, wasn't spoils, but backseeds that could feel spoilery.
Oh, that's...
Oh, thanks, guys.
I appreciate it.
No backseeding until I'm really like...
Head up with me!
And then only give a little hints.
Little tiny hints.
I don't think it's...
Yeah, I was gonna say, I don't think we got anything else,
truly.
Well, no.
I mean, we saw...
I guess it's this.
These are the...
Oh, this area I want to go to so badly.
This secret area.
I want to go so badly.
Come here.
new secret new secret
we gotta be so vague it doesn't even make sense here we go
okay we are inside the stranger which take me out to dinner
first oh my goodness that's what this stranger is saying
right now is like yeah i barely even know you okay roll
there we go
perfect it's a beautiful sunny day i'm stuck on
i'm gonna grab the artifact I'm gonna grab the artifact
first, though.
Again, just in case.
Just in case.
Where are you going?
To where the tower is.
Stranger.
I hardly know her.
Huh?
Oh.
I completely...
Caught me off guard.
What's the point?
Why are you so funny?
You're laughing too hard at this one.
You're not laughing hard at this one.
Oh, man.
good one I think it's because oh god I think it's because
I've only ever heard people do it correctly and so when it's
like you know okay okay okay okay over there over there over
there oh is this it wait yeah is this This is it.
Oh.
Okay.
This way.
They're giving me tears in my eyes.
Hello?
Over here?
This is it, right?
That looks like...
That's the egg!
Hopefully I didn't need to um oh wait uh let's see okay nice
and it's um oh hold on i'm checking my screenshot it's in
the trees so it's it's basically where i'm at right Here?
In here?
Hello?
Is it in the water?
No.
Do I hop up here?
Hold on, let me...
Oh gosh, you guys my RB is broken again!
No way!
I just realized my RB is broken again.
Uh-oh.
I might actually have to restart my game.
No!
Unplug, re-plug the controller.
It's a wireless controller.
Jeff said to toggle active controller on off again.
A key.
Oh.
I was like, wait a second.
I can't move it.
Okay, there we go.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you guys don't think that, like, you know, if I get a
bug, I'm like, oh my god, how dare.
I don't really care.
Like, it doesn't bother me.
No, I fell.
Is there another way in?
Let's see.
Is my boat still here?
Uh, nope, nope, she's long gone.
Like, it's pretty obvious, don't worry.
Oh, so you're saying I'm stupid, huh?
You're saying I'm a dummy, huh?
Is that what you're saying?
You're saying, wow, Minto's so stupid.
No, I'm just...
Yeah, that's what you're saying, right?
That scared me so much.
Oh god, it happened right as I jumped in!
Oh!
I think I found it.
So why are all of these ones destroyed?
The thing...
Oh!
What a love for you.
I had a feeling it would move.
Oh!
Okay.
It looks like eyes are staring at me.
It's so freaky.
Hello?
Who locked me in?
Uh...
I'm
a good Minto, I promise!
Oh god!
Wait a second, what's over here?
Uh...
Anyway.
Rude as hell.
I'm taking this back and I'm...
I didn't know that I was gonna fall through, okay?
Left the real.
I didn't know that I was gonna be...
You know.
I guess we don't need the artifact for now.
This leads to...
This room.
Okay.
I have...
Something I wish to view!
What if this is how we had to watch anime?
Now I need to find a place for... the lantern?
Which is...
oh the tower the the tower had a ton of a ton of them 1980
or 1890s anime yeah exactly we're old school we're retro
here that's how you have to watch vtubers I'm gonna have my
all my um streams in stop motion from now on let's
go onward where are Where did we come from?
Another thing.
Oh, that one right there.
Yeah.
Claymation.
Every stream in five frames per second?
Good luck, everybody, figuring out what's going on.
Oh.
Okay.
We got a little more if some they're doing something with
the seal
This is this is where oh, this is where the eye temple was
that's the binoculars
Wait, what the hell are they holding?
Okay, we've been here.
We've been here.
Oh Hello my friend oh he can't gives him the tablet.
Bye.
We go back.
Oh, there's a secret!
Grabby grab!
And then he goes down.
Oh, my gosh.
This is giving us so much information.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wait a second.
So once he goes down, down the lights come back on so that's
what turns off the lights when you think about it clips are
just the VTuber equivalent of watching an episode of Ranma
what half what Ranma what half in in 10 minutes chunks on
YouTube ho ho ho ho ho ho okay
what is he doing here he's just chilling
okay but i still haven't figured out a way down to the hole
which is the issue i think oh no i think as soon as i do
that too the guys are gonna start walking around more aren't
they oh right now they're upstairs but when as soon as i do
that they're probably all gonna come running okay oh shucks
unless they start descending themselves And then I follow
them like before.
Okay.
We do need a cardboard box.
Okay, so that was one.
Or rather, two.
Part two.
The dam still hasn't broken, but like literally any second
now is probably gonna...
Look at that thing.
The thing's about to blow!
Holy hell, we're watching Interstellar.
So the other one was at...
Sorry, I'm checking my map.
So we have the one inside that building I'm trying to get
to.
Oh, and the one at the very beginning.
Which is like right around here.
Which I don't think we're gonna make it.
It's gonna become flooded.
Like two seconds.
Do you remember why you couldn't go down the hole?
Because I died.
um because i dropped down i i couldn't find an entrance
rather i haven't been able to find an entrance yet it
dropped down and i broke my legs okay
i don't think we're gonna make it but i think it's gonna
become flooded but we could try but what killed you oh what
was the alarm i do know that i'm or rather i don't know if
the by my own um silliness you know i
could not tell you
um i don't have like an artifact or anything i have nothing
with me i've got nothing on my property
the stream a little stuttery honestly for me streams have
been so awful on youtube
music here.
This is so relaxing.
Stream looks good today.
Streams are like in general.
Like I'll be watching someone and like it's almost
impossible to watch them.
But I'm glad that it's okay.
I think it's probably because I'm using Firefox with like an
ad blocker.
And they're like, um, can you stop that?
Oh my gosh, I didn't realize it would take me to- Ah!
Um...
The house is, like, right here.
Oh god.
Oh!
We made it.
Well, the house...
was here wait have I never noticed that what is that thing
oh I think it's huh is it just a bell is it just like a
decorate yeah maybe it's just a decoration you
can measure damn integrity with scowl oh really okay good to
know for the future oh there it is there it is The other
house we need to get to.
I think we might be able to still do it.
We'll see.
Who knows?
Maybe we had to wait this whole time to do it, to get in
there, right?
It is this house, though.
I think.
Right?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-
Oh.
Oh, it's this place...
Wait.
Okay, so that first one was, like, super obvious.
Can I rotate you, please?
Oh, it's stuck.
Never mind.
That's the raft house.
There's our raft.
Dang.
Okay, hold on.
I'm looking at the picture again.
I'm zooming in.
in.
I think we might just have to meditate to get to it or to do
it.
I think we'll have to meditate.
To get to it.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, because it's like, right?
Hold on.
I'm trying.
Down here or something.
I think?
I'm getting pushed away.
Because there's like a bridge that I'm seeing.
Like, you see this place.
This is the place.
Yeah, you see this place.
And then you see there's a bridge.
Okay, I meditate.
I give up.
I'm not going to fight the current.
Okay.
I've tried to do this while flooded might be a bit hard.
Good to know.
Good to know I probably made the right decision then.
And it's right at the entrance.
It'll be fine.
I love meditating.
And then we'll have this one.
And then also...
did our oh our ship log did update beep beep beep beep see
secret oh secret well yes well it's like the not really a
secret the reel I found in the slide burning room shows a
container marked with a symbol glowing being handed to a
shadowy figure the lights are extinguished and the figure
carries the container down a dark well the room for a room
full of burned slide reels piled next to a strange device.
Am I able to use the device ever or is it just not a thing?
I love meditating in bed with my eyes closed.
I call it sleeping.
I love sleeping too.
Found a hidden slide reel that shows a container marked with
a glowing symbol being handed to a shadowy figure.
The lights are extinguished and the figure carries the
container down into a dark well.
Yato Takoyaki!
Welcome to membership, thank you.
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
Virtual!
Thanks for two months.
Gosh, I can't believe.
It's been over two months since I've been back.
It's kind of crazy.
Soon to be three, right?
Because...
Guys, uh...
You know, I guess if you count April 1st...
Perfect.
Perfect landing.
Can't believe it's only been two months.
No, it's already...
Been two months.
I have to use this to call Minto cute before it's gone.
Stop it.
Die.
4-4.
4-4 is...
It's funny because, you know, 4-4 is the day I stopped
streaming.
Before?
Ha, get it.
And...
That is the day I returned to stream.
streaming so it's just basically like nothing ever just and
ever changed you know nothing ever stopped okay hold on I'm
looking at the picture real quick oh wrong picture oh here
we go so there's this it's behind all of this oh I see it oh
I see it I see it okay
Let's...
Oh, uh...
Uh...
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Happy Yuri Day?
No way.
Thank you.
Oh.
Here we go.
Give me the reel.
I turn around.
Be a little freak.
You better not be a freak of when I turn around.
Thank you.
Okay, now this one...
Oh, okay.
We have to...
I was going to say, this one is a little, you know, a little
more difficult, I'd say.
Wait, what did I put down?
I didn't have anything.
Did I?
Oh, the lantern.
Okay, we don't care.
We're good.
Good.
Two months, here's too many more.
Mint is cute.
Stop!
What's over here?
Oh, oh, oh.
How mysterious!
This is kind of fun.
Does this also lead to the projection room?
Which, if it does, we'll just go back for that lantern.
Eey.
Yippee!
Okay.
Like how...
Everything is like opening and closing.
What an inefficient... I mean, you could just go into
anybody's house, honestly.
Where was the door?
Oh, here.
Okay.
Nice!
Alright, let's go get the lantern from in here.
How my contact is starting to bother me.
I got new contacts for my new prescription and they're like
better quality so that they're um so that they aren't like
keep my eyes moist but
but um i've had i have so many contacts of my other
prescription my older prescription that i'm like i have to
use them or else they'll go to waste but they make my eyes
so dry I haven't even gotten the other ones because I was
supposed to have them for before Japan but um they called me
while I was in Japan because they hadn't even arrived yet
and now I I came back and I had COVID so I couldn't even go
get them okay the first on the first seal of strangerville
My true safe said to me Your RV isn't working No, don't go
in reverse Don't go in reverse Wait, wait, wait, hold on
Hold on, I have to I have to reprogram it Why is it
happening like this This time?
It's so weird Here, oh, let me turn the active controller On
and off again
There we go Okay, we got a grabby grab Um, oh, I don't
recognize this place as much.
There we go.
Huh?
Oh!
This is where they do the concert.
What?
Bug feed?
No, it's okay.
Also, it's the alt tab losing app focus thing.
Ah, that makes sense.
That makes sense.
How am I supposed to do that one?
Okay, interesting.
Alright, let's go figure out the final puzzle of the other
thing.
Yeah, how am I supposed to just walk into the fire?
No, but how am I supposed to sneak past them?
Maybe if I walk into the fire...
Like, I kind of just stood there before.
I kind of just stood there and let them take me.
You know?
Maybe it wasn't my most proudest moment.
Wow!
Come back!
Don't run me over.
Okay, we're good.
Everything's fine, you guys.
Town, town.
I felt like...
I feel like that was, I like literally felt like a
tumbleweed there, you know?
Okay.
Here we go.
Come on.
We're all good.
Yeah, just a couple of concussions.
This is, it's concussions for science, everybody.
Concussions are fine if you learn after them.
If you learn things because of your concussion.
It's all good.
This dang.
Confound it.
That hole's too small for me.
I'm a thick boy.
Yes, I learned English again.
If there's a hole, there's a way.
Something, something, hole, goal.
I get it, I get it.
Lottie Doody.
Think outside the box.
The only thing I can think of is involving an elevator.
There's not even a door to open.
Wait a second.
Wee!
Ah!
Oh, I'm okay.
I did it.
And I didn't die.
Can you imagine if I had died there?
That would have been pretty embarrassing.
What's up here?
Okay, that's our secret tunnel.
Just minor leg damage.
That's our thing.
Oh, there's even like a...
Ooh.
Is that our way out?
Don't...
If there's a freak, I'm gonna be...
...a little upset!
Okay, so I probably have to launch the...
Oh, I just have to guess.
Nice.
Guys, I'm a bit of a genius.
I'm a bit of a genius.
Gaming?
Skill.
I know, I know.
I know.
Can't wait for season two.
I...
Yeah.
I'm...
I haven't read the manga but I do have someone like like a
friend that will kind of they'll be like do you want a
spoiler I'm like okay usually usually I would say no but I
wasn't sure if I was going to continue the series um
actually actually wait now I think about I don't know at all
what the second arc is about is that friend mata why is mata
always spoiled things to shows.
Okie dokie.
Alright.
Where's our next thing?
The third.
Okay.
Very helpful.
They're just in pure darkness.
Oh!
This is where they were doing the recital!
And then...
Shut up.
Ooh.
Oh, he's taking it to the tree!
Never mind.
Yes?
Whoa!
Wait, that was in the tower.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
That one we can do.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
An invisible bridge.
Sleeping in your bed.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, though.
Hold on, I'm thinking.
That's why the boats are so important.
Okay.
Because I was like, how do I get to the tower?
It was in the tower, right?
Oh my gosh.
Whoa, this is...
Hold on.
This is a lot of...
Okay.
Oh, geez.
Okay, I might have to write, like, this step by step
because...
Oh, goodness.
Okay.
right no it was the lodge it was oh you're right it was the
lot it was the lodge right because
because um we sneaked past the guy and then we saw the mural
in the basement yes yes yes yes yes yes okay okay hello
there it is
Oh, Nyerhodo, Nyerhodo.
Oh gosh.
Oh, it's spooky.
OBS disconnected for a second.
Everything good?
Everything all right?
You guys okay?
OBS, OBS, OBS disconnected for a second.
Very spooky.
I don't remember where this one leads us to.
Small F.
It is...
Oh my goodness.
Oh, that spooked me.
It's this one, right?
They're yelling?
Or they're dying?
I can't tell, actually.
Maybe they're dying.
Maybe their fire's going out.
Wait, that means that they would be...
there wouldn't be any guys walking around then, right?
If their fires go out...
Did I guess it?
Did I get it correct?
Tensai?
Moshkashite?
Assess with me, this guy?
Let's see.
Well, this is...
This guy's still here.
This guy, what's your dealio?
He's watching the best 5 frame per second live stream of his
life.
It's his favorite.
Okay, let's see.
I'm just happy.
Well, I guess we'll figure, we'll find out soon enough.
Right here.
No, he's still going!
Interesting.
So, but someone's dying.
Someone is dead.
Oh, I don't know why I'm here.
Just yet.
Because...
Okay, okay, hold on.
I don't even remember what the order was.
Can I jump down from here?
I just realized.
Oh, no.
I go into the water.
Raiders!
Thank you!
Thank you for the raid, sorry, I didn't see who it was, but
thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Go to the recital, that's right.
But that was in like a completely...
Do I have enough time, I wonder?
I guess we'll see.
To the recital.
We have to go take a boat.
Which...
Where is a boat around here?
Anyway.
Oh, wait.
It was upstairs, wasn't it?
My bad.
No, Marvin, thanks for the vibe, gifted.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know who rated me, but thank you so much.
We're playing a kind of spooky game, so if that's not your
style.
Then, uh, see you later.
Wait, I remember there was a boat over here.
That's right.
There was a boat down here.
I remember.
Nexi, thanks for the vibe, gifted.
My brain has been expanding.
Wait, it was over here, wasn't it?
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe.
The boat was the other way.
I thought there was one...
Uh...
Oh, here, here, here.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
We got this.
We have to go down, down, down by the river.
Here.
Okay.
Right?
Yes!
Oh, will we have time?
If I'm speedy, maybe.
There's gotta be speed.
Okay.
Unless it's here.
Wait, where are you heading to?
It's...
The music sit...
There was this bar?
There was?
Wait, I thought the...
I thought it was um uh uh no help no this is fine to help
wait i thought it was um i wasn't i thought it was in the
same area as the first as the big recital as like a little
tiny place to the left okay i understand the error of my
ways wait so it's
around this way no uh i forgot how to get there uh wait wait
i wish i could open this well maybe i don't wish i could i
don't know i don't know i don't want to wish anything in
this area it's too spooky wait
was it through here try to figure out how to no hold on let
me go back to the very beginning
i don't die here though i think oh shoot i have to go oh my
god i'm sorry guys my brain i'm so sorry i'm like yeah i
have to go all the way up so that i can go to the hand
inside deactivated.
There we go.
So around here.
Wasn't it...
Maybe it is on the side.
Or wait.
Yeah, because that...
Oh, that blue...
That turned on the bridge.
Eh?
Oh!
Do I need to go that way?
There, up there.
I know it's over here, right?
Like, it's over there somewhere.
It's over there somewhere.
I think the bridge just fell.
I think I was too slow.
Here we go.
Okay.
It was here?
Where was... What was the spot, though?
Uh-oh, I don't remember.
Here?
They did something?
Well, I found it, but...
I'm not sure what to do here.
Near the edge.
That's right!
We walk!
To the other side.
We'll come back.
That's right.
We walk to the other side.
And then we...
Blow this out.
I don't think they like that very much.
Oh, neat.
Are they going to be walking around?
Are they going to be walking around in here now?
It's okay.
Just run.
Uh, where'd the bridge go?
Oh, God.
so rude it blows out all the candles in the house so it
blows out the the bridge so i have to go do it again anyway
do you think love can bloom even in the outer wilds it's a
great question i'm just gonna wait to die oh man and i also
have to go to the bathroom so I will do that too
You have to do it while they're looking for you I know
they're gonna be walking around There's gonna be two of them
Oh no At least I know the layout pretty well At this point
but
It's gonna be mad because you turn off his show No Stop the
stream
Here's where the real stealth happens.
Oh, I can see a lot of progress is going to be made in this
run.
Well, I'm hoping to beat it.
That's why I'm like, even if I play for 12 hours, hoping to
beat it, but I do have to go to the bathroom.
So, I'm going to go do that.
I'm going to go potty real quick.
I'm going to go to the little ghosty's room.
Oh, gosh.
That means all three of them are going to be stealthy.
All three of them are going to be...
And they're spooky stealthy.
It's like the worst kind of stealthy.
It's my least favorite kind of stealthy.
It's like spooky stealthy.
It's not as bad as it seems now.
Okay, I'll trust you.
I'll trust you.
Okay, I'll be right back.
You guys can roast your marshmallows and have a good day.
Have a, you know, have a delightful time.
I guess we'll go back to that one first because I know what
to do immediately with that one.
We'll do that one.
Maybe then we'll do the giant, the opera house, and then
maybe we'll do the third one because I still don't know what
to do with that, like how to get down to the hole.
There's a way to bypass every spooky section of the game
with puzzle solving.
What?
Oh, are you saying like I sequence break and I figure out
how to do everything without being told what to do?
That is not true.
Oh, just kidding.
Hey, stop one guying me.
Everybody...
Wait, who said that?
Who said that?
Mood!
Hito?
Mood hita!
Why would you?
Why you?
Protect that wisp!
No!
No future knowledge or sequence breaking me.
What the?
Don't lie to me.
Okay, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Sorry, I have to pee a lot today.
Gonna get more tea though.
Yippee!
Guys, I'm doing a blue archive break.
A BA break.
Is she alive?
No!
No, I'm not alive.
I'm dead.
I'm a ghost.
A BA break, a BA break.
I haven't, I have, I'm installed, I'm like downloading the
new update right now.
Because I forgot to last night.
Time for camping hidea.
Exactly!
Let's pull for her right now.
Wait, wait.
Did the banner start already?
Actually, BA, fine.
Thank you.
Sensei got a sensei.
you know one of my favorite things to do um actually in one
of the meetings last night that i had um uh one of the one
of the people was a sensei and i was because uh they had
like a profile picture and i was like are you a sensei they
were like yeah and i was like who's here this is one of my
favorite things to do to sensei's this i'll be like who's
your favorite who's your favorite character and they'll be
like oh i really like so and so and i'll be like wrong if
you all the girls would be your favorite you would treat
them all equally and then they're like the other person the
other person the meeting was like oh she told you they were
like oh damn
yeah if you were a good sensei oh wait the banner's not up
yet it's it tomorrow oh wait yes it is camping hide I
remember seeing the ads for this in Japan.
Like the ads for her.
I didn't realize she was a...
Oh, I thought she was a unique.
Oh, nice.
Maybe I should wait then.
I thought she was a unique.
Maybe I should just wait then.
Both permanent.
Maybe I'll just do like one.
Maybe I'll do one.
I just...
I'm waiting to...
But isn't she like really good?
So it's like good to get her now.
Just one tempo.
One becomes two, two becomes four.
No, no, no.
Actually, yeah, that happened to me last.
See, this is peak gotcha polling music, right?
hold on blue archive break everybody everybody do your
dailies if you play if you play any gotcha games or whatever
do your dailies with me let's do dailies together you know i
forgot to do them earlier well i guess i was streaming i
streamed right when it updated so or when the date changed
but you know i don't want to do dailies do your dailies your
girls are going to be so sad.
I love this song so much.
I did Niki Daily's already.
Well, then do something else.
This is why I can only play like one gotcha game at a time
because, you know, I invest so much into the one.
That it's like doing daily is for more than one gotcha The
game seems tiring to me.
Very valid.
At least with Blue Archives, it takes like five minutes.
It's not even so much to do dailies.
I'm playing three and it's a lot.
You're crazy.
Hmm.
I'm doing my lessons.
Such a good sensei.
I'm teaching my girls good things.
I'm teaching them.
What do you think they learn?
What is Sensei teaching them anyway?
Maybe don't answer that.
Do you assign homework, Mint?
It's optional.
It's optional homework.
I'm the cool teacher.
I'm the cool teacher to you.
Can I get extra credit?
What a question.
think about.
Stop.
Get your minds out of the gutter.
I almost have my Hot Springs Chetty node to level 20
relationship.
Not relationship.
What's the word?
Oh, it is relationship.
Relationship doesn't have to mean romantic, though.
We're just, we're back.
I'm her comrade.
I'm her comrade, you guys.
Don't be so weird about it.
Sure.
She's at 18.
Almost got her.
I like the Hot Springs one so much, though.
It's so cute.
With her little milk mustache.
She's so cute.
Chetty knows a cute brat.
Yeah.
she's definitely a brat but I think that makes me love her
more she's so dumb she's like when's my nap time how dare
you make me over sleep I love that about her comrade is the
new roommate what do you mean by that
oh my god we're living together oh la la blue blue Archive
in the streets.
Comrade in the sheets.
No!
My love for Chenino is so pure.
Can't say that about others.
I guess I can.
I'm a good sensei.
I'm a pure sensei, you guys.
Oh my god, they were roommates.
Get your minds out of the gutter.
Nice thumbnail.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I lost the tactical challenge, as always.
What else do I need to do?
I can save probably some of it.
Okay, I'm going to do some pulls, though.
Oh, they gave a lot of...
A lot of jemmies.
Okay.
I'm going to do one pull...
110 pull for Hade.
Pull!
Confirm.
It's blue, but maybe it'll change.
I'll draw a wisp on that.
Wait, it changed, it changed, it changed.
Let's see, let's see.
Blue, I got duty and...
No way!
Oh shit, I pulled out a first try!
Wow!
Oh my god, streamer luck!
Streamer luck!
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee!
I threw out my boy cute.
Thank you.
Yippee!
Very nice.
Her thing is so cute, she's eating the yucky emo.
It's my favorite.
that was meant for me I'll take it back no take back sees
you would give you would give me a gift and then ask for it
back have some shame never got into gotchas because I
refused to get a new phone oh you know what you're saving a
lot of money the Kotama like a her she looks so cute
everyone so I want everybody because they're all so Yudu
camp.
They're all so Yudu camp.
So cute.
Okay.
I'll do the rest of everything later.
Though I am starting to get hungry.
I should probably think of what I'm going to have for
dinner.
Okay.
Let's meditate.
B.A.
is actually pretty good for a gotcha when it comes to
currency.
Sometimes.
Now it's time to try.
Gotcha luck on Woo-Wah.
What is Woo-Wah?
Oh, no.
What is...
If it's you here and I don't trust it.
What do you mean by that?
Like, it's just the campfire the whole time.
Weathering waves.
Oh, it's Genshin 2.
I've never heard of it before, actually.
What?
I've never even heard of it.
Hot new gotcha game.
I won't.
play.
Oh, never...
Oh, it's new!
Ancient but harder.
Oh, interesting.
Beep.
Okay.
Let's see.
Guys, I'm not looking forward to this at all.
I'm not looking forward to this at all.
A room full of burn slide reels piled in a hidden slide reel
that shows a container marked.
with a glowing symbol being handed to a shadowy figure.
A figure follows a procession of green lights through a
forest to a candlelit building where they carry the
container into a passage behind a roaring fireplace.
Oh, okay, that's that one.
Just kidding.
I was like, wait a second.
This isn't the one.
Made by the same company from punishing Green Raymond.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, whoa, whoa.
There we go.
No, no, no.
Um.
This is the one we're doing.
Right?
Oh!
No, this is the one we just did.
What the heck?
Wait, I can put HUD... I can put mark locations on these,
too?
Okay.
I'm just getting rid of these real quick.
wait a second though weren't oh they're the same because
they're connected I'm so I get it secret well but we're
doing this one the secret mural
I don't want to do I'm scared you guys Can I turn on the
baby mode now?
Can I turn on baby mode now, please?
No.
It'll be fine.
Is that why it was a spoiler?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, coming in hot, coming in hot.
Is that why I was a spoiler?
Because...
Yep.
Do it in one run.
Okay.
I'll try at least one run.
Probably should have gone the other.
Well, I'm going to grab the...
The artifact here.
I like getting it here.
It's really easy.
I'll fail in one run.
Guys, I'm not good at stealth.
So scared.
I'm scaredy baby.
I'm so scaredy baby.
Oh.
Take it down.
Going around town.
Careful not to imply what she's about to experience.
I'm not gonna look at chat too much.
I'm sorry.
I'm just being a little baby.
Okay.
Here we go.
oh oh oh there we go yeah we're going we're gonna go in like
two seconds here we go rip the band-aid off i'm scared at
least i know what happens if they catch me because i've well
i don't know if that applies to everybody there might be
some really mean guys there might be a guy oh my gosh what
if they like well you know i was gonna say what if they went
to earth and they went to the United States of America and
then they have guns.
Metal Gear!
I keep forgetting this is not a VOD.
Thanks for joining!
It's not a VOD, not yet.
I could stop the stream if you want.
I'll play it off that, I'll play it off the stream.
I'll finish it.
Wow, thank you!
Sit down!
I'll finish it off the stream so that then it will feel like
a VOD.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, yo.
It is this one, right?
Yeah, it is this one.
She actually hates us.
Stop being so dramatic.
This has all been pre-recorded the whole time.
Pretty much.
I'm going over there.
I'm going there.
I'll see you later tonight.
Is that too bright?
Nope.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, order of operations.
Order of operations.
Go there, go to the show, go to where the little recital is,
or the stage.
We walk across the river, blow out the lights, go back
inside, turn on the lights for the bridge, walk across the
bridge, go to the basement.
Okay.
I'm scared.
I don't want to do this.
The shortcut I found.
What shortcut?
I found a shortcut.
good?
Wait.
Wait, if I go across the river...
Wait a second.
If I go... Yeah, wait.
If I go across the river...
And I...
Where is that part... Where is that spot, though?
Yeah, where we pop out.
I wonder if that will work, then.
Right.
Over here.
right and then we just come back and oh wait no wait no that
doesn't work wait uh-huh you can see it from the bridge that
but no that's just what we have to I'm just I'm confused
What's the ghost cooking?
My brain is fried.
I'm too scared.
I'm too nervous.
Oh, the power just went out.
Power just went out.
No time for music.
Oh, God.
No.
Oh.
My...
My shoes!
Will he be...
Will he have a light?
Oh.
This room.
Oh my god, it's just a place to hide.
I hate this, I hate this, I hate this!
It's just a place to hide!
No wonder I did it!
what this is.
He's not gonna have, he's gonna have a light though, right?
He's gonna have a light though, right?
Oh god, oh god, oh god Is he gonna have a light?
They all have the same artifact, yeah, right?
Thank you
Wait, I'm lost
Oh Oh my god, they don't have a light.
They don't have a light.
Why can't I just jump down there?
Actually.
No.
Wait.
If I were to leave.
Technically speaking.
And take the boat.
And come back here.
And...
Um...
How...
Oh, wait, no.
The...
I would need the ladder.
Or I would need the elevator.
Dang it.
Never mind.
I would need the elevator.
I was going to say, What if I just left?
And then...
Came back.
And then took the boat.
And then avoided everybody inside.
But, um...
Because then I would use the little boat area.
And go through the back.
but you can lower it first but I have to you have to get on
that side to lower it
that was some good cooking thanks I mean unless hold on
what if I lower it before I before I blow out the lights
Hold on.
Because then I could...
Then I could avoid everything.
I'm just stalling.
No, no, no.
I'm actually clicking.
I think.
Should I try it?
But I would have to...
Hold on.
If I go back inside.
I'm scared.
I don't want to get caught again.
Worth a shot.
Okay.
I'm really scared, so I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm gonna try it.
Wait.
What if I just...
Who knows?
Maybe I won't break my legs.
I'm just an alien boy.
Or actually, I don't know what my gender is.
I'm just an alien!
Okay.
I think I would have to meditate, though, right?
I wonder if there's a way to do it the other ones too then
hold on uh what were they I'm just a little guy yeah I'm
just a little guy then um hold on so that was that one the
other there's the one we still don't know how to get down
sorry I know it was probably a waste of time but I just came
up with this idea.
Hearthians are genderless.
Oh, okay.
I'm just a little creature.
I'm just a creature.
Um, okay.
That was a bit of a waste of a loop.
But...
Okay.
If we...
I'm trying to remember, I think it's the, um, I think it's
the first area.
I think it was Super Chad, by the way, hold on.
I think it's the first area that has, um...
Not a hidden Gorge.
I think it's here that you can access the boat.
I think its here that you access the boat.
Okay.
All right.
We're gonna speed, speed, speed.
If I can find the seat.
We can find the seat.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
And my mind is...
Alright.
That was so close.
Oh, my mind is clear.
Not really.
Gender scaredy cat.
Stop!
Oh!
For the other two, though, I'm still not sure.
I'm going to have to even look up what to do again for them,
because I don't quite remember.
Okay.
Alright.
Inside.
Oh.
Oh, good.
Can I exit?
Then we're fine.
Okay, here we go.
Now...
No, I'm just going to go the normal way.
Okay.
It's going the way that I've been going.
It's okay.
Because first we're gonna grab artifact.
Then we go in.
We lower.
We go in.
The, um, the, um, the.
Why do I want to say umbrella?
Elevator.
Ele.
Hey.
a a under my umbrella then we leave come back here go back
in with the artifact you and then we ride to that area use
the elevator go up avoid all spookies right the umbrella
vader elevator a a a a
oh yeah is this a tutorial i sure wish oh oh no no don't we
need to all right let's go
it might be a really tight timing but by golly by george i
hope we can do it and then we'll figure out another way to
avoid ah ah The rest.
Full speed ahead!
She's had brain cells spooked into her.
As long as the dam doesn't break broken...
Yeah, exactly.
Come on, come on!
We need to go faster!
Faster!
Full speed, full speed, full speed!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This way, this way, this way, this way.
Okay, voila.
And the reason I also wanted to take the boat is because now
we have an easy access boat for when we come back, that we
can just drop down and continue onwards.
Run, run, run.
Come on, come on.
Come down, come down, come down, come down, come down, come
up, come up.
At this part of the DLC where time really starts to matter.
Yeah, right.
Which one is it?
It's you.
I knew that.
Okay.
Go, go, go.
Go, go.
Go, avoid the spooky.
Go, go, go.
Go avoid the spooky.
Sleep.
Wake up.
No time for sleep.
What's wrong with you?
Wake up, wake up, wake up.
Run, run, run.
No time to be scared.
Only scared if we don't make it.
Only be scared if this fails us.
No time to be scared right now.
Okay.
No time for caution.
His shows.
There wasn't there another room.
In the, actually, with the tree, there was another room in
there that, um,
that, uh, we couldn't go in.
in just yet.
Okay.
Your shows, your shows, just keep watching them.
Don't worry about me.
Okay, go up.
It is really rude, though, that it does extinguish the fire,
or the, yeah, the bridge over here.
I'll be honest.
It's pretty rude.
Look at all these hiding spots.
This guy is gonna be around here it'll be so scary it'd be
so terrifying okay now we go back
oh here we go time to lower and then we're just gonna jump
into the water
is there something here oh no okay don't jump into the water
yet no time to slow down Only speed, only speed here.
Oh, hello.
All right.
Okay.
We've got...
We've got the elevator down.
Go, go, go.
Woo!
All right.
Good morning, everybody.
See you.
See you later.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Now, we, um, go back.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, I forgot to show off the light.
You're right.
Uh, why did I...
Uh-oh.
I made a grave mistake.
Um, wait.
Okay.
Then we go back.
We turn off the light.
And then we leave again.
Wait a second.
Can I leave?
The lights are on.
Sorry.
This is why I was like, I should write this down.
Because the order of operations is going to be all over in
my brain.
Okay.
Oh, then we go over here.
There's so much to keep track of.
There really is.
Okay.
Upwards.
why aren't you using the shortcut i don't remember the
shortcut i don't remember where whoever is
i don't remember
thank you so much for the 20 gifted thank you okay now okay
now i wake up though right because then i hold on okay
there's no way way to drop i have to yes now i wake up and
then i go back to the okay
okay into the water whoa whoa whoa
okay see ya
you just walk through the shortcut that oh okay you know
what i'll be honest i don't even notice which which picture
frame it was so um i'll be honest okay then we have our boat
right there all ready to use ready to cruise Gustavo looking
at my bullshit thank you thank you thank you
did you guys see my short my snake eater short i was so
nervous about it i'm still so nervous i still don't think i
sound very good but the comments seem positive enough so
thanks guys if you listen to it it's a song i really don't
think i can sing very well but if you guys say so i'll trust
you maybe
i think it's because i wish my voice was a little bit more
soulful, I guess.
Like, a little more, you know, something.
I feel like something's missing.
Not more idle, I...
Leaving Scout on the Dam makes a good clock.
Oh!
Like that?
Oh, that's so...
It already went down.
Oh my god, wait, it's going down really, really fast.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, it's going down really, really fast.
Um, I don't think we're gonna make it.
Yo, this is so messed up.
This is so messed up.
Go to the tower?
Instead?
Oh, I guess we could go to the tower instead.
Okay, we'll go to the tower.
You guys are right, you guys are right.
Yeah, the tower lasts longer.
You're right, you're right, you're right.
And there is...
We can't get the boat there.
Wait, how do I...
How did I...
Set that up before?
I'm trying to think.
Whoever suggested that...
Thank you so much.
That was such a smart idea.
Um...
Zero!
Wait, will we make it here?
here too.
Let me just get to the tower first, please, before you come
crashing through here.
Okay.
Okay, wake up.
Now, guys, here's the issue.
I don't quite remember.
Don't quite remember how we got the boat to reappear here.
I don't quite remember how We got this part.
Gotta loop around.
Hold on.
Gosh, there's so much.
Activate your memory neurons.
I'm trying.
Yes, you guys are right.
The door to the left.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Because I was like, we've done it before.
So...
We've done it before, so it's fine.
If you guys give me a little reminder.
Yeah, remember how you foregoer.
You're right.
I foregoer how to go places...
Or how to go through doors when they are not open.
Okay.
Now we travel.
I wish I could run faster!
Okay, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on,
come on, please come here.
Come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come
here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here,
come here, come here, come here, come here, come here,
come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come
here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come
here.
Is this the one?
I think so.
Here we are.
Full speed ahead.
Okay, maybe not so fast.
Let me be able to get off the boat, please.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my god, oh my god, this might work, this might work.
work, please, please, please, please, please, please.
I'm going the right way, right?
I see like a...
I see like a flashing.
There, do you guys see that?
Oh.
I'm in a wall.
I can't see anything.
Time is precious.
I know, but I can't see anything, you guys.
What is This is...
Quickly, quickly.
Quickly.
Wait, what's going on?
Upstairs?
Where am I?
I can't see anything again.
Wait?
Where?
What?
Um...
I've never seen anyone do the puzzle this way.
Thank you!
Oh, here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, goodness
gracious.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
It's really dark, though, so I can't see anything.
Um.
And I can get my artifact back.
Okay.
Now it opens the doors.
It's so over.
Stop.
I'm grabbing him.
Not yet.
No, yet.
It's not.
over yet I gotta put him in there we go okay okay
they went oh we think I think we've seen this one and they
cry they're so sad yeah I remember this oh this is the part
that was blacked out what is that thing it looks like a
Digimon like you know
Okay, they're like...
Let's go home!
In our dream world!
They fall asleep.
They're like happy, happy boys.
Yeah, the Digi-Divise, yeah.
Okay.
So that's what happened there.
And there was another one.
Got it?
Just had to use my leggies.
Okay.
Oh, digital Saturn.
He's walking in his...
What the hell?
It says stuff.
What?
So if I leave my...
If I drop my artifact and go too far away from it, I become
a polygon.
I literally become Polygon from Metal Gear.
Cool.
Very cool.
Yeah, PS1 Asset.
Can I go through here?
No.
Is that everything in this area?
What if I...
How...
Oh, clearly.
I really know.
Oh, whoa, what's happening?
Oh, I think my game just crashed.
Wait, no!
No way.
No,
I didn't get any of the information.
I have to exit my game.
Oh.
You got all the info from that place.
But it's not gonna update, is that okay?
If it doesn't update, and if it doesn't update and...
Actually,
now that I know it's all a simulation...
Wait, oh, wait, maybe it did update.
Forbidden Archive!
Ah!
Wait, there's more to explore here.
Okay, we gotta go back, you guys.
Who knew that this was literally VR missions?
library full of intact slide reels hidden deep underground i
found a slide reel that shows the strangers inhabitants
congregating around a strange green fire um the slide
reveals the creation of a simulated reality modeled after
their home moon i found a slide reel that wait so they're
all just like in this simulation and that's they're all like
they they like sword art aligned it like never wanted to
wake up because they all were just so much happier being at
home Oh my god!
So they're all so much dead.
It's just their, like, consciousness.
Well, if they actually wake up, they die.
Yeah, yeah.
I found a...
Oh, some sort of error report.
It shows one of the strangers as an inhabitant dropping
their artifact on the ground and walking beyond its
projection radius.
Yuni!
Thanks for the five gifted!
there's more to explore here so if I go back
I've reached the tower's upper floors by protecting a power
wait oh that's just the more to explore if I
you don't have to do everything all over again trust
there's a code in there
yeah I'm gonna try the new thing that we just learned.
That was probably the best one to start with, maybe.
I feel like...
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh, I do not know where the planet is.
One moment.
Don't crash.
Actually, buckle up, everybody.
Uh, I don't know where the stranger is.
Uh, it's some...
Um...
Uh, it's, uh...
It's, uh...
I know, hold on.
I know where it is.
It's up there, obviously.
Gosh, you guys.
It's right there.
Duh.
We're gonna try our new trick.
Our ghost trick.
The recordings are the game.
I'm just worried that...
Oh my god.
We're fine.
Anyway, um...
Do a flip.
Perfect.
Okay.
Right by the entrance.
That's where we need to go.
Wait, what was the super chat?
They did that thing where you fly to a foreign country.
Say in the hotel room, play games on your laptop the whole
time.
It's true.
Well, that was me.
But, um, involuntarily.
I'm kind of confused how I'm supposed to do this now.
So I'm guessing it's easier to avoid them.
If I can see where...
they are because of this new trick, right?
I'm guessing that's the deal, yo.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, my goodness.
Or maybe they won't even see me, who knows?
Maybe I will be able to, like, when I...
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was close.
When I did it in there, I...
was able to like walk through the walls and stuff so I'm
literally hacking their game I'm gonna hack the game so that
instead of little alien people they're all big gloomy anime
girls Jeffrey I'm hacking your game in a good way
in a good way in a good way hacked wild dot hack wild Oh my
gosh.
I only, I actually only read Dot Hack.
Um.
Uh.
I watched a little bit.
I didn't finish Dot Hack sign.
Oh, what was the, there was like one where they were cuter.
Um.
The Legend of the Twilight Bracet, I think it was.
Legend of the Something Bracet.
Legend of the Something.
She's figuring out how to actually press the button.
She's been thinking about that since the stream.
We're fine.
No, not TV.
Yeah, Legend of the Twilight.
I was like, Twilight Bracelet.
There's something with a bracelet in it, that's why.
Oh, it is Twilight Bracelet.
Legends of the Twilight.
Well, actually.
It's called Legends of the Twilight.
Well, I actually...
Um, actually, it's called Legends of the Twilight.
I listen to the sign, OST, like, weekly.
Yeah, because it's, like, Katsuura Yuki.
God composer.
Tobeys!
Thanks for the 10 gift, and thank you!
I'm surprised we haven't seen more...
...the attacks.
I don't know.
Just feels like...
It's not another... like a franchise that they would
continue.
Unless I... unless there has been, and I just don't know.
SAO killed it?
No!
I don't think so.
I know people would compare it, but...
I think they're different enough.
You know?
So if I just leave this here...
See ya!
Oh.
Um... an attempt...
To leave.
I'm walking up the stairs.
Maybe I should have left.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe this was a bad idea.
Hold on.
Oh, you guys.
You guys.
Oh!
I'm good?
Oh.
When does it activate?
I'm stuck in a corner.
Oh, okay, that...
Oh, shoot.
I saw light for a second.
I'm looking around.
I'm turning my head.
We had jump.
I'm stuck!
Oh!
What do you think that is?
Wait, what do you think that is?
Tower staircase.
Wait, so where am I?
Lost.
Light from the fire.
Um.
Ah!
Fact!
Anyway, okay, let's continue.
Okay, I'm gonna leave it right...
Right here.
Whoa!
There's even a...
Do you think I can fall onto that?
I
think I can fall onto that.
Anyway.
Little flip!
Okay, second go!
Well, we tried.
There was an attempt.
Shaa!
Wow!
This is so beautiful!
Oh!
Oh my god!
This is so pretty!
Game changer!
For real!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Wow!
Still, this doesn't work though.
The game is borked.
Wait, can I...
Oh, but it's still...
The lights still need to be off.
And I can't go through here either.
Okay.
We still need to turn the lights off though.
But let's explore a little bit, I think.
But also...
Like also, well the grabby...
Like how will I work the grabby grabs?
Yeah, see I can't even get over.
Yeah.
Okay.
But now if I turn it off, it's so easy to get over there.
I'll have to forfeit my artifact though.
I love VR chat!
Yeah,
wait, can I take that hidden path with my artifact?
I like the music even with it.
Hold on.
Okay, wait.
What's the...
Is it this one?
No.
This one.
Yes.
Push.
My shoes!
And now, I don't, I'm not quite sure if the path works.
I guess it would, because there was that hidden path, right?
Is it here?
Oh, God, wait.
It's here, right?
I'm scared.
Wait.
I don't want to fall into the abyss.
Let's just check.
We can set it down and we can check.
Drop.
Whoa.
Okay, okay, okay.
Way more to the right.
Wow!
I guess I just...
You just never think to drop your thing, right?
Like...
You just never think to get rid of your artifact, so...
Oh.
Crazy.
Mind the gap.
I wonder now though Wait, which one is it?
This goes outside So it's this one
I'm curious if I just go without Oh my goodness Uh oh Oh
it's already off Okay, never mind, my bad I wonder if I go
Without even holding this thing I'm kind of curious what
will happen
I'm just gonna drop it
Okay.
Just curious.
Huh.
What else is down there?
What's going on down there?
How are you going to use the elevator?
Oh.
Good question.
But let me see.
I want to see if there's a guy down here too.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Have your spine adjusted by a pursuer?
Oh, and I came...
Okay, I still have it though.
Wow.
Okay, so that guy is not so nice.
That guy is a little mean.
Hmm.
Okay, cool.
Well, there is a guy down there.
Good to know.
Still think they're friendly?
you guys um but i was just like i don't think they're
friendly it was you guys that were just like no they're
friendly uh he's mad because i clearly it turned off his tv
shows i don't know if i have enough time but we can try i
really don't think i have a lot of time left this makes me
just want to play everything
without okay without the artifact.
Did it get shorter?
Oh, I walked off the right.
Oh.
You have to point at the elevator.
One more time!
Shortest nap in existence.
I nap for one second.
Can you...
Gosh.
to be able to just close my eyes and fall asleep i have a
lot of trouble falling asleep you know i'm like always i'll
be i'll be rolling around for like
okay so the elevator is that the elevator
keep the little tree on each side of your
I can't with this.
We're gonna...
The tower's gonna fall at this rate.
It's all my fault, though.
Hold on, I'm gonna put this here.
And we're gonna...
I'm just gonna go check, okay?
Okay.
What is my landmark?
Tree?
In between the trees.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
I hope I don't get caught by the guy.
I'm gonna be getting scared.
Okay.
Like that?
Wait.
Over a little bit more, maybe.
Oh, it's so hard to see that one.
Yippee!
We made it!
We made it just in time!
No, I don't want to go back down there, I'll be honest.
I'm too scared to go back down there.
Now sprint past one guy.
Okay.
Okay,
we're back here.
I love the music in this room.
It's so epic.
I don't think we have a lot of time.
So time is not of the essence.
We gotta figure out what we're doing.
Which means I'm putting this sucker down like right now.
right here and I'm walking away and I'm gonna go to this
thing over here okay open oh oh it's corrupted but maybe it
won't be corrupted in the real world JK get owned hold on
maybe it's normal here oh it's not
uh okay what else can what else what else is weird in this
weird world okay
we're cold yeah oh it's because the lights wait not to put
them in into here right Oh, that was it.
That's it for this place.
No way.
It was for a nonsense useless code.
That didn't even exist.
What if I had discovered that on accident?
What if I had put the thing in and then what?
Wow.
Whoa, it's that light over there.
Where are we?
Where are we in this video game world?
Hmm.
Ohio.
Very funny.
Now you know the shortcut better.
Yeah.
I mean, do I have to come back here?
Maybe eventually to figure out how to fix it.
this right it's all corrupted oh
okay I was just gonna wait for the there's also a screen
over there so those are the other ones that we have to get
I'm assuming.
This is the...
This is...
The screen.
I think there's nothing else, right?
I think that's it.
Yeah.
I think we can wake up and...
Or I think we can just meditate until the next level.
Okay.
Very good everybody.
Good job.
Why can't you see the scrolls or the slides in here though?
How peculiar.
Oh!
I like... I like died died!
I don't know how to swim!
That's interesting.
Two more locations to solve, yep.
One of them I'm really not looking forward to!
One of them I'm really...
Wait.
Huh?
Didn't I just meditate until the next one?
Yeah, I wasn't holding the fire so I actually drowned
drowned.
Oh, that's right, I meditated close to the fire.
I remember, I remember, I remember.
Okay.
Good loop, everybody.
I remember.
You got world-breaking knowledge now.
I know, you're right.
Okay, let's see.
If I go in here, not even the system knows what to tell.
It's like, um, I don't even know what to tell you, man.
Oh, here.
There's a container marked with one of the vault seals, but
its contents have been destroyed.
Yay!
We got it!
Okay.
Shrouded Woodlands is...
Uh...
The one with the boat.
Right?
how will people please fix the first one okay
um and then this is the tower
we still have the sealed vaults but we know so much more now
than before
you have new knowledge yeah we have new knowledge
In fact, I'm thinking, well, I should probably go to these
two first before I go.
I was going to go to the submerged structure and sleep there
and see what happens at the lake.
But I will refrain, maybe for now, until we do these two
other ones.
Or I could do that as a break.
Try it.
I was going to say maybe do it as a break from...
from these so that I'm...
Since I'm scared...
Security, baby?
Look at this all started with a radio tower.
Alright.
So let's go to the submerged structure.
I'm coming!
Okay.
Cool!
Is there any part of the game which doesn't scare you?
What are you talking about?
What?
I'm scaredy baby.
I'm scaredy baby, please understand.
Coming in hot.
Do a flip!
Okay, sorry, here, here.
I'm suckling.
Actually, I am kind of hungry.
All right, everybody, teeth out.
I'm hungry.
I'm hungry!
You know that person earlier that was just like, have you
ever thought of chat as your baby?
Oh wait, let's get this.
Sorry, I know I always get this one.
I just think it's really easy.
It's like so fast and easy to get to it.
Well, it would be if I didn't get the post.
Stuck out.
Wait, this is it, this is it, this is it.
You know, they were just like, do you think of chat as your
babies?
And I was like, no.
What if you thought me as a baby?
Your baby.
Would you treat me better?
You were like, I gave birth to this ghost.
Or death?
Kind of complicated, isn't it?
Are we allowed to?
I don't know, your name is the bravery duck.
Are you brave enough?
Why'd you have to go and die so soon?
I'm not into baby play
That's fine We'll go to Nile Perch And we'll all get new
outfits Together And if you don't know what Nile Perch is
Just look it up and tell me It's like It's like the cutest
brand ever But I can never wear a single thing Oh actually
that's a lie I bought a beret from them once But everything
else I'm like I can't I can't buy, I just, I just can't buy
from this brand because I would never be able to wear it at
home ever.
You were doing a baby RP and I took a nap and I woke up and
you were still doing a baby.
Why'd you sleep during my stream?
You're not feeding the alligator.
Oh, wait, we don't have to go to the right.
I'm just remembered.
Just remembered.
We can go straight.
Don't, this is a clipper.
sleeping on the job don't sleep during my stream fine i'll
do asmr or something god is that what you want god stop
pulling my gosh you're really yanking my arm here with this
just like non-stop do asmr me too actually i think my asmr i
have an asmr mic but i think it needs to i think it needs
new batteries i think i forgot to turn it off
Nile, perch is apparently also just a straight-up fish.
It is!
I had no idea.
Okay, to the submerged place.
We're gonna keep our boat here.
Please, please, please.
You guys know that Sabrina Carpenter song?
I've kind of been listening.
to it a lot.
Heartbreak is one thing, my ego is another.
Don't ever something embarrass me.
She goes so low, motherfucker.
She goes so low there.
I was singing it earlier while I was getting ready for
stream, while I was thinking, how late should I be today?
I was singing it.
Pulling your locomotive limb.
What does that mean?
I've only heard her name like yesterday.
She's like the hot, hotness right now, you know?
It's just kind of the hotness.
I like her music.
I think it's cute.
Let's leave our little buddy here.
Right here.
Oh.
Towards the exit.
Thank you.
Oh.
It's probably fine.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
Oh, there they are.
And then there's a beam of light that comes down that makes
us visible.
Oh, there's also parkour.
Oh, the power thing just went out.
There's also a boat that goes directly here.
Oh my god, he's like half...
Can I see inside?
Ah!
Yes, we've seen this already.
I'm bored.
Stop, I've seen this already.
You can see the platforms.
Vision jump scare.
Walk out of it.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Um...
I still am not quite sure, unless I have a box, I don't
really...
I'm not really quite sure what to do here.
I was hoping that maybe if I...
Wait.
I see what I can do.
If I go along the railing...
Hold on.
Let's go get our thing.
I didn't think I said that last stream too.
I was like, what if...
Oh my god, leave me alone.
I don't care about your vision.
He's like, wait, wait, wait.
It's like a tech bro.
I was wondering.
I was like, I wonder if I...
Go along the railing if that will work.
I'm crawling.
Oh.
No worries.
It means no worries for the rest of your day I...
Oh.
It's our problem.
What if I drop?
Damn.
That was a far drop.
You can't solve it yet.
Yeah, I don't think so.
What's wrong with me?
Okay.
We're gonna get out of here.
We have other places to be.
I think the dam is about to explode.
Um...
I think we should Go over here Towards Yes Right there Okay
And Nice Okay Okay Okay Okay Okay I feel kind of bad for
them They were just so like Yeah we hate it here We're just
like We're just gonna go to virtual world And become VTubers
for real
I ask myself that question every day About yourself?
Or about me?
Uh Guys
I don't think we have much time Both Sadly about you What
are you doing?
What do you- what do you- what do you- what do you- what do
you mean by this?
Why?
Why me?
21 20.
We'll go to the tower.
19.
18.
17.
15 14 13
12 I don't think we're gonna make it though to the tower,
we'll say it 10
Nine!
Oh, maybe we will.
30 seconds left?
Oh, we might make it then.
Maybe.
Well, no.
Not 30.
Maybe?
Actually, I can't tell.
Oh, we'll make it.
We'll definitely make it.
Five hours ago.
Wow, it's already been five hours of streaming?
Holy cow.
Even I'm shocked by that.
No way!
What time is it?
Oh my gosh, it's 8pm?!
What?
Wowie.
Okay.
Um, I don't care, I sleep.
What was that?
What are you getting all upset for?
Unless he died.
That was pretty freaky.
Aha!
So, oh, wait!
Okay, wait, I just wanted to see what this looked like
because I knew that we weren't going to have a lot of time.
But I did want to see what this looked like.
Why are we still walking around?
Okay, what was it?
We go down here.
Then we go halfway.
we blow it out.
But I'm trying to see if there's any shortcuts we can do.
Because they're going to be... You guys are going to be
walking around once we...
Oh, I thought that was him.
I was like, he's a spider!
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my gosh.
That's kind of crazy.
They're going to be walking around.
And I don't quite see how we get down here.
Oh, wait.
okay hold on hold on I see I see so now we're figuring this
out because we go this way we go down and then around and
then through okay okay okay there's the other guy you can
see him up there okay I see this was helpful Do you ever
check the other door on the left?
I wonder, actually, is it a shortcut?
Let's see.
I don't know where these guys are going to be wandering
around, is an issue for me.
This door over here.
I can't remember if I did or not.
Maybe that's easier.
Hold on, we can go check right now.
I can go check right now.
Void.
But if we're coming from the boat, it's hard to say which
one of it will be easier, you know.
Yeah, so there's the elevator.
So we'll be coming from that end over there.
Yeah.
We'll be coming from...
Over here.
there so hmm and then I'm just gonna go downstairs and see
what happens this is just a this is just getting us oh
I thought it was the bad I thought it was the music of lose
music of you're done I'm just getting a feel of the area
Okay, so down here.
I can go through here?
Is anyone around here?
I'm scared.
Oh, no, there's a loop down here, which means somebody was
gonna be down here.
There's a loop, there's a loop.
God.
Okay.
Well, now we know.
What is their vision like, though, you know?
okay all right so we take the boat we blow it out okay now
now that i know how this works what is a way that i can
avoid avoid having to do this in the manner that must be
done you know what i mean hmm how can i how can i big brain
this just like the other one.
You turn off the game.
The DLC got redesigned to make it easier to bypass the
aliens.
Oh, really?
You won't cheese this one.
Alrighty.
Well, we know what we must do.
We go to the other side.
We, uh, We blow out these lights, we come back, an attempt
to go around.
I'm just gonna trust your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer.
I played the old design of the DLC.
It was hell.
Really?
So, actually, I'm curious.
Now that we know, or now that I know about, like, what's
going on, if I turn on baby mode, what does it...
What does it change?
The enemies move slower when chasing you.
Oh, they chase you slower.
Oh.
Dumber AI.
Still just a spoofie.
Oh, see, that's not that bad.
I figured they'd be chasing after me, so I feel like that
wasn't even really a spoiler.
Did I get anything new?
Oh.
The wall at the bottom of the village is guarded by a statue
that actually Activates an alarm bell when it sees me.
Astute observation.
Thank you.
Well, as long as I'm faster than them, all I have to do is
run, right?
As long as I'm faster than them, I just book it, right?
Okay.
Here we go!
To the tower.
To the tower, to the tower, to the tower.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
coming in hot.
Oh, coming in hot.
Do a flip.
And we're good.
It's just a glass.
We're never coming back here ever again anyway.
Goodbye ship.
Goodbye.
Goodbye world.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
you say goodbye to ship?
Say goodbye, ship!
I hardly knew he.
Okay, oh, oh, okay.
And let's get our artifact.
I never liked that ship anyway.
What?
What did this ship do to you?
So after, after I do, I mean, this seems like pretty oh that
was close pretty big puzzles after these i'm guessing
there's i have to figure out a way to unscramble the code so
then we can unlock it
every time i'm just like i don't know what else i have to do
in this game it always surprises me ship during base game oh
my precious baby ship during dlc Smell you later, Stinky.
That's because I needed my precious baby before.
Now, he just gets me to this place, and now it's all about
boats.
It's all about boat, baby.
Ain't that part of the fun.
So true.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Ugh.
i'll be honest though you guys think i'm gonna finish today
if i go for like another how long has it been one second oh
i can exit out of all these paint windows now
get rid of you oh sorry it keeps like auto intoing auto
returning to the game Oh, I just, oh shoot, I just exited
out of one of the codes, but it should be okay.
Okay, my RB still works.
You are in the latter half.
Awesome!
But it depends.
It's possible, but it depends.
All right.
Guys, we're just gonna big brain everything, okay?
We're gonna big brain everything.
Can you even finish a one hour of brain think good?
No way.
brain um might need a break brain might need food actually
okay is there now that i think about it is there anything i
need to do here hold on i'm thinking is there anything i
need to do here um to make things easier for me no the
elevator elevator was up
any Mike Tyson's ass
I think we're I think it's not like before I don't think
it's like before I think we can just go if not then I guess
FML well really FMAL and then I'm really scared of I'm
really scared because before I was like, I could just chase
her.
It's great!
Now I know I cannot.
But conceal.
And walk.
And that's the thing that sees me.
So now I'm good.
And here we go about halfway through.
Where are you?
There it is.
Whoa!
Elevator.
Downwards?
Upwards?
Upwards.
Oh, nice.
Wait, what's over here?
Hold on a second!
They didn't show me this in the visions?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Where does it take me?
Oh, oh, wait.
Look at the...
I took a nap and woke up.
Why are you all taking naps?
Um.
What was I going to say?
Yeah, it said endurance in the title, so I really am
planning.
I'm really wanting to finish the game today.
Okay.
We just lost the electricity.
Also, I noticed that sometimes my controller rumbles, and
sometimes it doesn't.
So, in some places, we're closer.
Oh, nope.
Never mind, there's the rumble.
Let's see.
I wonder if I can, like, jump from here and then run over to
the elevator.
I think that will be our best bet, I think.
You'll just need to cook.
Okay, well, you know what?
We have so many kitchen, or so many, so many cooks in the
kitchen, right?
We have so many cooks in the kitchen.
I think we'll be good.
You weren't even watching TV.
Why do you care?
Oh.
There you go.
Wait.
What the?
Oh, they're coming down.
Vento.
Thanks for the gifted.
Wait, are they just taking the elevator up and down and up
and down?
Oh, no.
I think they went down.
Oh?
Wow.
Very cool.
Oh, no!
Um.
Nice.
Actually, I wonder if this works even better.
because we can take that shortcut on the left, right?
Why is he able to turn his light on?
Why can't he have his light on all the time?
I also can't hear them walking.
Before they were like so thumpy.
But now it's actually very...
hard.
To hear them walking around.
Do you think he's in here?
I'm so- I don't- I don't- I don't- I don't want to fall in
the water.
Okay, this way.
It's so dark!
I think I hear footsteps.
I'm scared to turn off my light.
I'm actually so scared to turn off my light, you guys.
Do you think it's okay?
I can hear it.
I didn't see nothing.
Is that better for you?
Okay, I'm gonna turn on the light.
Oh.
What's happening?
What's this music?
What is this?
What is this sound?
What is that noise?
He was right in front of me.
No!
You!
Why don't you want me here?
So that's what that music was.
Yeah, clearly.
Oh.
That's...
That's the dam breaking.
I think the guy...
Is downstairs.
Legit jump scare.
I know, right?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do this again.
Hmm.
Will they see if I focus light?
that she found out what that noise is i have not
what what wait did i go in the water or did i get caught i
guess i got i guess i went in the water oh my god oh
gosh luckily it's easy enough to get over there you guys say
I need to use my brain well it's really just I need to I
need to get this to work I need to get over there
I'm just gonna walk if I get caught if I see me we only have
We're on, we're, we're living on borrowed time.
I don't, I think he's all the way on the other side, so.
Set down the lantern.
Oh!
Here.
Try not to fall in the water.
I think I'm in front of a rock.
Don't fall.
Don't drown.
Um.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Guys.
Okay.
I know what.
I'm gonna...
Before I set it down, I'm gonna see what the water situation
is.
I'm gonna see what the water situation is.
And then...
Then I'll walk away.
And then I'll...
And then I'll go, I think.
The Mintu sold the outer world.
Okay.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
We understand how it works now.
We go off and then we go... We pivot straight to the right.
Gotta put it right here.
We'll come back for you.
All right, I see that.
When?
When does it happen?
When does?
It
sounds cute.
Oh my god.
Fine.
Did you see something?
directly at me again that's what i saw why can't he at least
he have a light you know i think that's the most frustrating
part because i really can't hear him at all i can't hear his
footsteps he will turn around once he starts looking i
i know
you guys are gonna hate me.
No, you know what?
Never mind.
I give up.
Okay, he's there.
Yeah, thanks a whole lot.
Idiot, you're also dead.
Black screen makes me sleepy.
I took too long.
Yeah, no shit.
I know, but it's...
Oh my god, all my footage is just black screen.
It's... It's...
Oh, wait!
Are the... Are some of them... Wait, some of the things...
When it shows out of the game, it doesn't show that.
Interesting.
This area was the spookiest.
Really?
Not the one with the...
the house or like the the concert hall one that one seems
the scariest for me this is this is tricky though it's
because I can't see them that area was the hardest for me so
yeah you can't see them you can't you can barely hear them
it's it's tricky it's tricky
This area is really...
It's only difficult before you pass it through at the first
time.
So maybe if I, like...
Like, if I can't outrun him...
But I have to have my light off anyway for when I...
Go to the...
When I go to the...
Do a flip!
The hole anyway.
just have it on run to where i need to be and then turn it
off when i get there maybe focus the light on them i could
do that too yeah
the focusing the light scares me the most because it's like
having to switch between it and um covering the light i'll
have to practice a little little bit.
Oh, of course I forgot to push my wrap.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
Frozen.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
I'm struggling a little, guys.
I'm struggling.
Blip.
There we go.
Okay.
I feel like this is stealth but it also doesn't count so
much because i have to seems like i have to get caught
justin thanks for the 10 gift thank you thank you oh yeah
yeah
good night mint and that good night oh yeah i haven't even i
didn't realize how late it was now i'm realizing i haven't
had dinner yet I will have to do that at some point.
I'll have to take another break.
Short break, though, just to eat.
But it's only been six hours, so...
This one?
Oh,
I forgot to wake up.
There we go.
Okay, so I...
I can focus.
So I can focus and then close.
And then open and close.
Okay, okay.
Good to know.
So now we go this way.
I wonder...
Okay.
Hold on real quick.
I'm putting my thing down.
And I'm gonna go in a straight line.
I just want to see...
I think the elevator is the only way down, right?
I can't...
I can't actually can't see.
But it seems...
What do ghosts eat?
I just possess somebody that...
Could be you.
What are you having for dinner tonight?
Possess somebody and then I...
You know...
Just have what they're having.
Okay.
Pretty much.
Oh wait, there's an elevator here.
But these all... I wouldn't be able to make it.
Right?
Showing me where all the elevators are.
Wait, okay, hold on.
If I have to wake back up, I wake back up.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
That... I didn't mean to happen.
Sorry.
Okay.
The real enemy is the gravity.
Truly a terror.
Door?
Door.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm checking again.
Okay.
Where this leads to?
If it's the only way I can go over there.
I think it's the quote-unquote easiest, though.
I think it was...
I think it's the quote-unquote easiest way.
Unless it's, like, in a cave in here.
But then there's also a guy stalking the night, so...
It's not so good.
Wait...
Okay.
Mint is too spicy of a flavor?
Even I can have mint, and I can't have anything spicy.
Are you sure?
Mint too spicy.
Okay.
We're going up.
Light it up.
Oh.
I hear, like, him walking around here, too.
So I'm kind of curious who comes this way.
And up, like, this elevator.
Is there a guy over there?
And I just don't notice him.
Is there a guy in there?
Are there three guys?
How many guys are there?
I don't know.
So I think...
Just finish the deal.
see on my end what absolutely 10 out of 10 experience good
look kyle how did you get past this bar kyle help kyle test
get there kyle
five guys
i love five guys yummy no help i hate you all oh you know
what you know what you mean You think she hates us?
It's real.
It's true.
It's the truth.
Oh.
It's like he sees me, you guys.
I lived.
Oh, he's coming.
Hey, how'd you get here?
Hey.
Leave me alone.
Hey, hey, hey!
Hey, leave me alone!
I think you gave up.
Let's go back.
I think you got me.
Oh, bing bong!
You're setting up your own alarm!
Kankan, everybody, wake up!
Wake up!
What if I just blew out all of their flames?
Wouldn't that be kind of diabolical?
That would save me so much time.
Why can't I blow out their flames, huh?
They're two dead asleep.
Oh, gosh.
Now we're back to where we started.
There's an extinguish on everything.
You just go up and you extinguish it.
extinguish their own fires.
Yeah, take that.
You don't want me hanging around here?
I don't want you hanging around here either.
Oh, there goes.
I'm running out of time.
I'm stalling too much.
Oh, this way.
Here it comes.
Whoa.
I think I hear him to my right.
So I'm just gonna go straight.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Run!
Ah!
That sounded like he was on my right.
Guess not.
Herthian lungs are too small to blow out their flames.
Okay, then I'm gonna get a bucket of water.
I'm gonna cup the water in my hands, and I'm just gonna
douse them.
This guy is such a...
Freak!
Yeah, carry a squirt gun.
I think I'm already screwed.
Is he coming this way, you think?
Or did he give up?
I wonder if there's a way I can sneak past him there.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh...
Maybe I do need the baby mode on just so I can progress.
Maybe I need baby mode on so I can progress through the
game.
Oh.
I'm hungry.
Just give him the runaround.
Oh, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
I just gotta...
He's faster than me, though.
He's pretty fast.
It is a skill issue, 100% yeah.
Yeah, you could say it.
Skill issue, yeah, whatever.
It's a skill issue.
Pretty much.
What am I looking at?
I think I'm looking in the wrong direction.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I turned around.
Trying to troll him a little bit.
What are my lights coming from over there?
You don't know.
Ha ha ha.
How do I get to the other...
Don't turn around, mister.
Where's the exit?
Oh, I found it.
He's not coming still here.
Now I need to know how to not fall into the water here!
Oh, you guys, I probably should just meditate and redo this.
I don't think I'm gonna have enough time.
Okay.
So close.
I think it's just the one guy.
I sure hope so.
Please be honest, guys.
There's no one else.
Buy the...
I will cry.
If there's someone else buy the actual thing.
Okay.
Don't just put smileys!
You guys know I'm struggling and you hate me so much!
You just hate me!
I'm having so much fun in my death loop
Please stop noticing me Please stop noticing me Why does
elevator have to go back up?
Stop noticing me please Run past him, he'll definitely He's
definitely gonna grab me Oh shit.
Oh, there's not land there.
I thought that was my own vision.
I thought that was my own vision going nutty.
All I am is frustrated.
So used to going to the flight log.
Okay.
Let's go all the way back.
Coming in hot.
You know what?
Let's come in hot.
Better now.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's get our artifact.
How far can this...
There we go.
Now we'll always know.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
But I have to put this away.
I have to put it away, though, don't I?
To get the thing.
Actually, maybe...
Maybe I can't do that.
Because we have to grab the...
to grab the artifact.
Oh,
it still works.
Nice.
Okay.
It's my endurance, okay.
I'm just... I'm just frustrated.
It's all...
I think because I'm getting hangry.
But I'm like wanting to do this before I eat.
I don't want to take a break because I just want to get
through it.
Because we've made no progress in probably like a fucking
hour.
And that annoys me.
Well right now, I'm not...
I'm less than okay, but I'm okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Viewers are encouraging a streamer called Minto who is
overcoming a threat.
Okie dokie.
Alright, let's go back to the boat.
And blow out the candles!
And then...
I wonder though...
Hold on.
Before we do so.
Let's get a...
Let's get a little more...
acclimated.
With our...
With our terrain.
So we go down here.
There's no one here, right?
No one here.
So if I just go, well, okay, where's the...
Okay.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
So here, we can go here.
Okay, this is...
Oh, that scared me.
This is what I was trying to find.
I thought it was another bridge.
I knew there was another bridge, but I thought it was like
immediate.
So if he starts seeing me here, then I can just run here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
See, that's what was tripping me up a lot.
And then here,
it's just straight from in here.
Just straight.
It's going to see me in the light, though.
I shouldn't have lit.
I didn't know there were candles there.
Straight until you hit the candles and then to the left.
And then we go down the stairs.
Alright, that should help a little bit.
I thought I knew what I was doing before, but I did not.
I just don't know when he'll give up.
But...
Music freaked me out for a second.
Okay.
Will he?
Well, maybe not.
But if he doesn't, whatever, I guess.
If he does, that's...
That's pretty cool.
If he doesn't, well, we'll just keep on going.
Okay, I just felt the power thing go out.
Oh, wrong thing.
There we go.
Oh, I heard the bells for like two seconds.
That's so funny.
Can't catch me today, sucker.
And have a good day.
Okay.
Oh.
Nope.
Can use your light a bit to avoid drowning.
Yeah, I think I will have it up.
I think it's fine to have it up if I'm, like, running away
from him.
Oh, wait.
No.
I can't have the light because I'll get spotted and the
bells will go off.
Well, I'll have to, like, quickly conceal it.
though.
Okay.
Let's not waste any more time.
I'm just gonna drown or die or something.
I'm just gonna so we can quickly get back to the beginning.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Please, please, please.
Hopefully I can game.
Please let me game.
Please.
I think I I just heard the thing's still going down, the
elevators.
Please let me game.
Okay, so it was, it was distract him, have him come forward,
go to the right.
Don't die in the water.
Right?
I think.
I think?
Across the bridge.
Yeah, but I won't even be able to see the bridge, right?
He's gonna be coming after me, right?
So...
Straight but hug the right wall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can flicker your life to see it.
Okay.
Okay, here it is.
So it's here.
Hey dummy.
Yeah, come here.
He just showed me the exit.
Don't look this way.
Oh shit.
Yeah?
What are you seeing?
What are you seeing, huh?
Oh gosh.
Straight?
I think I still hear him coming.
Where am I?
Where's...
Is there an elevator coming in here?
I'm scared.
Is there...
Is there an elevator?
Shoot!
No!
Oh!
You made it to face down!
You might want to put the light down to get a better look.
I don't even know where I can put it down.
Put the light down upstairs.
If I can't even see anything!
Oh.
Shit.
I'm stuck.
I'm trapped somewhere.
I'm going downstairs.
Screw it.
I'm lost in the sauce.
Put it down now?
Okay.
You won't see me, though, right?
So...
Let me go upstairs.
Oh, there's two of them!
No way.
There's two of them.
Okay.
How did I avoid both of them?
It's kind of impressive, right?
Impressive in its own right, maybe?
Okay, over here...
Here?
No, wow, this is really obnoxious.
Who designed this?
Who designed this level?
Is that it, right?
Oh, here, here, here.
Oh, and there's a light thing.
Oh my god!
What?
Jeopardy!
So I'm kind of in like the worst position.
in here.
I should have never come all the way down here.
I'm kind of in a really bad spot right now at the moment,
actually.
I wish that was you.
I wish that was you right now.
I wish that was one of you guys.
I don't even... There's a room over here.
Where does this lead to?
An elevator?
Okay.
Um...
This used to be harder, by the way.
That's insane.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's all the way over there by the room where we
need to be at.
Go!
Okay, hold on.
I can't even figure out how to get around.
Okay, so it's up here.
It's up here.
Wish you had a Soliton radar.
I know.
Okay.
What?
Can I see where?
No, no, go away!
Go away!
Oh my god!
I think this is where he's usually roaming and I tricked him
earlier.
Maybe?
I can't tell.
He's circling.
I don't know where the other guy is.
Hold on, let me see where he's at before we continue.
Oh, sheesh.
Where is he?
This is so messed up.
He's camping.
I'm going to have to get through all of this.
Oh my god.
There's no way, you guys.
There's no way.
There's no way I can do this.
I don't even know where the other guy is.
Wait, there's a spoiler mode.
What does that mean?
What do you mean?
Is there a bridge over here?
Oh, in the darkness.
They're both on the bridge, maybe?
No, I don't think so.
Oh, he went down here, I think.
I think maybe he's...
I see someone over there.
I don't know what he's doing.
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, guys, oh, guys, oh, guys,
oh, guys.
I don't see him there now, well...
This is...
Oh!
Already?
Where at?
I'm just gonna go...
till I can hear no more.
Okay.
What the
hell?
Why am I stuck on the stairs what what am i stuck on
actually what what am i stuck on um i'm stuck you can't get
me can i outrun them oh shit wait oh wait no i'm going the
right way
how did i manage to get so lucky How did I manage to get so
lucky?
Ah!
Wait, but do I have enough time to explore this area?
Is the bigger question.
Okay, there's a lot here.
Let's get this ball rolling.
Wait, I can't see.
Actually, wait.
Drop, side row.
No, no, no.
Here we go.
There we go.
Insert.
Here we go.
Yes!
XE, thanks for the tech gifted.
Okay.
The eye.
They're like, yes, we love the eye.
Eye is my favorite thing.
Just kidding.
Eye will destroy the universe.
Crush, it will destroy all our planets.
It will even destroy me.
I will just become bone.
A new life will happen.
Oh my god.
No, the eye sucks.
We hate the eye.
Eye sucks.
Burn the eye.
Eye is the worst thing ever.
Oh, build a
thing to trap the eye.
Huh?
Put the used ones here.
Okay.
Eye is canceled.
So, yeah, they blocked the signal of the eye.
It was, like, doing its thing, and then they were like,
Like, no, no, no, no, we don't care about you anymore.
Oh, bing bong, bing bong.
Oh, brain says time to awaken.
Oh, my God.
He's dead!
Bing bong, bing bong.
Everybody wake up!
No signal then.
They stay.
That's why they're not waking up.
Okay, that makes sense.
There's no...
No activity up there.
He's just like me for real, for real.
There's not a single thought of...
Brain.
Too much brain rot.
Oh, this is literally me.
Okay, brain.
The brain.
You go in here.
And it monitors your brain.
Brain good.
Brain not so good.
Oh, you're asleep.
You're in the gate.
You're playing Sword Art Online.
Oh, yes, Grandpa.
Oh, they're like...
Oh, my God, Grandpa!
No, no, no, no.
Grandpa, Grandpa, Grandpa.
No brain activity.
Literally me.
Oh, but he made it.
Because he fell asleep.
An eternal sleep.
He's like, ooh.
I like the music here.
Ooh, I'm Grandpa.
Grandpa lived.
He's in the game.
What else is... Oh, here.
Oh, come on.
You...
You!
I'm gonna drop the artifact here.
I'm gonna walk away.
And we're gonna go into the game world now.
Now.
Uh.
What else can we see in here?
Well, um, not much.
Hold on.
What?
Oh, I need that.
I need you actually...
Let's see.
Okay.
We need you to open that up.
There's more here.
I can't extinguish these because I'm a stupid alien.
So that's it?
That was it.
We got everything here?
I think?
Got what you needed?
Okay, cool.
Oh, we did it, you guys!
We did it!
Oh, I'm so relieved.
Oh, man.
I'm so relieved right now.
Holy moly.
Okay, that means just one more and then we figure out what
the heck is going on with these.
Holy cow.
Um, I guess I'll die?
Okay.
Oh.
You guys have no brain.
Ah, brainless, stupid.
No activity.
Nothing going on up there.
You wish...
You wish you could have a single thought, but you can't.
You have no thoughts, no thoughts, no thoughts.
this one's for me I want to have no thoughts too all right
now I'm gonna go make food and and I'm I'm going to then
we'll do the last one which was the house there
I'm nervous, though, that...
Um...
Good night, Minto.
Thanks for streaming.
Good night!
I'm still streaming.
Don't worry if you guys, you know, I'm still... I'm still
gonna be here.
I'm still standing.
I'm nervous about the next one, though, because it seems
more difficult, but maybe it's not...
Maybe it's okay.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Back from food, what did I miss?
Jeffrey, I finally did it.
I finally- Jeffrey!
You put me through hell, man.
Oh, I think this one is the most difficult.
Wait, the one we just did or the one that we're about to do?
Because I sure hope it's the one we just did.
Oh yeah, I was pretty mad at you, Jeffrey.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, the next one's the easiest one, IMO.
I'm glad to get the harder ones out of the way then, you
know, because...
Forbidden Archive.
Wow!
A library full of intact slide reels hidden deep
underground.
There's a container marked with one of the vault seals.
But, blah, blah, blah.
It's been destroyed.
I found a slide reel that shows the stranger's inhabitants
analyzing the eye of the universe.
Intact slides reveal the construction and launch of a
spacecraft designed to block the eye's signal.
Yeah.
What do I do?
What?
Hmm.
reel that shows two artifacts being lit near a green fire.
Wait, so are we gonna have to do something to like destroy
the craft that is blocking the eye signal?
I wonder.
I found a slide reel that shows two artifacts being lit near
a green fire.
The first artifact lights after its bear falls asleep, and
the second artifact lights after its bear dies.
I found a slide reel that appears to be some sort of error
report.
It shows an alarm bell failing to wake up the stranger's
inhabitants.
Okay, I'm gonna let you guys listen to the music while I go
get some...
We're going back to the...
I think this is the first time I've ever taken the lift
down, now that I think about it.
I'm gonna give you some of this ASMR.
I'm gonna get food real quick.
Oh, real real quick, real real quick.
And I'll be back.
Once I...
once i have some food okay barely
i'm back with food yippee yippee yippee
okay food break everybody food break dinner break scatter no
Don't leave!
I'm checking my notifications.
If I'm ever midstream and you guys see that the Delta
Collectors Edition goes on sale somewhere, will you guys let
me know?
Tempted to grab some mallows.
I know, right?
I bought a, like, a portable...
marshmallows like it's it's really like a portable fire but
it's intended uses for marshmallows and you get some stuff
like some stuff starter and you pour it in the center and
then because I always I had like a my favorite thing about
marshmallows is how when they get toasty so like it have to
be set on fire you know what I mean and
And so, I got that.
And, um, because I originally bought, I really like, I don't
know, maybe I just really like toasted marshmallows.
Because I had bought one before, but it only, like, heated
it up, you know?
So, it still made it gooey, but I like the crunchy.
Mmm.
It only made it kind of gooey.
But I love burnt marshmallow, so.
Crunchy, yeah.
Yeah, when they're up, when they have the crunch on the
outside and then you can peel off the skin and then you can
eat the burnt skin.
So good.
Crunch your blush.
Yeah!
I'm jealous I want s'mores.
I don't have them right now.
Two words, toaster oven.
Yeah, but then I can put it on the stick myself.
Like I want to be able to roast it myself.
It brings out my child.
It makes me go.
Here, look!
Come here, child!
Come on out!
I miss making s'mores with my friends.
If you miss it, then you should do it.
You say, hey guys, today we're making s'mores.
You get marshmallows in the shape of squares.
No, I normally just get the normal marshmallow.
Have a child!
Let me on the raft!
Never had s'mores?
I'll be honest.
I like just the burnt marshmallow more than the s'mores.
Usually, if I have an option for s'mores...
Because with like the graham cracker and stuff, you're gonna
get full more.
So.
So I just, I just eat the marshmallow.
I feel like the type what?
What does that mean?
Just a smoe then.
Just the moe.
The marshmallow.
The moe.
Please stop eating burnt marshmallows.
I'm not in!
What do you mean?
You can't stop me!
This is such an awesome view.
That's not the sun at all.
That's um...
That's brittle hollow.
It's not the sun.
Look at all those stars in the...
in the distance bursting though.
But yeah, how are you guys?
What day is it?
Tuesday?
You have any fun plans this weekend?
And who's going?
Is anybody going to Anime Expo?
I have a concert.
It's not at Anime Expo.
But it's during Anime Expo.
Oh, that's Giant's Deep.
Just kidding.
There are people who had to put smoke on the membership
there too!
Hold on one second.
There we go.
Too far away?
That's okay.
AX is overrated.
Nah, it's...
Like, even for me, I'm just like, I don't know how people do
stuff.
I feel like everything needs to be ticketed.
And, like, I would feel less pressure if everything was,
one, ticketed and two, the tickets were given out before the
convention.
You know what I mean?
because it's just so busy and there's so much it's not
ticketed what i mean is like the events and stuff like
autographs like if you applied online and got everything
there's the lines are insane there's it's like almost
impossible you have to pick like one thing that you really
want to do and that's basically your weekend talks.
Thanks, Minty.
But, like, the amount of guests that are going to be there
this year that I have an interest in, I'm like, I wish I
like, I'm going to be there, because I'm going to be there
for the concert, but it's and then the lines on the stomach
heat.
Yeah, it's awful.
Mm-hmm.
What I mostly plan on going to do is like is like marketing
myself
I want to go to companies like the Blue Archive booth and be
like hi have you heard of Mint Phantom so I'm going to
basically only be there to be hustling mm-hmm put it on
networking I think there's like an industry.
There's always, these conventions usually, like, I mean,
most conventions have an industry party.
But I think the concert is...
I don't know.
I don't want to do, like, anything before the concert.
Because I don't want to risk it, you know?
She's on the grind set.
I have to be.
It's just me, myself, and I.
If I'm not going to do it, nobody's going to do it.
Oh, uh-oh.
That was my controller.
We're all good.
We get a song.
Window 10 user.
Wait.
Is there a different sound for Windows 11?
I've never heard it.
You should never hear it.
I have Windows 11 for my laptop.
Not by choice, obviously.
I don't like it.
I don't like it at all.
But I still use Windows 7.
Windows 7 was the goal.
I did the whole thing where it was like, Um, it keeps being
like, oh by the way, Microsoft AI!
And I'm like, please stop!
Please, yamido!
The sun!
Praise the sun!
Don't look into the sun, you guys.
Don't look into the sun.
I can look into the sun.
I have ghost eyes.
Don't look into the sun.
Keeps looking.
what did you say i can't see oh no we lost one
whoa it looks like a giant like cell like it could split
into two in any second you know that's what it looks like oh
there's giant state
wait no this is giant state that's giant seat i was right
about brittle hollow was i not or did i not wait i can't
remember anything anymore i'm almost done with my food by
the way guys don't worry i'm almost done i'm eating fast
that was right
that's the stranger down by the river stuck in my head all
day
I feel like, oh my gosh, if they ever released a...
Like a super...
Okay, Jeffrey, I'm pitching this to you.
If you're still here.
A VR version of this game.
And it doesn't have to be, but it doesn't have to be like
the full game.
Just like, just like very minimal.
I actually looked it up, like, in, what's it called?
In VR chat, if there were any outer wild worlds.
And there are, actually.
There's a mod.
There's a VR mod.
I would become one of those people.
There's a Yudokamp game.
In VR.
If you guys didn't know.
And like, all you do is just sit there.
And do nothing.
And that's what I would do.
I would become one of those VR chat people that exist in
their headset.
I would just sit in here.
I would listen to the music.
And the crackling.
I would just stare up at the sky.
I would be like, yeah.
I'm gonna become one with my chair.
I'm never moving from this location.
Mint Mirror's Edge VR stream win.
I want to do some more VR.
Or maybe not VR, but
um...
So I'm like...
I want to do the new WarioWare game once I have like a um...
I don't know if You guys have seen it, but the artist has
been posting it on Twitter.
There's, like, a Cheeby Mint 3D model that's getting mid.
No, I want to try it with that.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, no, I...
Oh, no.
That's what...
That's the noise that Matara makes.
Are you going to watch the anime where the wife dies, but
reincarnate...
Oh, the...
My wife is a...
Reincarnate.
It's an elementary school student or whatever.
No, I remember seeing all, like, the people being mad about
it, but I heard the story was actually really good.
Don't judge a book by its cover, everybody.
Or a light novel by its title.
Even though that's the reason why light novel titles are so
long.
They're supposed to, because they're, because...
They just, they didn't, from what I remember, and somebody
can correct me if I was wrong, but the site that they were
hosted on...
Like didn't allow descriptions.
And so they had to put the description of the work into the
title.
They had to work it in.
Yeah, and so that's why you have all these titles that are
like ridiculously long and silly.
I've heard that explanation too.
Yeah, yeah.
Unfortunate name, heartwarming story.
I mean, I guess it got people's eyes on it.
And once it comes out...
I mean, what does manga...
But there was also like a live action, I think.
The manga's been out.
I mean, you'll have people that will watch because of like,
you know, the morbid curiosity type.
And then they'll see that it's not as bad as they.
Whoa!
Woo!
I mean, it's so crazy to see how dark it gets.
Oh, my controller's going crazy.
Someone who's read it is genuinely like reincarnation sucks.
adapt laws yeah reincarnation does suck being a ghost is the
best don't reincarnate just become a ghost
okay let me put my plate i just finished too so let me put
my plate down okay awesome yippee all righty we have our
next thing let's we gotta do.
I don't remember what we gotta do.
22 minute break over.
Alright.
So.
For this one.
Uh.
This one.
Okay.
They go to the bridge.
I don't remember where this is at all.
The handover, the goods.
The codes.
They walk away into the woods.
through the fire right oh the fishing sorry i always forget
about it okay oh wait one second again my bad my bad my bad
there we go okay okay and then they go through the fire so
some people said this is the easiest one i sure hope you
guys aren't pulling my leg Or my ghost tail.
I hope you guys aren't pulling my ghost tail.
I hate when you guys do the smileys.
I'm retracting that rule.
It feels like you're mocking me at this point.
It feels like you're mocking me.
I don't like it anymore.
I don't like it anymore!
Okay.
At least with this...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Coming in.
Easy.
Oh, just kidding.
If I'm so fast and I leave the hatch before my helmet has
finished putting on its head...
Do I die?
You know how like the helmet will like go over your head
while the you're when you get back up from the from the the
seat can we have a no help emote no
no you guys don't deserve a no help I don't even know I
don't even know why you say it like that someone said it's
been from Twitch you think we're on Twitch here give me a
break this is no Oh, Twitch stream!
Alright, we don't have as much time here, because we
basically have until the dam breaks.
Um, whoop, uh, this way.
So we're gonna have to...
Skedaddle.
I think maybe that's why I did the other one before.
I was just like, oh, I have more time, because even when the
dam breaks, I can keep going.
here.
First what we're gonna do?
You made it to the party once before.
What's the plan this time?
We're gonna look at the area in data mode.
I don't quite remember where the bridge is.
Oh, not this one.
There we go.
This way.
Oh, maybe this is the bridge.
I think this is it, actually.
But we have to...
Yeah, I think so.
But we have to bring it into existence.
It was, like, around here?
Nope, just kidding.
I'm lost.
Here?
Over here?
Yeah, right here.
Perfect.
And there we go.
Trying to decide where I want to leave.
You know what?
I'm going to leave it here, because we can see all through
here.
Wow, wait!
Oh, wait.
I think there's the hand.
No, I don't.
No, there's no... Not yet, not yet.
Oh, you can see him.
Well, they can't see me in this mode, so what if I just go
in there?
Right?
The elevator.
Yeah, that's true.
I can't remember where the entrance... Oh, okay, it's down
over here.
Hello.
Sorry.
Continue.
keep going trying to see like how every often a guy shows up
oh there's okay I was gonna say there's something here it's
just they can't even program comfier chairs what is in this
house anyway
this is where they're all coming from.
What's over here, anyway?
Look how close these two are together.
That's not fair.
Yeah.
Back up, buddy.
Back up.
Oh.
We can't go inside.
Ouch.
Okay.
Never mind.
No worries.
If I have to redo the loop this time, that's okay.
Outer Wild's VR mission.
That's literally, yeah.
So at some point there will be two guys that are really
close to each other.
But when it's those two guys, I can go.
I believe.
They look so similar to me.
Okay, can I just walk?
Uh...
Do I have to go through the whole basement thing?
Can I just walk over there?
Let's see.
This way.
Oh no, it goes underwater!
Okay.
Good to know.
Good to know, good to know, good to know.
And then he come out on the other side.
Good to know, good to know, good to know, good to know, good
to know.
Oh, then there's another guy.
Okay.
Hold on, my turn first.
My turn first.
I'm going.
Wow, it's so pretty in here!
Wow!
This guy's slow as molasses.
You're going ghost.
I mean, this is just Minto World, is it not?
This is Minto Vision.
Essentially.
I can hear the...
They're little...
Okay, I wanted to... Oh, okay, there's nothing over here.
Well, good thing I didn't...
Oh!
Oh, they still see me.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh, that's right, they could still see me.
They could still see me.
I just have to...
Yeah.
I just...
I can hide better is what the...
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know what to do.
doing okay well clearly okay first thing we got to do is we
got to blow out the light which was
um which was
uh which was
somewhere over here maybe i think you may have actually
figured out this previously um well i did know how to get
past them so i did yes figure that out oh no this is to open
that up um how do i turn off the light hold
on i don't remember oh shoot
what's your goal now to sneak in.
I think.
Act natural.
Oh, shoot.
We're gonna follow.
Nothing?
You don't see anyone.
Where'd he go?
Where'd you come from?
You jerk.
What was it that I did?
I wish I could go back to the ship and watch the thing
again.
No, they...
Oh, that was close.
What was it that they did?
They went?
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to remember.
They like...
Went from the bridge, but it would look like some backway.
Or was it from the bridge?
I don't even know.
Maybe they did...
Eh?
I think it was from...
Maybe the bridge over there.
Come on.
I see them walking.
Oh...
Oh my god.
Wait.
Grubby Grubb.
Grubby Grubb did something.
What did it do before?
What the?
Oh shoot!
Oh I forgot!
Okay, we'll just meditate.
Shhh.
Shh.
Hmm.
Yeah, we can watch the log now.
We can watch the log.
Okay.
We have all the tools you need.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just...
They walk...
I can't remember.
They walk somewhere.
Okay, hold on.
Thank you.
Okay, so yeah, wait, that is the bridge, right?
Wait, what?
Is there?
They walk somewhere.
That has to be.
They walk through there.
To there.
Yeah, that has to be.
And then...
They walk through.
So does...
The light never have to go off at all?
The funny thing is she came to the conclusion and thought it
out loud and she forgore.
It's so funny.
Why?
No way.
Am I that dumb?
Don't tell me.
Don't say yes.
What?
Wait, then if I already came up with the...
With the conclusion, you guys can tell me.
If I already came up with the solution myself, then you guys
can let me know.
If I already came up with it.
Right.
Wait.
you
have to put two and three together yourself oh so it wasn't
like okay now that okay that actually helps me more than you
guys realize though because if i had been like wait the
solution if i said the solution earlier um while i was oops
um while i was doing the thing then i would have like this
whole part then i would have been like oh okay what did i
forget But if I figured out the solution somewhere...
I'm so...
I'm so confused!
Mintomatics.
Thanks.
Thanks a whole lot.
Minto brains small.
What did I figure out?
Well, I- you know what, guys?
That doesn't actually help me at all, because I figured out
so much today.
I've figured out a ton.
And so it could be literally anything.
I'm I'm banning no elk from my chat.
I hate it.
I actually hate it now.
Now it actually pisses me off.
I'm banning it from my chat.
Wait, what?
What was that?
Up there?
Wait, can I get a hint of where I figured it out?
When I figured it out?
What context I figured it out?
Two to three hours ago?
Oh, I always forget to wake back up.
Ah.
You didn't figure it out, it was unrelated.
Child's just desperate to spoil the solution.
Wow.
Now I feel even dumber.
Thanks.
So I didn't even figure it out.
You guys are just...
Hmm.
Hoki-doki.
I did.
Just not that it was a solution to a puzzle.
Ah, I see, I see.
You're so tense that you didn't realize you figured it out.
There's our guy.
Is it one or two?
That's two?
That's two of them.
So clearly the solution is to blow their things out.
Okay, so we'll wait for these two.
When the second guy goes...
That's when we can go.
I don't remember where the entrance is, which is why I'm
trying to get closer.
I think that's it right there.
Yeah, no one else has come yet.
Don't fall in the water.
Wait, wait, where'd it go?
Oh there.
Right?
Here?
Yeah.
In
fact, I'll just conceal just a case.
Ooh.
That thing just vibrated.
They can't see me.
Act natural, everybody.
Act natural.
Okay.
Act natural, everybody.
Oh, my God, it's so loud.
Wait, I can't see you.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
You jerk.
Close one.
Got a good look at him, though.
He looked really cool, like, in the...
in the shadow, you know?
Um...
I don't think he's going to move.
I have a feeling he's not going to move, especially because
when I came before, another guy was the one who came out and
grabbed me.
Oh, shortcut with the grabby grabs.
I always forget.
I actually don't know...
I don't remember where this one leads.
I don't remember.
Oh.
I saw one, I think.
I'm just gonna go forward.
Oh, shoot.
Why don't they stop coming?
How many of them are you?
This can be the easiest or the hardest, depending on your
big brain.
Oh, gosh.
Why is the game so dark?
Because it's dark.
I don't know what just where his path is.
Oh my gosh, wait, no.
Is that a...
No.
I don't think that's another one.
I'm just going to get up behind them.
Okay.
Easy mode.
Here we go.
We're following.
This one was the hardest for me?
Oh, gosh.
No.
Why can't you guys give me a hint?
I've gone through so much, you guys.
Any help spoils the solution?
Okay.
Trying not to get too close to this guy, but I don't know if
there's someone.
I don't think there's anyone.
following him.
I think we're good, but just to be, just in case, you know?
Look at him with his goat like limbs and bento welcome back.
Thank you.
I'm just following to the party.
Don't mind me.
Leave me alone!
Oh, but I came in with that guy.
He invited me.
He literally just led me there the entire way.
He led me there.
I was totally invited.
Okay, hold on.
I'm thinking...
thing that I can do here.
There's some elf.
Minto is cute.
There's no help at all.
I think I had to look up a guide for this one.
Felt dumb afterwards.
Oh yeah, we need a second herthian.
Why don't they like me?
Shouldn't they be like, oh my god, what what are you?
You're so cool.
You're so cute.
I'd be like, I'm so tiny.
I'm just a small alien compared to you guys at least bring a
nice bottle of wine oh
is there a way to give a hint that won't spoil it like a one
word hint is what i'm wondering
no oh
You can't get a bucket of water.
I know.
Look outside the box.
A fire extinguisher on the ship.
I know, right?
I'm thinking.
Just pretend you're the delivery guy.
I know.
It's a me.
pizza pizza you did ironically solve this earlier i'm so
what i can't i my it's been seven hours please how am i
supposed to remember everything that i've done and have it
done
how am i supposed to remember everything that i've done
your brain has been working less ever since you're not as
scared oh my god don't be so mean what are talking about oh
my god so mean wow don't be rude thanks for the gifted i'm
thinking i'm thinking girl first puzzle of the day because i
was thinking i was like does the um i can't oh wait oops i
forgot to do it was back off i can't wait until the water
because because or unless I can I'm in a different building
and that building over there I think doesn't get affected oh
wrong way so maybe I can wait until the the thing is
destroyed because I was thinking oh I can't wait for the
water because it'll flood me but that's on that's in that
room this is the building across the across the way it
should work i think conceal don't feel don't let well i
guess we're about to find out baby oh shoot wait no but the
fire is still gonna go out Ah,
see!
But, wait a second, do I...
Oh, wait, maybe I take a boat here or something.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I take a boat from the tower.
Why am I going out the longest way?
Oh, come back!
Come back, come back, come back!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, you're going too fast.
Okay, let's try it.
Wow, no, not the rock.
Dwayne.
Wait, is it Dwayne or the rock or Johnson?
Okay.
And...
Uh, put you down.
Thank you.
Pick up.
So maybe, if I don't have enough time here, maybe I should
start from here and then go through the boat and like kind
of wait it out until I watch them all burst into flames and
disappear.
Well, I guess they wouldn't burst into flames, but you know
what I mean.
Okay.
Dwayne the Rock, Dwayne, Dwayne or the Rock, Dwayne or the
Rock or Johnson.
They're brothers.
So that's all the hullabaloo, oh silly, all the hullabaloo
we've been hearing screaming.
It's those guys dying probably, I hope.
Most likely.
Rock the Rock Ron Rockston
Dwayne or the Rock or Johnson
Oh my god hold on
Goodbye Easton plays Easton plays like Do Do
Easton handing out all the Ls he's ever got
We continue onwards past this.
Roasted from the afterlife.
Oh, oh, okay.
Pass here.
Oh, I like the singing, though.
Who is singing, I wonder?
Maybe the guy, the one blocking the...
Okay, not here.
Oh boy.
Are we gonna make it?
I don't know.
It's not here.
We're continuing onwards.
Forward.
Whoa.
Forward march.
Trying to spread L's just to take them.
It's this one, right?
I can't tell.
Yes, because these are their houses, right?
I think?
Wait a second.
Uh-oh.
I just realized something.
Um, well, I can...
Um...
Isn't there a door here?
Oh.
Wait, I can probably open it from the other side.
Oh!
Is there a grabby grab anywhere?
Or...
Um...
No way.
How did we...
How did we fumble so hard, everybody?
Gotta restart.
How did we fumble so hard?
Can I jump?
Onto.
Yes, we.
This is a collective effort!
Yes, we!
Yes, we, yes, we!
We, we?
You're going so far away from the shore, little boat!
Okay.
I think, at this rate, I should just meditate.
Because I can't do the other.
Because I cannot go any further.
I was going to say, oh, I'll just go back and do it, but I
cannot.
Okay.
We got this, though.
We got this.
We know.
Hopefully, maybe the solution.
I think.
I think I have a pretty good idea of the solution.
I think so.
Do you trust?
Do you trust Minto?
I trust you with my afterlife.
Oh my god.
This last don't know what I meant.
You immediately thought outside of the box of that one using
a boat that helps.
It was a no spoiler hit.
It's okay.
I accept your apology.
And I'm sorry if I'm a little sensitive.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry too.
Aww.
we're we're we're getting through this together okay
we're gonna get through this together
oh my gosh you guys i have something to admit to i have a
confession to make i have a confession to make so metal gear
on saturday i stopped at at Psycho Mantis.
Not because I didn't think I could beat him in time for
Doki's outfit.
But also because I was afraid to ask how to change the
controller.
Since I didn't know how to do it.
Oh, we're fine.
All we need to do is leave.
Oh, I forgot my suit.
Oh, no, I put on my suit.
Can I open the hatch?
Oh, yeah, we're fine.
Okay, anyway.
I thought I was about to die.
This is top three worst landing.
What are you talking about?
But yeah, I was afraid.
I was like, I don't know how to change the controller.
The controller port too.
I should figure that out next by next stream.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Push, push, push.
Wait, is that a Super Chat a spoiler?
I only saw part of it.
Is that a Super Chat a spoiler?
Oh no, can I read it?
I don't know.
I can't tell if I can read it or not.
Swap your keyboard to a different port.
I'm... I'm... not using keyboard!
Oh, is there something I already solved?
Oh, okay.
I'll read it in a second then.
Or I can read it once it pops up.
Wait, grab.
So, yeah.
That's why I was just like, you know what, I'm gonna...
I was embarrassed to ask for help.
Oh, it's spoilers?
I can't tell.
Some people are saying it is and some people are saying it's
not.
Well, anyway, thanks for the super chat.
50 50
one second nap i hope you're rested i hope you're well um
feeling well and refreshed i was wondering if okay i'll be
honest i was wondering about the door because i know how to
do the door obviously, because it's right here.
But I was wondering if I would have to use it because I knew
that I needed...
Oh, whoops.
I knew that I needed it for the boats, but I didn't...
I guess I just didn't realize.
Okay, from here, now we can take a boat and we can go wait
in the other...
Oh, wait.
I should wake up because I'm going to have to leave.
Hmm.
I'm gonna have to leave.
Oh, wait.
Let's get the...
Let's do the...
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Because I gotta do the bridge, too.
Oh, maybe?
Do I need it?
I'm better to have it than not.
Let's just do everything that we can do.
Do everything that we can do before we...
Skedaddle.
Is it this way?
Okay.
quite remember.
Wait, where is it?
Did I not go far enough?
Further down maybe?
Okay.
Getting all sorts of jumbled everybody.
Oh, I didn't even cross the bridge.
I'm getting all sorts of jumbled.
Holy moly.
Okay.
We're good.
I think I understand what are saying is a spoiler i have not
played this game it's not so hard because you know people's
definition of a spoiler will be different right like you
could think something's a spoiler and i'm like that's just
this whatever but also i do appreciate um because if someone
you know unless i'm unless i'm asking if someone's like oh
have you thought about this But it's, like, not an answer,
the actual answer.
And then I'm like, hey, I was able to figure out the answer
because of your little hint.
But some people consider that a spoiler, you know.
Uh-uh.
Okie-dokie.
So I'm going to go to the tower now.
If I dip my toes in, does it...
I don't even need to dip my toes in.
Alright, let's keep going.
Okay.
Wait.
I still haven't even figured out this thing, man.
I still haven't even figured out this thing.
I want to go.
Let's see.
See if we can...
Is the current 2's tough?
Or can we get to the...
Can we go back a little bit?
Just a little.
So that I can get my scout.
Oh.
Oh, here.
I'll try from here.
Let's try from here.
Wait.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
75%.
Okay, we got plenty of time.
We have plenty of time.
Okay.
Now we continue onward.
Grab my stuff.
Oh, oh, oh, whoopsie.
I don't know if this is a spoil, but in this game, there's a
time loop or something.
whoa we haven't even reached we haven't even gotten there
yet please it's kind of unnerving watching it count down
it's just something ominous there's always something ominous
about a countdown always something like something crazy is
gonna happen i don't know something ominous Damn, my bad.
You should... Yeah, there's finality, maybe.
Wow, that was smooth!
That was some smooth sailing!
It's starting to look a little...
A little questionable.
You know?
What?
49.
Hello, everybody.
I love a group of free thinkers.
Or no thinkers.
I love no thinking.
Yes, I would like to also join the no thinking cult, please.
Yes, I don't want to think of her again.
Yes, take me with...
Whoa.
Take me with you!
I offer myself.
I'm gonna be like that guy.
No thought.
There is one place open, and I've very much been
wondering...
I thought it was maybe a guy in here.
But now we know why they are all in here.
So now I'm thinking...
It's the guy with the cracked antler.
his face on the wall they they that guy that guy is that guy
thinks too much i think oh no oh no i'm gonna get kicked out
i just thought oh i'm gonna get kicked out of the club
that guy was just like look we can't live in sword art
online we have to you know our planet is gone we have to
experience other stuff and they were like no we love our
planet reject new embrace old
this way all
right oh it sucks that we can't see the integrity of the
okay
we're just gonna take it easy for now until what about the
boat candles wait you can do that you actually can but then
I think that's what's lighting this partially right I don't
think it'll move at all if we blow them out.
We're just cruising.
Oh yeah, we'll know when it comes.
Those guys are going to be screaming, hollering, hoopla.
So much happening.
Why does it feel shorter?
Hmm.
I'm getting I'm getting restless.
I guess we can maybe still go over there.
I think the first time I heard them scream from the Brit or
from the dam exploding was when I was on the boat actually
and I was like why'd they scream
meow pretty sure BGA file fantasy tactics there it is did it
with the main cast getting stuck inside a book and the MC
adventuring to free everyone All right, we're zooming, we're
zooming.
Oh, there they are.
There they go.
Did you see that?
I just saw them dissolve.
I just saw them.
Yeah, we just saw them burst into flame.
Yeah!
Whoa, whoa, we're slanted a little bit.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah!
They're dead!
Wait.
Oh, here we go.
They're all dead!
Wait, are they all dead?
I guess...
We'll still be careful.
Just in case.
Dead, dead.
Oh, that's my boat.
I was like, oh my god, they're not all dead!
Because there could have been someone visiting from the
tower, you know?
I think the tower is the only one that's good.
Oh, wait, no, that's the night sky.
I believe, yeah.
The night sky?
Okay.
Good thing.
Good thing I set up the bridge.
Now, I don't quite remember how to go.
get in there.
Uh, I wish I...
Um, I wish there was a...
Wait, there is a path, right?
That I'll eventually run into.
Right there.
There we go.
That I'll eventually run into.
Uh.
Huh?
Wait, what is this?
Where is it?
Oh, no!
This is not where I wanted to go.
I'm all backwards.
Use the glitch.
Oh, yeah.
We'll try that.
Ooh, it's really scary going into pitch.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Where is it?
Actually, I'm gonna go see if there's anybody left, too.
I'm gonna go check.
Where the heck is this hole?
Oh, there it is.
I'm stuck pulling a double at work.
It's awesome having your stream to keep me company.
Oh, Penn, good luck with work!
You seem to be suffering more than me at this point.
I'm alright.
We're okay.
I think we just solved a puzzle.
I'm gonna go make sure that there's nobody in here.
That's it.
Nice, okay.
All right, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
We're all good, I think.
I hope?
Oh, whoops.
Definitely dead.
Dunzo.
They're all gone.
You need the lantern.
I know, I'm going to go get...
I was...
I literally said I'm going to go check to see if everybody's
dead first.
That's all.
That's all I wanted to do.
Uh, here we go.
Pick up.
No worries, guys.
I know.
Is it here?
Is it this one?
Is it this here?
No.
Oh my god.
I can't...
Wait, here?
Here.
Yes!
Awesome, awesome, awesome, awesome.
That's why they guys didn't die in the other one, too.
Makes sense.
Because they were in that high up building.
Right?
Yeah.
So.
Okay.
Thanks for the preach.
I just walk on in.
Cool.
Here we go.
Are those eyes or...
Those are lanterns.
Oh, okay, those are the...
Okay, okay, okay.
Artifact does not fit!
Uh-oh.
Okay.
This one's a bit more peculiar, eh?
Oh, now we're going to be all mysterious and interesting.
some...
Uh...
Let's see what we can do here.
Um...
Well...
Well, the artifact goes in here, right?
And then...
But how do we get these, though?
This is my question.
Let's see.
Mint!
What are you talking about?!
We can't even get to them!
Minto, please!
Oh I forgot it opened the door.
I don't remember now.
Thanks for the raid!
Slippy!
Thank you!
Okay here we go.
The eye sucks, the eyes gonna destroy everything he sees
everything from the eye oh my god whoa whoa the eyes awesome
Wow everybody come look at the eye Murphy thanks for the
gifted oh oh oh I I I I that's everybody reaching up for
Minto spank thanks for the 10 gifted we We love the eye, we
love the eye.
Oh.
They destroyed their own planet.
They destroyed their own home to build this thing, to go
search for the eye.
So they don't even have a place to go back.
Oh, you idiots.
You didn't even...
Oh my god, that's so sad.
Oh.
Oopsie daisy.
Whoopsie-poopsy is right.
Digital.
Digital world.
Digimon.
The strangers.
Stranger aliens.
Digital stranger aliens.
He's going along the little...
Down, down, down by the...
River.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
To me, I was just like...
oh it's cool that they go through the caves to like you know
it but it's in pitch black so it like helps load the next
area but that's literally that's literally their game as
well that's just a loading it's just oh
boy oh my gosh I can't wait to try this oh my gosh we're
gonna go in the boat and then...
Whoa!
Okay, that's kind of fine.
Let's go try that.
If you die in the game...
Nah.
Oh man!
We're no clipping!
Oh my gosh, this is so exciting.
Oh.
Wow.
Okay.
Now we go all the way to the ship.
Actually, how do we get to the ship?
No, I know.
I know.
Don't worry, I know.
Okay.
This one's really cool.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Wait, so will each loading area also have a different thing
going on?
I'm so curious.
I'm so excited to try this out.
I hope we have time.
If we don't have time, the next...
loop obviously he he where's the bridge over this way I was
wondering like in the in the little in their little was that
did I see it over here in there's in the slideshow it showed
that they had like fish and stuff in there in their rivers
and I was wondering before we knew that this was a
simulation I was like I I wonder where are there?
Like, some of the sounds we're hearing are other animals or
something.
Gosh, it's really hard to navigate through here.
How the hell do I get home?
I can't find the bridge!
Girl is so lost.
I'm really lost, yeah.
I'm pretty lost.
I'm pretty lost, yeah.
I don't know where to go.
I'm... I'm trapped!
I'm...
Oh!
Oh, thank goodness.
Okay.
We found it.
We found...
Wait, so then probably...
Oh, I'm silly.
Probably...
I have to...
Um...
Blow out the candles then, right?
Actually?
there's a hand here but why can't I was there another hand I
just missed it
hmm just a silly
one way shortcut oh wait what that sucks oh I see it now
though oh I see I see it oh okay
Well...
Do a flip!
No, I can um...
Wait, I think that's the music.
I think...
Maybe that was it?
No?
I thought I heard the...
BOOM BOOM BOOM BOOM BOOM But not yet!
Not yet!
Yeah, it's snake.
Bound.
No, it's just ambience.
It's just the ambience.
To the hole.
With the boats.
Oh, I see!
Oh, oh, oh.
Not to the hole with the boats.
Anyway.
Let's meditate.
I don't know if you can actually I don't know if meditating
under the water is like is possible okay
I'm thinking if I should get some more water hmm I think
that's just called drowning I think so too
everything is so green
good morning world Oh, to be a Herthian.
My mind is so expanded.
Not a single Herthian here can understand what I'm going
through.
Nobody here gets me anymore.
I don't even feel.
I don't feel.
I don't.
You guys, I'm beyond saving.
They're just like, I don't sit there like gosh what's wrong
with them they just they wake up and they just take off they
don't even say hello goodbye anything they just they
literally just run to their ship and just take off into
space like they're a like they're a natural like they've
been doing this since they were in the womb what am I who am
I brain maxing I gotta get back I know I'm just like, I
gotta go into the void.
I gotta go into the void of the... I'm so excited to see
what's in here.
Oh my gosh, you guys don't even know how excited I am to see
what's in the void.
So much so that I did a perfect landing.
Let's go!
Yike!
I'm also just very excited to be past those parts.
If there's more stealth, I'm sure that's fine.
But I'm very excited to be past those parts.
It has re-invigorated me.
We'll just go to the first one we can.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Bunga.
AI says we are concerned.
What are you concerned about, huh?
Tell me your problems.
I can help you.
What are your problems?
You are indeed done with stealth?
Peep!
Oh, no.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that feels so good.
It feels so good.
Yes!
Oh, it feels so good.
Yabba-dabba-doo!
I can see why he says yabba-dabba-noo now.
There's just some moments when you want to say it.
You know what I mean?
She doesn't know.
Stop!
Now it's stealth chapter 2.
I can't tell.
Some of you guys are...
I can't tell if some of you guys are trolling or...
I'm just gonna always assume that you guys are trolling.
Okay.
This one we can get to...
We can get through to the boats pretty easily, so...
Good assumption.
Troll?
Awesome!
You're right.
You guys would never do that.
I trust you guys.
I think I trust you guys way too much actually.
And I never learned my lesson.
I trust you guys and I never learned my lesson not to.
I just want to believe that you guys have the best interest.
We do but it's funny.
You're so...you guys are so evil.
This thing is so much.
like the um little pod or the little thingy in death
stranding
boat time
oh okay here we go
oh they're back oh my gosh for some reason yes they would be
back it's a loop but my brain is just like oh my god they're
back scary No, no, nice boat.
No, no, nice boat.
Okay, so I have to put this down, right?
And in the darkness, we vanish.
Time to break the game, exactly.
Wait, do I need to extinguish these, or...
No, I'm just gonna leave.
Bye!
Oh!
We're just a figment of your imagination.
have the lamp?
Oh, I thought in the, um, I'll be honest, I thought in the,
uh, thing it showed him, like, putting it down.
Yeah,
I'll take the lamp.
Take the lamp.
Okay, that was cool, though.
Yeah.
Uh, wait, so it's not supposed to look like that.
What?
It's not, it's not, wait, scared even more.
Uh oh.
Wait, so I'm gonna actually extinguish these.
Oh!
Now I know.
Okay.
Third time's the charm, everybody.
Third time's the charm.
Knowledge gained.
Now we know what happens.
Curiosity will get the best of us no longer.
The boats are afraid of the dark, okay?
Please understand.
Oh, I think we just lost that power.
Which...
Will that have anything...
Or not lost the power, but like...
Will that have anything to do with...
Hmm.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh.
I'm just gonna go here first.
We can actually walk around in the water.
Oh.
Wait, can I walk in that too?
I extinguished those candles for the first time in one of
the caves and legit thought the game bugged.
I guess I was sort of right.
Yeah, right.
Can I jump in here?
I guess I'll try.
Okay, now I know.
God damn it.
Now I know.
Fourth time's the charm!
I like going from this area, though.
Well, actually, it's going to be a little inconvenient once
the dam breaks.
Now that I think about it, maybe we should start doing this
from the tower.
But this one is just so easy to get to, you know.
I guess the tower one's pretty easy, too.
We'll just keep going until we have to go to the tower.
Definitely we learned a lot today.
Oh, yes.
And we will continue learning.
Until it is done.
Alright, keep going.
Go!
Gorge is the fastest.
Oh yeah, we can go there too, right?
Wee!
Woo!
Oh, I was gonna say it's different.
No, it's not.
It's the same.
And let's see.
What's this direction?
Ooh!
Oh, we can actually get here!
Wait, am I on the other side?
Wait.
We've been here before!
This is that place?
Okay, what place have we not been to before then?
Um, hmm.
Let's see.
Now I know how to get past.
Nice.
Wait, what is this actually?
What is that?
Never mind.
I thought it was something else.
Oh, these are extinguishing the...
Oh.
The locks.
Ah!
So we got that one.
Wait, can I just walk on this or no?
I can't tell what's real water and what's not anymore.
Hashtag free mutara.
Yeah, the combinations are gone, but we can still...
Okay, I'm just gonna try walking on it.
Okay, okay, okay.
How can you tell?
It's real and what's fake.
Yeah!
Uh-oh, I think I'm stuck here.
So we do!
Oh wait, no wait.
Oh.
So we do...
Skill issue?
Oh yeah.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I can't get over the that one quite yet hmm okay so now it's
a matter of figuring out how to blow them out
let's try over here what's going on there's even smoke here
this place looks like it's on fire fire you have everything
now Wow.
Wait, actually?
Oh man.
Wait, there's a rock up there?
No way.
We're about to get a rude awakening.
Probably have an hour or two left.
Okay, perfect.
Awesome.
There we go.
This way...
Oopsie daisy.
The puzzle pieces we have every, every puzzle piece!
Wow!
Now we just have to be big-brained.
Hmm.
No.
But also...
I still don't know what that thing is.
The thing that's been...
That's been going...
I don't feel like I'm very close at all.
Unless...
Is it a thing that, like, activates, like, the movement?
Because I'm still convinced that we're moving, like, away
from the sun.
Is it a thing that activates and starts moving us away, I
wonder?
Or something like that.
what?
Look at the map.
Wait, how do I look at the map?
Yeah, I can't.
I have no map.
Where do you enter the stranger?
Why don't you die to supernova?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying, since we're far, far away.
So I am kind of right.
But it's us getting the heck out of here.
I like going through this one because um rather than like I
like doing here because uh the tower we know how much like
once the tower tips we know how much time we have left you
know what I mean so it's I think it's a better gauge it's a
better gauge of uh time for me
flavor plus assistance with the timing plus you found the
log that literally said stranger tick-tocks supernova and
balls out yeah okay so i am i am on like in the right
mindset of that then okay that makes sense i was wondering
if it was like something powering on or powering off
powering on does make sense
i don't think that's a spoiler i don't think so
There's a diagram in the damn room that you found that shows
it moving away.
Yep, yep, yep.
I did see that.
But unless you spend six minutes there, you don't see it
update.
Oh, okay, okay.
All right, here we go.
Wee!
Whoa!
So cool.
Okay.
This didn't light back up, did it?
The lock, I mean.
Oh, no, I think it's, I think it's this one.
This one that should be here, right?
Yeah, that went out.
Maybe we don't even need to come here.
Maybe.
Actually, since I sent the boat,
maybe I didn't need to go to the glitch zone.
hold on I'm still looking around boat is still on land side
on my side or over there oh no there's the boat yeah yeah
yeah right once I send the boat what it will just take me
back and forth still right so hmm
I never figured out a thing for this Did I?
I don't think...
No, I don't think I ever...
There never was.
Because we never were able to figure them out.
So...
What if I brute-forced it?
Oh.
Sorry, going on.
Off again.
Weren't there platforms here?
Or am I crazy?
I want to see the glitch world.
Yeah, that's why I'm literally...
That's exactly what I was just saying.
Let's see.
Put it down.
Go down here.
Oh, glitch world.
There are platforms here.
Hmm.
Whoa, wait.
Oh, wait a second.
Oh.
Oh, what the heck?
I'm a secret genius.
Oh.
Oh
my god.
That's so funny.
It's impeccable.
A genius taken.
before her time.
But now we know we can just go to the bell.
We don't have to go to the glitch world.
At least I don't think so.
You know what?
I'm going to go to the or I'm going to go to the back rooms.
Actually, I will go to the back rooms just in case we need
that boat back.
Okay.
Oh yeah, we're going to have to unlock it again.
That's so true.
Never mind.
Yeah, we're gonna have to unlock it, the...
Let's see what the ship logs say now.
Hey, la...
Oh.
Ugh.
Nothing.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
This went updated.
There's a container marked with the vault seal, but it's
kind of been destroyed.
Intact slide reveals the sacrifice that was made to build
the stranger.
I found a slide reel that appears to be some sort of error
report.
It shows one of the stranger's inhabitants jumping off a
raft during a transition between areas I'm falling below the
world.
Very cool.
Not the back rooms.
Yes, that is the back rooms.
That's the, that's literally the back rooms.
That's the, everybody raise your hand if you think that's
the back rooms.
Meow.
Amen.
Packer voice.
Guys, did I cook or did I...
Did I cook with that, that, that answer?
Did I cook or did I cook?
Great landing as always, thank you.
Keep cooking.
It's not over yet?
Okay.
So I must still continue to cook?
Oink!
I'm trying to decide.
Oh, well.
I'm just gonna grab the artifact here and then we'll go back
to the tower.
Eekanji!
The final cookdown.
It's the final cookdown.
It isn't brah, but it's not well done.
It's a perfect cook.
Needs more egg.
Honestly, that's me with, like, everything.
Egg sometimes...
Wow.
Egg sometimes gives me, like, a migraine, but I love egg.
I love it.
I love egg.
I feel like everything could use eggs.
Egg is just perfect for everything Egg soup Egg and ramen
Egg you sandal Omelette I mean I have to love an omelette
I'm a maid
That's why you know When Matara makes fun of me For liking
Tamago Sushi It's just You know it's because I just like egg
And then they sweeten the egg a little bit And it's so yummy
I wish I could get some sushi can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs thank you miss senator wait does he say
it or does the other guy i can't remember oh gosh i gotta
replay you know what's so exciting is if like or whenever i
play um l-gear rising again it'll be my first time replaying
it after having uh like played through the game so things
are going to i'm gonna get so much more of the references
and stuff so excited yeah i'll get all the references we're
making a mother of all on let's hear jack
into the void into the unknown into the unknown well i don't
know i have no idea what i'm going to be singing at all
tomorrow you guys it might just like I was gonna be like I'm
singing whatever I want because singing you know you know
I'm not sorry sorry I'm not the best singer but singing that
makes me feel good that's been a rough week for me even
though it's only Tuesday so I just was like you know I'm
just gonna do a karaoke Yeah, to let it all out.
Yeah, bucket, we ball.
Exactly.
I'm not one to, like, you know, when I hear really amazing
singers, you know, I mean, like, I'm...
Please stop pat-pouting.
What are my absolute favorite people to watch?
Like, stop!
It's like, you know, I'm...
There's, like...
Like, you know, not a...
There's always going to be someone better than you you know
or like some based on people's opinions or whatever oh uh
hold on there we go um i'm not to one to be like how do i
say like oh my like when i hear such amazing youtuber
singers like elizabeth like i'm not like oh man i feel so
like it doesn't it's not it's not something that like makes
me want to put myself down or anything like i think people
having so much talent is like so amazing.
I bring her up because I've been watching her karaoke stream
so much.
And I know other people are too.
Oh wait, we gotta go to the other side.
But you know, I do think like...
Oh, it makes me want to improve if I can.
In that way.
I think it's I think it's really fun when oh wait let's go
put our little guy away I think it's fun you know when
people have you know different what's the words when like oh
my gosh I can't see anything again how do I say it if
everybody had the same talent it would be so boring is what
I'm trying to say.
You know?
If everybody had the same talent, it would be like, oh,
everybody can sing.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
So, you know.
Even if I'm not the best singer, I maybe still have other
stuff, so it's okay.
Wait, can I do it from here, or do I have to...
Oh, I can!
Nice!
Easy peasy.
Yeah!
You need your artifact?
No, I don't!
But what about the last one?
Now this one?
Let's see what things do.
Hmm.
Time.
No way you thought you'll use one seed.
to solve two puzzles.
Shut up!
Please don't sell yourself short.
You know.
But, okay, I have a question.
I have a question.
It's everything that I, like, that I need to solve this in
this vicinity, I guess.
Because I think I saw some, oh my goodness, how am I
supposed to go back upstairs?
I saw some people say, like, maybe check the logs again,
but...
I haven't looked at the logs.
So, will I be able to solve it if I haven't looked at the
logs?
Hmm.
I have all the information to solve it.
It's technically no!
Wait, what do you mean?
It's in the ship logs.
This depends if you can remember certain things.
What?
That's the most vague thing I've ever heard of my life.
Can you think?
Screenshot the password?
No, that was to another thing.
That was to another, another thing.
Okay, hold on, I'm thinking.
Oh, that's so funny.
I forgot that the This one was broken.
Where are you going?
Why?
Why did you leave me?
Okay.
Just remember what you learned from each stealth section.
A whole lot of nothing.
Unless this is a similar thing where I have to...
Wait, so I'm noticing this.
This is like the big key here.
The light that is shining from the ceiling.
So it must be that I have to wait for something, right, to
cover that hole.
Because otherwise...
Otherwise, there's no way I'll be able to get through.
Is it?
Oh, am I wrong?
I can't go back, oh man, if I have to go back all the way to
the ship logs, I might as well just meditate here.
Okay, I'll go.
I might be able to get back to the ship from here.
Maybe.
wait
is it coming wait is it coming oh there it is just takes a
second oh my god i almost got squished almost got squashed
you just made me realize what that heavenly light is
actually referencing slash communicating oh i'm glad that i
helped you with that
oh we're inside the bell that's right oh okay guys i think
it's just time to meditate
at least it's easy to solve the first two
you can like make you know you can pick phone pick fun at me
but like calling me dense i think is kind of mean after i've
been streaming for eight and a half hours and you know um i
think it's a little rude to say something like that so maybe
i wasn't even looking at chat i don't even know what you
guys are saying so maybe like i've just looked over and
that's the first thing i see so maybe don't be so mean you
know
like i'm not gonna remember everything in
there was somebody that said it it makes me you know I enjoy
play games like this but like sometimes you know and I know
that I'm like oh please help me but it's very just it does
make me never like not want to play games like this when
people immediately insult me if I don't get the if I don't
get the the answer right away so you know
okay what am i looking through uh the arc was it the
archives um
error report shows an alarm bell failing to wake up
strangers in happenance so i need to be dumb to not wake up
the bell
Uh...
Alarm real...
Or slide real that appears...
Be some sort of error report.
It shows an alarm bell failing to wake up the stranger's
inhabitants.
This one was...
I know someone said about the error report, so let's see.
It shows one of the strangers having jumping off a raft
during...
Okay, that's the one we did.
Uh... wait.
Um...
This one?
Show is one of the strangers having a dropping...
their artifact on the ground okay so it's this um you can
scroll to see the slide reel wait what do you mean oh thank
you oh it's only three wait i don't think i can wait why is
it why does it only show three things or oh wait okay maybe
it's uh this one Yes.
Oh yeah, there were three reels in the place.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Non-working button prompt.
What are you talking about?
It worked.
If no brain activity, then no disconnect.
If no brain activity, then no disconnect!
So...
I already knew that information, but it's still...
No brain, no problem.
Do I have to die?
You're already deaf.
It's a good thing I'm not.
Never would hear all the good voice acting in games.
Okay.
Because we can't, if we're asleep, then we obviously wake
up.
But it has to be that we have to be dead.
How do we die?
Oh, my one more shindier.
Hold on.
I gotta go get some...
My throat is really hurting real quick.
So give me, sorry.
Give me like...
two seconds to go grab some some hot water sorry it like it
was hurting earlier but i was like since i'm since i'm just
chilling here i'm gonna i'm gonna go grab it real real quick
real quick i'll be right back
okay okay she's in the vr world Ha ha ha ha ha
Tadaiima No, that's what I'm supposed to be saying I'm
supposed to be saying Oh Kaidi to you Oh my goodness I feel
like I might overthink this one A little bit How do we die
How do we die?
How do we die But also Die in the game People overthink
Outerwiles all the time.
It's like...
There's more slide reels.
But this one shows the brain activity.
And you go in and it's like, yeah, I'm sleeping.
I'm taking a little nap.
And then it goes inside the fire and the old man dies.
Wait, do I have to die by the fire?
Wait, do I have to die?
Wait.
Oh.
My bad.
As long as I'm within the range of the fire.
Maybe I could die...
Death by fire.
If I die by the fire Or if I die by the hands of the fire I
am dying within the range of the fire I think Yeah, we're
gonna go Oh my gosh, you all told me to cook It was a hint
after all That was the hint that we needed Just cook Oh my
gosh Oh my god, you guys do love me!
You helped me after all!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Um...
Good la- perfect landing!
So we're going to...
go to...
Okay, so first we're going to go to the places that we've
been going to.
Like, I'm going to go to the tower first.
Wait, do we need to?
I guess...
Yeah, I'm going to go to the tower first.
Because...
Because I want to get to the boat.
Pemdash.
Yeah.
I want to get to the boat.
And then do all the boat...
things and then once we're done with the boaty things we can
wake up and then die yeah we need at least one loading zone
exactly exactly so we'll do that interesting that like the
we have like the fire seems to be related to the ghost
matter but when we're by the fire we don't get a Ghost
Matter, like, notification.
Guess I'll die.
So real.
Death by fire.
Into the video game.
And then once we...
Wait, but won't we be dead?
You know what?
Let's not think too hard about it.
Let's not think too hard about it, you know?
Whoa.
I mean, if you die in the game, you die in real life, then
literally does it apply to me, so...
What am I gonna do?
Die again?
Yeah, we've already died so many times!
What's one more?
Exactly!
I always love you, but I've never played, so no help.
Aww.
I'm glad that you're watching regardless because I know a
lot of people don't want to watch outer wild streams because
they want to experience it for themselves and I totally
understand that and we're on part 3 of a of a 8 hour 9 hour
long stream now almost so I get it okay I appreciate you
guys watching and anyway and you know there's always like a
you know being a content creator right you have to think of
like what's the popular thing versus what's the thing you
want to do and truly like these types of games are like
sorry my fan was making my like dress blow kind of weird and
it was making me like feel like someone was touching my arm
so it's kind of like you know when you play longer games
it's it's much more feels like a a passion something that
you would want to do you know what i mean tunic next oh
tunic um kiara really liked that one didn't she she like
wanted that to be game of the year or something right that's
how that door opens oh
I'll always watch a bit play anything.
I appreciate it.
You know.
Yeah, because it's always just like, what's the popular
thing?
What's going to give me the views?
And then obviously, what's the thing that I want to play and
want to experience?
And this was one of them.
This was something I really, really wanted to play.
So.
Just streamer things.
I missed out eight hours was working.
Woo!
Otsunan!
Here we go.
Wee!
We're in like end game now, right?
So...
Tunic is great!
Is FNAF a popular streamer?
Streamer?
Oh my gosh, Freddy Fazbear, my Oshi streamer.
I don't know.
I can't, sometimes I can't really tell what's popular and
what's not.
It's even though it's my job.
She's gonna meet Matara.
Oh my god.
Is this... is it Matara time?
Soon.
Matara time soon.
Wait.
Drop artifact?
There we go.
This should be far enough.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Okay.
You should play Suica game.
You know what?
I've never, ever played Suica game before.
Even when it was so popular, everybody was doing it.
I had never played it.
When you're done with the DLC, I really recommend watching
an Outer Wild 100% Speedrun.
They do some wild things, especially in the DLC.
Oh, yeah, that sounds awesome.
Speedruns are so interesting.
It's kind of awful, but fun.
Yeah, that's the general consensus, right?
That's the general consensus, I'd say.
Let's light some more pathways and such.
So I'm not completely blind going up here.
Pull the lever, crook.
What's your plan?
I think I'm going to death by fire, I think.
Wow, joy!
Thank you for the 50 gifts and thank you so much!
Hmm.
There's like a multiplayer now, though, for Suica game.
So I think a lot of people have been playing it more.
Not a lot, I say that.
I usually forget solutions, so I'll be fine if I decide to
play.
I think this is the only thing I know to do.
If I die, I die.
But...
I think I must die within the vicinity of here.
Okay.
I don't know if the I don't think the elevator counts is
this what you would do to wake up Matara for the pot
whoa my controller is shaking so much
wait wait
oh oh oh right right right right right okay now we go to the
I was like wait a second huh yeah I died in the game.
I was confused for a moment.
I was like, wait, how do I have all my stuff?
Okay, now we go to the bell, I believe.
Taco bell.
And then...
Hopefully this works.
I hope this works.
I just got fired!
Oh, Sayo!
I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry.
are 90 degree over here oh everybody be careful not to get
now that it's actually summer careful not to get heat stroke
or anything like that wee whoop
oh do be spicy outside yeah
okay over here to the bell the structure
Okay.
Now we die here, everybody.
It's been an honor.
Everybody
play...
What's that song they play in the Titanic?
I hope this works.
There's even one left.
Oh my gosh.
I hope this works.
Ah!
It worked!
I cooked.
I cooked!
I cooked myself.
I cooked the meal.
So now I shouldn't go off at all, right?
I guess we'll test it.
We'll test it.
Well, I guess also They still go off I just hear nothing
Wow, this is kind of dark, right?
It's kind of sad It's kind of dark Oh
Here we go
No turning back
I'm scared Thank you for that, because
watching you solve this game in some really creative ways
was a blast so hopefully food bad eggs have it soured your
enjoyment of it thank you today i really appreciate it no no
thank you
it's really dark i can't see a single thing just a little
bit of the walls it's so dark oh there's a light
there's a staircase there's some creepy sounds some spooky
sounds What's in here?
Oh.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh, it's a...
It's a room?
Oh, wait, I haven't looked through here yet.
I can look through them.
Oh, they're looking at the planet, their home planet.
Oh.
Insert the article?
Oh, what's going on?
Okay.
Here?
Anything in here?
Anyone around?
What is this?
What is that?
There are instruments?
Um...
Bolt.
Their game?
It's like a, it's like showing their, what's it called?
Hi!
Wait, it's him!
It's the guy with this...
with the, with the, with the, with the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the...
Oh my god.
Hi.
Talk to the prisoner.
So he has been in here!
Who are you?
Oh.
I thought it was...
Oh, sorry.
I'm in your way.
He's trying to walk.
I'm just...
I'm just standing here.
Thank you.
Oh!
Okay.
He woke up before them.
What the?
Why?
Why did you do that?
He was just like, Yon, I'm going to casually unleash
craziness upon the universe.
Then they sealed him away.
Yo, that's so dark.
Then they were like, no, no, no more eye anymore.
We hate the eye.
Isn't it the same as...
oh gosh that one that one that one um no mayan who was just
like i thought the eye was evil but it's not so they saw the
vision already holding artifact oh thank you um maybe maybe
they saw maybe the vision they saw was if the was if there's
no well we're showing him our memories now
I don't know what's going on.
Oh.
You good?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, sorry.
I have to hold it.
Oh.
Oh, it's me.
The signal.
Ah.
What?
Oh, this is the first...
Okay, yeah.
This is the first time because then they launch to the
thingy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
And then they all die because of the internal burr.
Then that's me!
Well, that might not be me.
That might be someone else, but you know.
There's someone who's just like, whoa.
Whoa.
That's crazy speak.
That's me!
Feldspar, yeah.
Wow.
Aww.
Can I ask him?
He had another question though.
Where are we going?
Artifact is not fit.
Here you go.
Vision Torch.
That was so good.
Made me kind of teary.
Wait!
Oh, wait!
Why?
Um.
Did I get duped?
Maybe it's not so bad.
It's nice and quiet in here, you know?
Wait, I hear something.
So your efforts to Release the echoes of the eye.
Let the new mind reach our solar system and gave me.
Wait.
Oh, I don't think I was supposed to read that.
Oh, I can go up to Logan Good.
Bye.
So pretty.
Where are you, friend?
I've released you.
Please don't jump scare me.
I will scream.
Oh, it's not a spoiler.
Okay.
Oh.
No, stop!
We're gonna go travel together!
Where is he though?
Footprints.
Oh, thank you.
I could barely see them.
Oi.
So he's like, wake up.
Wake up, man.
Wake up.
Okay, here I go.
I'm gonna wake up.
We freed him though.
Now we can't wake up.
But we can, but we can.
But we freed him.
Now beat the game for a new ending.
Oh, okay, okay.
Um...
Does that mean I have to go back into what's it called?
Wait, I'm trying to remember how to beat the game.
Do I just go to the moon?
Wait, how do I beat the game again?
No, I have to go to the bramble?
No way.
Oh, no, I have to go to the bramble!
You'll not like the new ending, I hope.
That's a big ask, for real.
Just going casually, going to the bramble.
Okay.
Oh, well, luckily...
I will need your guys' assistance here, though, if that's
okay.
Um, it's because...
Uh, first of all, let me go find it.
Because I don't quite remember everything about how to go
navigate the Bramble, so.
Thank you for the!
Thank you for the Aqua Super, thank you!
Wait, I can't...
Oh, it won't let me lock on it.
Oh, no.
Ash Twin for the Warp Core.
Oh gosh you guys are oh my god wait this is oh my gosh I
don't remember how to do any of this oh god okay guys I'm
gonna do my best I hope I can do it in this um like oh my
god I don't remember how to do any of this this is pretty
bad I didn't realize I was gonna have to do the game all
over again but I go on ash twin and I wait the sun?
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, this is so bad.
Thank you, Isu!
Oh.
And I just kind of like orbit around here until it dissolves
enough, right?
I think I remember is like using the landing mode Oh What
the hell There we go Defined it maybe Okay Which tower is it
I don't remember Oh my gosh you guys This is really bad
Because I'm not gonna remember anything Oh You need the
escape pod right Wait there's so much stuff That I need
first This is so bad Because I should have, if I had known
all of this, I would have done it on my, I would have done
it on my old account.
Oh, no.
What?
Oh, this is, oh, no.
Because I'm going to need you guys to, like, handhold me
through everything because I don't know what I need to do.
And that's going to be really frustrating.
Oh, my God.
can look up the codes but don't i still need the ash twin
thing i need the i need to turn the thing off i need to turn
off the project it's
the ash twin towers here okay and then when i go to the fish
someone said find feldspar how do i don't do i locate him
with the
No, oh my gosh Swipe the core from the ATP Fly to the vessel
Through Bramble, input LXN into coordinates Okay, which we
can get We can get the coordinates Just watch a speed run
right now and do What they do easy Oh my god
Oh my god This is so Oh my god, this is so
I just watched a video because I couldn't be bothered.
That's, you know, that's so fair.
You're so valid for that.
Google the ending.
Give me the controller.
I'll do it.
Yeah, I already have Solanum.
I already got them.
Let me just try once, I suppose.
think it'll all come back to me in this in a glorious moment
i'll be honest i don't think it'll come back to me at all
but no no no no no get me out of there but um okay there's
the sun we need this one right because we're wait hold on no
it's that it's the twin tower right wait the sun is to go
need the twins stranger i'm gonna get you out of here i i
don't want to you know i'm gonna just unclick you for now oh
i'm just gonna un there we go okay
with the broken roof yes yes it's like i remember the timing
is quite tight because there's like bramble in there and
stuff that i have to get through very quickly
Was it that?
That was it?
Right there?
Wait.
Oh.
I lost it.
There?
Is that it?
Don't remember which one it is though.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
I think if I land like here, I'm safe.
Probably.
You need to go to the vessel once first.
You can reach it again with the marker like you used for the
stranger.
The vessel?
Why do I need to go there?
Hello, interloper.
It's all your fault.
But people said that I can just get the eye cords from...
Wait, is this the one that's broken or that one?
Not this one.
Wait.
Maybe this one.
People said I can just look up the coordinates, so I think
I'm just gonna do that.
Not gonna lie.
I think I'm just gonna look them up.
Oh my god.
Yeah,
so even if I don't have it, I'll just look it up.
It's no biggie.
Am I still on the equator?
I don't even know where the vessel is!
Oh, why did I do it on this save?
I thought it would be safe.
Oh, man, I'm so...
I don't even remember how to do this part either.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
I think I would just prefer to watch the ending.
If that's okay with you guys.
You know, I've already done all of this before.
And if you really want to see me do it again, I'm sure there
are ways.
You know, it might just be projected into your brain.
I can do it with my ghostly powers, you know?
So, I think, I think because there's, like, multiple things
about this where I, you know...
Okay, so what is this one?
If I had, what's the word?
If I had, um, if I had done this on the save that wasn't
completely wiped, I'd be down, more down for doing it.
But, um, right now it's just not feeling so great.
I don't even know if I'm in the right one.
I don't think I'm in the right one.
Congrats on getting through the DLC, but I had a great time
watching you cook figuratively and literally.
Thank you.
Maybe I was in the right one.
Wait.
This goes up.
Maybe I was in the right one.
Wait, I don't think I'm in the right building.
This is not the correct building.
Wait, then do I...
Oh.
Oh!
I was supposed to walk in the purple!
Okay, hold on.
We'll wait.
Just to watch a video.
This could take some time.
I completely...
You guys, please understand.
It's been so long.
And also, so much has happened since I last played.
I think, you know, it doesn't
feel so great just because because it's just watching a
video but it's just for the sake of my mental health
what do i hmm oh outer wilds ending okay it's 20 minutes
This person's video is 20 minutes long.
No way.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to check it real quick.
I'm going to turn off the audio so you get your...
Okay, just pretend it's me, okay?
We'll just pretend...
We'll just all pretend it's me, right?
Yeah.
I won't...
I'm not even going to...
Hold on.
I'm going to make sure there's no...
Okay, I'm going to pretend there's no voiceover or anything.
Okay, let's, all right, spend the next 20 minutes with me,
everybody.
Give me a second.
I'm going to put it up on the screen.
I'm going to full screen it.
Um, there we go, 1080p.
Okay, just pretend it's me.
Just pretend it's me.
Okay.
I've got to resize it.
Give me a second.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, hold on.
Let me get you guys in as well.
Everybody in?
Come on in!
Oh!
Uh, hold on.
Everybody in!
Come on in!
Oh, there we go.
There you go.
You guys are in.
Okay!
This is me putting in the coordinates!
Oh, audio doco.
Sorry.
This is me putting in the coordinates!
Yes!
Oh, I almost have it.
Hold on, I'm a little clumsy.
Yes!
Oh.
Boom.
You messed it up.
No, I didn't.
Oh, my God, we're at the eye.
There it is.
The eye.
The eye of the universe.
We're seeing it.
Together.
Oh, get there faster.
No, we're savoring this moment.
Whoa.
We're on the...
That's heavy.
I can't do it.
I can't fly.
It's too heavy.
Just a lot of breathing.
Mints, you're so good.
Thank you.
You just seem kind of bad here.
Yes, yeah, this is Minto gaming.
Quantum fluctuations everywhere.
I'm just making sure.
Look up?
Oh, sorry, I can't do that right now.
I'm into gaming.
Oh, it's too dark.
Oh, quantum!
Oh, everything is quantum right now.
Oh, this part was so freaky.
Gamers don't look up.
Exactly!
I didn't even flinch.
I'm so...
I'm so brave.
I'm so brave!
Oh.
Oh!
No hesitation.
Oh.
I'm in the cheese!
Maybe I wasn't supposed to go in here.
Hold on, I'm leaving.
No, I was.
I'm supposed to go up into the space.
I'm supposed to go up.
I'm supposed to jump into that.
Into the eye, baby!
Yeah!
I'm tempted to watch the game and beat it faster.
Shut the hell up.
Music is so dramatic.
Oh, all of them.
Horn fells.
Feltspar.
Everybody's gone.
Everything's gone.
All of our friends.
Yeah.
Whoa.
The evolution of Ghost Rider.
A ghost gamer.
No, I will credit this person in the description.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'll credit them.
Text missed.
Whoa!
There it goes.
There goes the universe.
I can hear crickets.
I don't remember this happening in Interstellar.
There was a spooky part in this.
I remember.
Sorry for the quality.
The bit rate.
I remember I got jumped scared by a fish here.
Wow, it's so beautiful.
Sorry for the bitrate.
You know.
Wow!
Oh, it's dead.
Wow, another universe!
Oh, I just destroyed it.
Oh my god.
I'm...
I am... out of control.
There are people living there!
No!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I just can't help but destroy everything.
I'm a monster.
What's wrong with me?
Why am I like this?
It's because I didn't get enough love.
And no Elp.
If I have no Elp, no one can.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Am I going to get jump scared?
I'm scared.
Wait.
The bit rate is so bad.
Quantum Rock.
Let's go.
gone.
There was a rock here.
It's gone now.
I was a certified Elper, but never a spoiler.
Incoming mouth breather?
It's me!
It's you.
It's always you.
Everything learn new.
It's me.
Shoot your scout at him.
I did that!
I shot my scout!
And he turned into a tree.
Oh!
And then...
It all comes back to marshmallows, huh?
Wait, is there a fish?
Please.
No fish!
Ghost!
Ghost, ghost.
Whoa!
I mean, technically, yeah.
Esker!
Do you hear music?
I do really love this ending.
If it wasn't such a pain in the neck to have gotten to it in
this playthrough, I would have done it.
Oh, for sure.
Stop flashing the...
Gosh.
Oh, you have to do that.
Evangel.
It's one of the most fulfilling moments.
It is.
It's so good.
It's such a such a good ending.
It's not quite time yet.
Pretty sure you'll need the others for the next part.
No rush.
Take your time.
The quiet shade.
Oh gosh.
There's a fish.
It's always dark.
Whoa.
There we go.
is does this ending have the prisoner it does yeah i i made
sure
that push looked like shrek
backseating a video but also being wrong about what she's
backseating is crazy what are you talking about what am i
wrong oh because no i just didn't want him to flash it so
vigorously
Whee!
We're traveling!
Oh, this is a video.
No, it's not.
It's Minto Gaming.
Ha ha ha.
Solanum.
Come here, you.
my friend I wonder I'm curious how we get the prisoner
I hate that part
I hate that part very brave
why is this is this him how did this become iron lung is
this the strange
Yeah, it's a tree.
Oh, oh!
Right here, right here.
Oh,
here we go.
Oh.
The ground is opening up.
So cool!
Oh, it's literally like they're coughing.
Wait, look at the pictures.
Oh, that's me!
Oh my god, wait!
That's not me.
Don't know why.
There's other candles.
Oh, they're gone in the pictures.
Oh, they're gone.
That's me.
Extinguishing each species.
Oh, God, don't turn around!
It's literally a tombstone.
Connection with Scout is lost.
There he is.
You're allowed.
Come join the party.
When my kind found the eye and realized that what it was
capable of, they were terrified.
It was too difficult a truth.
like a light too bright to look upon directly it burned them
what they could not unlearn was hidden away in darkness
obfuscated then lost my kind weren't always like this they
weren't always so afraid i did what i could to set things
right yeah i am still of my kind and you know now what they
did i cannot promise our fear won't stay in your mind and so
a choice are you and you want to remember me.
We're...
Join us!
I don't want to repeat my kind's mistakes.
But if you're willing to take the risk, then so be it.
What if I told him that his journey ended here?
It would be so sad, though, to not have him around.
Everybody's here!
We've come this far, might as well join.
Right.
His song sounds so sad, even.
Oh!
Church particularly stumps people that never use the single
scope.
Yeah, I could get that.
I think it even stumped me for a minute.
What do you say?
Harmonica!
I hadn't dared to hope that anyone would hear the signal for
how briefly I set it free, yet here we are.
Are you ready for the final step?
Then it's time!
Time to send our spark out into the darkness!
Oh, it's so sad!
It's...
It sounds like, um...
The thing you use with your hands.
This song is new to me, but I'm honored to be part of it.
There I'm in.
Yes, thank you.
We still have two more people.
Come on.
Thanks for the endurance stream.
This is the best I've been able to understand and follow
along with the story because of it being in one stream.
I wasn't smart enough to beat the bass game.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, of course.
They're creating the new universe.
What a coward throwing away the marshmallow.
How dare you?
I forgot this wasn't you.
It's okay, the immersion, you know?
Hopefully we've reached the end of our journey.
All that remains is to cloud.
Are you ready to learn what comes next?
I admire your curiosity, my friend.
How beautiful.
It's different than I envisioned.
Whatever happens next, I do not think is to be feared.
Brand, thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you.
Yippee!
My eyes!
We were stuck in darkness for so long.
you guys get used to it
there's still so much time I wonder if it's just the credits
Outer Wild
Is the thing after the credits also new Such a beautiful
game I know
Thoughts on the DLC?
Oh my god, I loved it.
Loved it so much.
Jaffer!
Yeah!
Loved it so much.
If you stayed around the mothership, you can observe the
elk's cloaking device.
Oh, cool.
Maybe the ending would be...
from the DLC.
I didn't realize it would like be...
I mean, I guess it makes sense, right?
Because the ending of the game is just the destruction of
the universe and the creation of a new one!
So...
Um, but it's so cool.
So awesome.
I think the DLC...
Um...
Added, like, such a good...
additional story to the overall plot and I like the way that
they told the story differently before you know it was all
like through text and then this time you have the you had
the visual which I'm a visual person so it was much easier
for me to understand yeah the imagery so good really adds a
whole new story Yeah, meshes perfectly with the existing
one.
I know!
Oh, Kukwai.
Providing another perspective on how people react to their
own mortality as well as connecting the thoughts of how the
Nomai found the signal and why it disappeared.
Yeah, right.
It was a very, very good, very neat tie together.
Tie it, you know.
It was a really awesome home.
I like the contrast between the Nomai and the Strangers'
Inhabitants.
The Strangers are so scary!
The Nomai, we're like, we're so chill.
Oh my gosh.
Nixie!
Thank you for the hug, I was so much.
It's my favorite game and you did great.
I was surprised several times by how quickly you solved
certain puzzles.
I agree the DLC really adds something new.
Congratulations on finishing it.
Thank you.
I think the coolest part is like, you know, the whole time
in the...
One of my favorite things was the whole time the original
game you had the ability to doze by the fire and then that
becomes a key mechanic in the DLC it's just so cool it's
just so so cool all
knowledge should be preserved for the future and the Elks
were not that the Elks you know Yeah, the elk saw their
demise and we're just like, now we're packing it up.
Get out of here.
Nope.
No, we're not doing this.
Nope, no, no.
So.
The area that teaches you how to doze by the fires right
next to the radio building where you start the DLC.
That's so crazy.
The elk were so...
I feel like they were very...
Realistically written.
I feel like, you know, if a species were to see that, and
also to leave their home planet and everything, I feel like
it would, you know, it feels very realistic.
And their responses were, you know, what I would expect.
Congrats on finishing another amazing journey, man.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
They embodied fear, yet they were the most afraid.
Thank you for playing Outer Wild!
Owks.
Super sympathetic.
Yeah, yeah.
14.3 billion years later.
S11, thank you for the 10 gift.
After Doom 64, will you play Doom 3?
Probably eventually.
Creation of new planets.
And New creatures.
Yeah, campfire!
Oh!
So cool!
They did meet again somehow.
Okay, ignore that.
Thank you to Humphreys for your full playthrough of the
ending.
Appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Some iteration of them survive, let's go!
Why are they so scary?
Don't judge a book by its cover!
Okay, I'm just gonna quit to the main menu then.
Oh, my controller disconnected.
Yippie, and congrats on finishing the journey, Minto!
Thank you!
What's the video?
Just the ending.
I would have imagined the whole thing was a video.
Just imagine if I just was like, by the way, guys, get got.
Oh, but.
But I really would have done the ending if it wouldn't take
another, I don't know, crazy amount of time for me because I
would have to go to so many places and get so much more
stuff.
I wish I I wish I had played on my original game.
I wish I had played my original game.
But, uh, that's okay.
I still wouldn't have remembered how to get there or do
anything.
But it's okay.
That's okay, it's okay.
That's my mistake.
thought I could just, you know, I thought with what I got
before, and, um, and, uh, you know, I thought it would be, I
thought it would have been different, hard to know.
Yeah, pretty much, so, mm-mm.
Look up the new giant's deep easter egg for giggles.
Someone said that there was a Steinsgate easter egg, is that
true?
It was Jeffrey.
No!
Well, thank you guys for joining me for this.
I didn't expect it to be so spooky.
I may have added one.
Where is it?
Giant seed?
Easter egg.
I can now go to the Outer Wilds Wiki and look without any
fear.
I can now look.
with no fear.
Yee-wee!
Uh, I'm seeing...
I don't see it under the Easter eggs.
Uh-oh, someone's slacking.
Wasn't that added?
It's a new one.
Time to join the Outer Wild Sickos Discord.
It's really new.
Wait, how new are we talking?
Hold on, let me go to the...
I'm going to the...
Store page.
Oh, oh, sorry, you can hear probably the video.
Um...
Wait.
Thank you, Gao!
GG, GG, GG, GG.
I just noticed the achievement I got from getting killed by
the pursuers called Ufouch My Bones.
bread thank you wait oh mr yura thank you oh my gosh wait
hold on thank you mr yura i see the elk owls is the opposite
of the no-mai instead of pressing forward and facing danger
they regress and hit in the past the dlc has a core message
about fear and overcoming it to make progress which is what
you had to do as a player too oh my gosh so deep oh fouch my
bones bread i think it might take a while before you're
things comes up.
So thank you.
Congrats on finishing echoes.
It was a blast.
This in Doom really cheered me up these past two weeks.
Thanks for picking it up.
You really cooked.
I can't believe I can't believe you guys said you have to
cook and it was to cook.
I actually had to cook.
I had to cook to be cooked.
You guys are secret geniuses maybe too.
You guys are maybe secret geniuses as well
to suggest that
10 hour stream
just a bit of help
it's almost 1am I have to take my cat to the vet at 8am I
need to shower Brain cooked.
My brain is cooked.
And then, I think tomorrow...
I don't know how long Doom will take me.
But I'm on a bit of a time limit since I have something to
do that night.
And, uh...
Uh, and then...
Saturday, Metal Gear.
Probably, like, 10 minutes trust.
Actually, I watched a Dacino video.
I was like...
I've watched the Sino video about the BFG.
Which I've watched him before.
So if you're familiar with him.
That guy does like a bunch of Doom videos and stuff.
Good night, man.
Good night, everybody.
Thank you if you're heading out.
But I still don't understand the BFG.
Like I understand it, but I don't understand it.
So I actually have no idea.
what to do tomorrow probably we'll watch another uh or watch
it's like uh what's it called a playthrough see what they do
have a great night you guys as well you guys as well hold on
i kind of want to keep listening to this congrats and good
night man thank you hold on sorry you guys give me a second
give me a second give me a second oh there it is i think I
think?
Give me a second.
One second.
Thank you for all the super chats.
Thank you for all the donos.
Really, really, really, really, really, really, really,
really, really, really, really, really, really, really,
really,
really, thank you for the Endurance Dream.
Thank you, guys, for...
watched it all day or if you joined in the middle or even if
you just joined now or even if you just watched at the very
beginning.
I hope you guys had fun.
Sorry for my frustration in the middle but we persevered.
We persevered and we made it.
I skipped work for this?
No way.
I'm glad you got to play through the DLC.
Thanks for streaming and thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Thank you.
Okay.
I'm gonna go to sleep now.
And I suggest you guys as well!
Otaminto!
And I'll see you guys tomorrow.
I have karaoke in the morning.
Morning?
Afternoon?
And yeah.
Excited.
Well, I'll do karaoke for a little bit and then I'll make a
waiting room for Doom as soon as I don't know.
I don't know how long I'll do for karaoke.
As soon as I'm done, I'll make a waiting room for Doom.
And, uh, yeah.
Okay!
Osaminto, everybody!
Thank you for the stream!
Thank you!
Thanks for letting me, uh...
do the ending by just watching it.
I know some people are like, it doesn't feel the same,
but...
Like I said, I've already done it before.
So...
You know, I'm not gonna get that feeling back.
or whatever okay i'm gonna i'm gonna quit stalling thank you
for the thank you for the super chat what did it say oh
endurance stream with the oh she was not to love oh yeah
okay ozuminto everybody thank you have a good night see you
guys tomorrow bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
I said it, oh, I said so, I said so.
Woo, woo, woo, woo.
Yippee, weird.
Oh my gosh, you're gonna like it so much.
They're crazy.
Thanks for dropping by.
I appreciate it.
Okay, bye.